I need
baby
baby.
I need
I feel I feel I
need
Ladies and gentlemen, welcome to the AI
Engineer Worlds Fair. We're excited to
kick off an incredible few days of
inspiring keynotes, technical insights,
and conversations with leaders across
the AI community. Please join me in
welcoming co-founder of AI Engineer and
editor at Leighton Space, Swix.
>> Wow.
How y'all doing? Welcome to World's
Fair.
Let's switch to slides and uh I'm going
to kick off the the stage. I'm really
honored to welcome all of you um to
basically the biggest gathering of AI
engineer we've ever had. Um I think it's
interesting to talk and think about what
we're all doing here today. So um I hope
that we have the slides up. I can't
actually see whether whether my slides
are up. Uh we do need to make sure this
thing is all right. Cool.
Um in the beginning there was the token.
Then there was the chat.
Then we learned to use tools.
Then we learned to set goals. I'm
skipping a few steps.
And these days we're all about
automations. We're all about cron jobs
and loops
and the rest of today on this live
stream. Uh the uh those of you watching
at home, uh we're going to be talking
about software factories as well. So
there's a lot of loop stacking. Uh I
wrote this essay called Loopcraft. Uh I
think Joel in the audience did a
workshop on it yesterday. Can you still
hear me? Are we good? Sorry, I I um had
a mic slip. Um and I think this is
something that is basically a core skill
of AI engineer. Uh is defining what
loops you're working in and figuring out
whether that's the right level of
extraction and when you're ready going
up a loop in order to figure out the
next level in productivity and scaling
your inference. and when you're finding
issues going down a loop and going lower
level in order to figure out reliability
and fixing whatever bugs you you find.
If you want to simplify it, uh I have a
I have a better analogy that will be
less complicated. Uh it's literally just
a stack of wild loops, right? I think
all of you in in the audience and
programmers will understand this. Uh and
effectively this is what we're here to
do today. We're um I expect our
engineers, our leaders, our researchers,
our founders um to all be understanding
and rehearsing as a as a as a sort of
human general intelligence all these
loops that you guys are capable of of um
going up and down. And that is why
there's so much content.
Um I often tell people who who complain
about the tracks, I'm not going to
apologize for good content. uh it's up
to you to decide and route yourself uh
as to which level you currently working
at and which level you're currently
blocked on. Um
so the thing that's occupying most of my
time um recently and what I what I make
the human analogy for is what is the
human loop? Um and in the beginning
there's a heartbeat when you when you're
sort of in the womb you you sort of get
that heartbeat that is the proof of
life. Um then you learn to talk.
Then we learn to use tools.
Then we start to work. We eat, sleep,
code, repeat or prompt.
Um and then we start working in teams.
We start working in small groups and
families. We we've uh promoted the
concept of tiny teams before and I think
that is increasingly important with uh
everybody. Um and I think the
interesting thing to think about is like
the broader human projects as a whole
like where are we all going you know
extend out from your personal context
your family your country your company
whatever um to the broader project of
the human civilization and what we're
building uh with collective intelligence
uh I think it's very interesting to uh
consider that so um I I think that's a
little bit what I want to leave you with
today like the things that you're doing
with coding are definitely crossing over
to human life. Um the message of my last
keynote at AI engineer was that the you
know it's very much like agents that you
see are working in one domain are
definitely generalizing this year. Um
this is the year that we're adding
vertical tracks like you know AI in
healthcare, AI in finance, AI in GTM uh
we have a four deployed engineering
track this uh today which I'm very
excited about. Um all of this is meant
to see how AI is just diffusing finally
beyond coding.
Okay. Um last world fair I give you all
an update on the stress curves uh of the
of the the organizers. Uh just to give
you an idea this is um the first world
uh first AI engineer in 2023. Uh this is
sort of the sales curves basically of
like how people bought. Basically it was
kind of linear. Then we had the first
world fair 2024.
uh about 2,000 people. 2025
uh was uh I think I maybe skipped uh
skipped a few lines, but we're we're
basically at 6,000. Um and if you sort
of calculate uh sorry, we we we we aimed
for 6,000. We actually crossed and going
went to 7,000 today. Um and basically I
asked you all to buy your tickets
earlier. We did not. Um
uh if you measure the Jenny coefficient,
uh it has gone up and not down. That's
the wrong direction. Um so if you all if
you all can just gather uh you know your
yourselves and um you know join us
earlier I think that would be great.
Anyway um why we want to work at a
conference why we why I work on a
conference why you all come to a
conference is basically the concept of
the highest loop. Um I I will submit to
you that the highest loop of all is to
uh if I can make this slide work. Oh my
god
I'm gonna refresh. Okay. um uh that the
highest loop is where humans come
together to figure out what the next
loop is, right? The loop that makes
loops. Um so we organize a engineer
summits all around the world. Uh this
year we have summits in New York,
summits in Paris, summits in Singapore.
Um and uh you know again Melbourne and
I'm forgetting one already Miami. Um and
uh we organize this as partners. We want
you to organize it in your own home
countries. We're we're hiring a
partnerships team uh to do this and this
is the highest loop of all which is the
world's fair which is the summit of
summits. So you're I'm very excited to
welcome all of you today. Um I hope that
you figure out your generative process
for generating loops and propagate it
down to your teams to your personal
workflows to your lives. Thank you very
much and enjoy the show.
Hello and welcome. Wow, look at the size
of this audience. This is incredible. A
engineer has grown twice the size
compared to last year and our expo is
four times the size. Thank you to each
and every one of you for being a part of
this community. Today we have 18
different tracks of content ranging from
breakout tracks, keynotes,
and expo sessions across all of our time
here and all of these different
sessions. Today I'm super excited to
introduce today's mainstage track called
Software Factories.
A year ago, Jeffrey Huntley released the
Ralph Loop. It captured our attention
and sparked our imagination as we saw
the Ralph Loop work autonomously
overnight on our behalf and create
entire products on its own. However, in
the early days, it wasn't perfect.
The Ralph loop came recommended for
green field work only, and it came with
the expectation that it would get you
about 90% of the way there. Over the
last year, we've learned a lot and
there's been considerable amount of
advancements made across the industry,
which makes now the single largest
inflection point for software factories.
Model vision has improved, allowing
models to see and verify work they
couldn't have previously.
We also have access to far richer tool
ecosystems, allowing agents to access
real production data that they couldn't
have previously.
We've also watched context windows and
memory improve, allowing agents in loops
to track work that's been done before.
Reasoning models and capabilities have
improved, allowing models to take on
more sophisticated tasks.
Also, AI security best practices have
emerged, allowing models and allowing
agents to have the security, autonomy,
and capability they need to do real
meaningful work within the enterprise.
All of this comes together now.
Software factories are no longer a
vision for the future. They become a
practical reality. Today's speakers are
on the forefront of this shift, and
they're going to help us separate what's
real from what's hype. what actually
works in practice and how to build
software factories that produce real
results, not SLOB. So, I'm very excited
to introduce our very first speaker.
His talk is titled on AI and Knowledge.
He's a CVP and distinguished engineer at
Microsoft. Please welcome to the stage
Pablo Castro.
Now taking the stage is CVP and
distinguished engineer at Microsoft,
Pablo Castro.
Hello everyone.
Hello everyone. Good morning.
It's great to be back here at the AI
engineer world's fair.
Now my job at Microsoft is to connect
the dots between AI and knowledge. as an
information retrieval nerd like that's
great for me like I spend a lot of time
on looking at knowledge representation
extraction search and whatnot
and thinking about agents and knowledge
really invites to reflect on you know
what it means to know something and uh
you know the the the nature of how do we
get things done based on what we know.
Next slide.
All right,
there. So this morning, what I thought
we would do is spend a little bit of
time talking about the nature of
knowledge and split it into these three
categories of intrinsic, extrinsic, and
learned.
Intrinsic knowledge is just the
knowledge that comes with the models.
you know, it's what we uh train the
models on the training data and what um
uh stored in the models kind of
parametric memory. And while it's kind
of the obvious thing, I would argue this
is the knowledge that actually threw us
into the exponential we are in today.
It's what started many of the scenarios
that then grew on all the things we're
doing with agents today.
Let me give you an example with code. So
I wrote these two pieces of code about
25 years apart and yet the process to
put this thing together was surprisingly
similar. Like I had to s sit down with
what I knew or what I I had to go look
up and um and then just write it up. And
uh while you know I'm illustrating this
with knowledge, you could say the same
thing about you know writing an email or
creating a summary of a document. Now
you can see this exponential at play in
tasks like these where you know I'm sure
you can go further back but an
interesting point in time to start
looking at this would be when Microsoft
introduced IntelliSense. That was in 96
and you know it was great. You didn't
have to remember function signatures
anymore and whatnot. It takes 22 years
from there to go uh for the next step
where machine learning helps us actually
rank the options we give you in
IntelliSense so it's quicker to pick the
right choice. just three years after
that GitHub copilot launches and that
was one key inflection point. This was
even before Chad GPT um was announced
and you know I would argue that GitHub
copilot chpt that sort of experiences
were heavily grounded on this intrinsic
memory what the models already knew from
there of course things shifted you know
a couple of years later cursor launches
GitHub copilot X launches and how we do
things kind of evolve really quick which
takes us to kind of late last year Opus
4.5 ships and then in rapid succession
you know GPT OPU and other models keep
getting embedded and bettered at coding
which takes us to early this year where
incredibly successful uh software like
like open claw uh comes out to existence
with not a single line of code written
by hand. So this is the shape of the
exponential weing and a lot of this was
powered by the by the uh intrinsic
knowledge in models and of course the
ability to reason.
Now in the context of Microsoft, we want
to make available all these models and
make it easy for you to integrate them
into the agents you're building. We do
this from our agent platform that starts
in GitHub where we all go and build has
a contextualization system so you can
ground your agents. And when it comes to
agent hosting, observability and
management, we all do all of these in
Foundry. Microsoft Foundry is also where
we uh offer uh thousands of models in
our model catalog. So you can pick
whatever is the right uh model for the
right task and we keep adding more every
day. In fact, just yesterday we
announced uh that cloud in Microsoft
Foundry is generally available. So you
can use all the capabilities of cloud uh
in the context of the kind of unified
experience in Foundry. So you get best
of both worlds.
Now, intriguing model got us here, but
it only gets you so far if you're
building a system that or an agent that
needs to participate in what's happening
in an organization or a company. uh and
you know as an industry we realized this
early and we you know we saw the the rag
pattern emerge that started as a pretty
low tech uh technique but quickly
evolved and what we do today with
context engineering uh and you know it
became a pretty sophisticated system for
connecting agents and the knowledge they
need to get their job done.
Of the many dimensions of of which this
got kind of complicated, I'm going to
pick on two. One is kind of the
evolution from simple and isolated data
sets to whole companywide grounding and
the other one is how we started with
simple vector search and whatnot and we
really saw this evolve into fairly
complicated retrieval systems. So let's
start with company grounding. Like at
Microsoft, you know, spending time with
customers, one of the things we saw
early was that whenever you build an
agent, you you always have the knowledge
you care about for that agent and you'll
manage that yourself. But you also need
to ground the agent often on the kind of
ambient data of your organization, you
know, whenever the agent leaves. This
includes maybe your documents, your
emails, your chat, uh threads or uh the
information in your data warehouse and
whatnot. So we built Microsoft IQ as a
way to give you a single entry point
into all these kind of ambient data that
agents need to get the job done in
addition to the specific information
that you build into the agent. Microsoft
IQ is not one feature. is more like a
set of capabilities that goes from work
IQ that connects your agents to all the
documents in say SharePoint, all the
emails, calendar, your chats and the
connections between people uh to fabric
IQ that gives you access to all the all
your analytics assets you know from data
warehouses and data links to PowerBI
reports and Foundry IQ which is what you
use for your or agents where you can
push your own data and then use it for
grounding and of course sometimes you
have uh your agents need to go out to
the web to uh ground on data that maybe
not yours is public information but uh
but you need to uh use it to comp
complete the picture of what the agent
world's view is and for that we have uh
web IQ.
Now this first part allows agents to
ground on the kind of this ambient data.
Now the second dimension I mentioned
before is the evolution of the actual
retrieval systems. you know, when Reg
first emerged, I think, you know, what
we saw is like an initial adoption for
uh vector databases that really
unblocked us from uh getting a lot of
these systems off the ground. And that
was great. Um I think, you know, for a
hot second as an industry, we thought
that if we could get really really good
at computing cosign similarity between
vectors, we were all set for retrieval.
It turns out, you know, things never are
never that easy. Uh so you know what
evaluations show over and over again is
how you know if you combine methods you
just get better results like in this
case this is an evaluation from Ashrai
search the search technology behind
Foundry IQ and uh and you can see how
individual methods don't do as well as
combined methods particularly when you
apply them to uh real world customer
scenarios. Now the trick is how do you
build a platform that allows you to
combine all these building blocks
without putting the complexity right in
front of you like let you opt into it
when you need control but when you have
a scenario that is clear then you can
have an easy system.
So in Foundry IQ that was one of our
core design goals and uh the way we do
this is we actually layer the system. So
you can start at the top. You can go to
Foundry and say, "Hey, I have a bunch of
I don't know PDFs or pictures over
there. Just deal with them and then
we'll do everything under the covers. Do
like chunking, vectorization, deal with
relevance and ranking, deal with agentic
retrieval and whatnot." Now, if you're
an expert and you want control, you can
also do that. You can go to the bottom
of the stack, you want to build vector
indexes and tell us how to quantize the
vectors or control lexical retrieval and
whatnot, you can do all of that. And you
can do it in the same stack which means
you can go up and down as you as your
needs change.
Now
on on top of the core retrieval system,
we also introduced an agentic retrieval
stack because we see that for easy cases
like you know quick singleshot retrieval
is great but for more sophisticated
cases you do want a system that uh can
reflect on on what's in the data set and
decide whether or not we've satisfied
the information need stated in the input
before we come back with results. Of
course, we see a lot of patterns like
this emerge and the always the question
is is this actually useful like are the
results better? Our experience in our
own evaluations is uh for for difficult
cases agentic retrieval can make a
difference across the many metrics that
we we track you know things like um the
actual evidence recall or answer
completeness we see like the agentic
retrieval approach continuously does
better than than simple that's uh
individual simple parts. Now, let me
show you some of this in action. If we
can go to the laptop.
Can we switch to the laptop?
There you go.
So here I'm in I'm in foundry and uh
foundry is where you you manage your
agents, manage models but also the place
where you can manage all the knowledge
that you give your agents in order to uh
do their jobs. Um when here you can you
can create knowledge bases as the kind
of the entry point of any agents into
the knowledge you care about. In this
case I'll create a knowledge base. I
have a data set about movies. These are
agentic retrieval systems. So I'll give
it a model to power the retrieval
workflow and I can say how much effort
you want the model to uh to make or the
system to make and this is effectively a
trade-off between latency and and
quality. I can configure a number of
other things but critically I want to
say where the data I want to ground is
coming from and uh I can start from
scratch or in this case I have a bunch
of unstructured data like PDFs and
whatnot in in blob storage. I have a
structure you know parket tables with
statistics and I also want to ground on
the web. So if I take these three steps
and then I save this knowledge base now
I have this asset this knowledge base
that I can connect to an Foundry agent
right here and it'll take a second uh
but also it's a standalone asset that if
I have already a harness that I'm using
in other in other places every knowledge
base is an MCP server so you can just
connect to it without having to write
any glue code in the middle. Now a
knowledge base like this has uh you know
has a bunch of parts. Some of them like
for example this uh storage uh content
you usually build indexes uh and you you
know vectorize these things and whatnot.
Uh and if you want control over that
like if I if you don't you can just use
it here. But if you do, let me just
switch to Ashure and show you the
service behind that particular instance
where if I go to knowledge bases. This
is the knowledge base we just created a
second ago. And I can go pick inside for
example I can go fish out the indexes
that back this particular uh piece of
content. And in that index I can see
what is the structure of the index. Uh
if I'm opinionated about I don't know
maybe the quantization uh approach I
want to use or which indexing algorithm
I want for my vectors. I can say all of
that. And of course I can actually go
and explore the data and you know see
what's inside how chunks were organized
and and whatnot. So the goal of this is
to again give you high product a highly
productive environment when you need uh
when you don't need uh the
sophistication and when you need it to
make sure you have it to get your job
done. Go back to slides.
And of course the other aspect of this
is you know top of mind these days for
all of us is token uh is token
efficiency and uh so uh we carefully
evaluate this system to make sure that
we give you the most information dense
answer that has the fewest tokens uh so
that you you know the the your
consumption of tokens has a high value
when it comes to all retrieval tasks.
The last category of knowledge I wanted
to talk about is learned knowledge. Now
learn knowledge is the result of us
doing the work we do as individuals and
as organizations every day and the the
idea that we can actually observe the
processes and get better at them by
reflecting and improving every step of
it is something that is really uh
changed now that we have agents doing
the work and we can go tune the agents
automatically.
Satia wrote about this recently and
reflected on the fact that people and
agents can really compound in in how
they do the work and how they can create
this learning loop that uh effectively
captures what's unique about the company
or or the organization you're working on
uh and and puts that to work to
differentiate the work that you do. Now
in Foundry we wanted to offer like a
material a materialized version of this
that you can use today. So we built a a
component called the agent optimizer
that effectively goes through this
process and allows you to evaluate a
baseline, generate candidates and then
you know evaluate the new candidates and
we have a strong result then deploy that
to production. Let me give you kind of a
quick flavor of what this looks like if
we can switch back to the laptop.
All right. So here I'm in VS Code. I
have the foundry uh toolkit installed
and uh I have a simple agent. It doesn't
matter how you write your agent as long
as you externalize configuration like
you know your instructions, tool
definitions, skills and whatnot. So once
you have one of those it takes two key
steps to do this. So first
whoops
um I can actually so usually you have an
evaluation already but if you don't you
can actually say eval generate and what
we'll do is we'll look at what we know
about the agent like traces and
instructions and whatnot and we'll
produce a task adherance focused
evaluation for you. In this case I ran
this a little bit earlier. So just to
give you a flavor of what this looks
like, you you have a bunch of tasks and
then you know the questions and the
criteria and whatnot.
Once you have a data set you can
evaluate then what the next step is you
can say
uh optimize and uh I could just run
optimize on its own and that will run in
this case this run for maybe 45 minutes
or so and you get an optimized version
by effectively hill climbing the metric
that's established from the evaluation.
Um so I ran this earlier and so let me
show you the output for this particular
one where you can see that you know we
established the baseline first and then
we kept iterating on candidates using
different combinations using a JPA style
kind of loop uh and uh looking for
options that perform better given uh the
rubric that we have. And uh the
interesting thing is that once you found
one that is that is better then you can
simply just say optimize apply. And what
this does is since you externalize the
configuration, it allows you to swap one
configuration for the other. Um if I if
we look here, you can see that for
example I have a baseline and the one we
just applied and just to pick on
instructions. These are just the trivial
instructions for this example agent. But
if I look at the optimized one, then you
can see like a bunch of instructions
that are not handwritten, but that they
emerged out of the hill climbing process
to get to make this particular um agent
better given what we have in terms of
instructions and skills and tools, but
also based on reflecting on the actual
uh traces from the agent as users are
using it. So this is a real learning
loop materialized in practice. Can go
back to slides.
So this was like a very quick overview
about how do we think about knowledge in
the context of AI and how do how we
think we can enable this learning loops
that will capture you know this
differentiated capability that lives in
each one of the companies and
organizations we work on. If you want to
try anything of what I talked about or
showed today, you can head to
ai.ashure.com
and get going. And with that, thank you
all for listening this morning. I hope
you have a great rest of the event.
Thanks.
Please join me in welcoming the head of
enterprise product and the head of
developer experience at OpenAI,
Alexander Emiricos and Roman Huitt.
>> Wow.
Good morning everyone.
I'm Roman. Hey everyone, I'm Alexander.
>> Wow, this room is incredible. There's
over over 7,000 AI engineers here today
with us. And you know, it's not just
about who's talking about this
technology. It's also about who's
actually using it and pushing the
frontier every day. So, we couldn't be
more proud to be here with all of you
today. And when we were thinking about
this event with Alex, we kept coming
back to the World's Fair. You know if we
can advance one slide
mine work all right we're great coming
back to the world's fair and the world's
fair actually in the future visible to
everyone by building it in public you
know ideas that previously sounded
impossible were actually suddenly there
people could see them they could walk
into them and they could even start to
believe in them and honestly this event
has the exact same energy the future of
engineering is not arriving from
somewhere else. It's really being built
here by the people in this room and much
faster than most expected.
And that's why it's a little surprising
that people keep saying that engineers
are going away. The argument is that
coding is, you know, abstracted away and
therefore eventually we won't need
engineers. Well, in fact, we think it's
quite the opposite.
You know, software ate the world and
then AI ate software. But now what we're
here to say is that the AI engineers are
eating the world. AI engineers are the
people here pushing the frontier. Yes.
And you all are figuring out how this
new capability can reach everyone.
And there has never been a better time
to be an engineer. In fact, because
engineering was never about writing
code. Engineering has always been about
solving problems for yourself and for
other people as well. It's about taking
the latest science and combining it with
design, with taste, with judgment, and
most of all, imagination to make
something that people can actually use.
And in that sense, it's not the end of
engineering. We think it's a return to
the roots of engineering.
And the technology we're building on is
accelerating, getting faster and faster.
For example, we used to ship a new model
every 15 months or so, and now it's
about roughly every six weeks. And in
case you missed it, last week we
launched a preview of the 5.6 series,
and we're super excited to get into all
of your hands. Now, building on top of
all these models, the rate of product
progress is relentless. And as a result,
I don't have to tell you, the
engineering feels completely different.
So, just to go over a couple years of
what for me were successive like
mind-blowing experiences. You know,
obviously for a long time we've had, you
know, completion and then we went to
inline prediction and then finally we
had then we had command K where you
could ask a model to make a change but
they wouldn't test the work. Then models
started testing the work and now we have
models taking on long hard goals until
they're done. And for me each of these
phases I remember the first time was
just mind-blowing and then obviously
afterwards you just get used to it and
you're trying to get your work done.
>> Yeah. In fact like I can't believe that
build and test loop was not even part of
the models just two years ago. This was
a picture of me at dev day 2024 and I
used 01 in preview at the time to build
a mini drrome drone interface from
scratch. And the slightly insane part is
the model could not actually run the
code or verify its own work. And I knew
the demo would work most of the time,
but surely not all of the time. So I had
to cross my fingers. You can kind of see
here that I was pretty nervous, but hey,
that's me. I only do live demos, so I
never know what's actually going to
happen each time. Luckily, it did work.
And by dev day of last year in 2025, I
was confident enough now the models
could test their own work to kind of
control an entire camera system and
lighting system live. But yeah, we've
come a long way.
>> Yeah. So we refer to as the demo god and
you know before the demo like I'll ask
him so how often does demo work? He be
like you know three times out of four
and all right good luck. Um obviously
we've come miles since then and this
year alone has been crazy. So what we're
putting up here or here or somewhere u
are all the things that we've shipped so
far. No, actually not even all. A
selection of the things that we've
shipped so far this year. Actually, can
we go back one slide? Um, anyways, it
doesn't really matter. The point is, uh,
my favorite things that we've shipped
are like Codex app, goal mode, remote.
These are things that really changes how
it feels to do work. And so, you know,
obviously we couldn't do these things if
we didn't use codecs to build codecs.
But I think to me, what is most
interesting is that now codecs can do
and agents can do any task that you can
do on your own computer. And so that
means they're not just helping you with
the coding, but they're helping you with
what happens before the coding and
they're helping you with what happens
after the coding. And this is really
key, right? I think there's been a lot
of talk, there will be a lot of talk
today about loops. And if you can
connect the agent to not only the work
that you have to do, but why it has to
be done, that's how you can get the
agent to start to begin much more work.
And then if you can connect it to what
you do afterwards, review and deploy,
that's how you help it land much more
work. So with all of this, of course, we
can move much faster. But to me as a
product person, the most exciting thing
is actually that we make better
decisions around what to build. For
instance, we try we prototype many more
ideas and we spend much more time with
users. So yes, that's all of you. So
wanted to pause and just give you all a
big thank you both for the love and the
constructive feedback. I would say it's
safe to say that we Codeex and actually
the entire industry wouldn't be here
without you.
>> Yeah, thank you so much for all the
feedback. We're constantly listening to
all of you. Thank you.
Okay, so what's next? The models are
getting really good. I would say if you
pick like a medium length computer task
and you give me and the model the same
amount of time to get that task done,
probably at least in my case, the model
will do a better job than me for the
average task. And so, okay, we're we're
getting these models, you know, in some
ways they're smarter than us. They can
do almost anything. How should we shape
that? what should the product that we
use feel like? And so to answer that, we
look to our mission. The part of it here
that I've got up is, you know, AGI that
benefits all of humanity. And I think in
order to do this, there are two main
questions that I think about now. One is
how do we set up the agents to actually
do things in the world? So what can they
do? You know, gradually agents are
getting connected to more and more
things. Then where do they run? More on
that later. And then the other question
is how do we use these agents for us?
you know what what should the product
feel like around them? And for us, the
goal is squarely not to automate
engineers. Instead, the the product
shape that we want is one that maximally
empowers engineers. So, you know, if we
think about what that product shape is,
we actually think it's pretty simple. I
I read a lot of sci-fi and, you know,
watching superhero movies and I actually
think that the the simple ideas in there
are approximately right. So, there are
two modalities roughly. Chat, I actually
think I know some people think chat is
dead. I think chat is underrated. uh and
some kind of hands-on experience. So,
what you want is a single entity that
you can ask for help with anything,
anywhere. And then you want a sing a
powerful collaborative UI that you can
use when you want to inspect, steer, or
shape things yourself. And so, I had
Codeex image gen me an illustration of
this to help understand when you might
want to use these things. And so, my
analogy for you, yeah, I hope you like
the image gen. Uh my analogy for you
would be it's just like working with a
team. Most of the time you're just
talking about stuff and your team is
just doing stuff. You don't actually
want to watch over the shoulder or like
have to walk over to the workbench of
your teammate for every single unit of
work. Mostly you just want to talk and
let them cook. And then every now and
then you want to dig in and really dig
in all the way to the weeds of things
and dig into that problem together. And
for us as we build product, we have this
idea that we want to make it so that you
can retain this feeling of mastery of
the work that you're doing because
that's really powerful. We don't want to
make it feel like actually it's really
hard to like get to the details and like
you know disassemble the hardware in
this case. So the way that we're
bringing to this to life is just the
beginning but this is why we built the
Codex app. You get a very simple chat
interface that you can use for coding
and for anything else and you know you
can have a conversation and then go as
deep as you want. So, in the case here,
we have Roma's predicted score of this
upcoming World Cup match.
>> I hope I'm right. I hope I'm right.
We'll see.
>> Okay. Um, and what you can do here is
you could go in and you can point at a
very specific thing and say, "Hey, I
want you to make this change or you can
make this change yourself." And a fun
story here is that actually the Codex
app was quite a controversial project to
start. Um I remember pitching some of
you who I know are in the audience uh
this idea before we started and I was
told squarely like we I will never use
such a tool. I will never leave my
terminal uh or Vim or Emacs. Um but
actually those people are now using it
and even internally like within our team
there were a lot of questions like why
should we build this? People love the
CLI they love the IDE and it's a little
subtle but our take is that you can't
really build that collaborative
interface for any kind of work in a CLI.
It's mostly chat and then in an IDE the
order is wrong. So you're starting with
the code but now it's time to transition
to like working with teammates where you
chat first and you dig in when you need
it.
>> Totally. And we're moving really fast on
this on the product surface and the
model layer of course but we're also
trying to keep pace with all of you.
Right. Honestly half the time I open X I
see someone in this room doing something
that I had not realized Codex could
actually do. And honestly this is what
pioneers do. You guys experiment. You
set up tools for yourself, for your team
and in turn we get inspired. We learn
from you and eventually everyone
benefits and so we are helping uh uh you
are helping us figure out like what to
uh what to build next and also what the
future of engineering should look like.
But for that to work one thing that we
we really care about is that codec
cannot be a closed product that only
openai can improve. So we've
intentionally designed codecs as a set
of layers that anyone can build on and
we want to show you a little bit of that
stack today and how it it manifests.
First it starts with the model and
Alexander showed how quickly we're
progressing on models and you guys use
these models through the responses API
and guess what? This is how we build the
Codex app, right? We use the same models
through the same API and we actually are
building on the same thing that we give
to developers. And when Codex needs
something new, we always try to bake it
into the API first so you can benefit as
well. One example recently was
compaction. Codex needed a way to
compact long contexts for longunning
tasks and so we'll build that into the
API. So that means your agents can use
the same primitives that we built for
ourselves.
Moving on to the next layer, the Codex
harness is also open source. So you can
inspect it, you can fork it, you can
adapt it. And we also took the same
approach with agents MD. Instead of
reinventing a new file format uh for
codeex to follow instructions, we
thought let's pick a name that other
agents can actually use as well. The
models are the default in the in the
harness, the models from OpenAI, but
they're not hardcoded in there. So if
you want to use an open model and keep
the same agent loop, you can. And we
also bring this codeex harness into the
post-training process of our model. So
that means the models can learn to call
tools and navigate an environment that's
actually something that's open source.
Now take the open code team for
instance. They actually were able to
inspect how we have this like reference
implementation and they could reuse the
parts that make sense to them or change
entirely all the rest and make different
choices. I know for instance they were
trying to see how we did like sign in
with chat GPT and so they could look at
the code and and learn from it. And we
think it's better than having developers
reverse engineering how we build uh and
and how we launch.
But now let's say speaking of
subscriptions that we want to go a level
higher and how you bring this harness
into an app and how do you let people
sign in with their existing codec
subscription for instance? Well, it
turns out we had the same problem
ourselves because we wanted to build a
VS code extension and the codeex app and
we wanted to have a unified way to like
actually control this harness. So we
built apps server and we also made that
open source and the apps server is not
kind of a a community adapter. It's
really the path that we use for our own
products and you can use it too. Uh Tuma
for instance here aka Dimilian on X uh
he built his own native app for Codex
called Codex Monitor before we even
launched the Codex app because he could
build that uh using the app server and
now he works on our team and he actually
built uh Codex for iOS.
And moving up the stack at the app
layer, we also want to make sure that
innovation is not blocked on our own
ideas. And so we build extensible
primitives here uh like the inapp
browser that we showed on the screen and
plugins. So if you take for instance
browser use and computer use, these were
built as plugins using the same
extension points that we have available
for for all of you. And lastly, we also
recently built rosp specific plugins for
codec say to make it easier to to
customize for people who work in data
science or design for instance. And
these plugins are also open source. So
you can see under the hood and get
inspired from them if that's useful.
Our goal is really to keep making this
as open and flexible as we can. And the
best part is people can use their
existing subscription in more and more
places from Open Code, Pi, Droid,
OpenClaw to even Xcode and Jet Brains as
IDEs. And you can see how they're
becoming quite a meaningful part of how
people use these tools. And that's
really why we want to care about
building this open ecosystem with all of
you.
Thank you.
So really, if there's one thing I want
you to take away from this section and
this stack, it's this. We're not
building one system for OpenAI and a
second system that's simplified for
developers. At every layer, we actually
use the thing that we give to you. And
we want to thank all of you because
every time you fork the harness, every
time you find the edge of capabilities
of the models, it means we get to learn
and improve. And honestly, with 7,000 of
the finest AI engineers in this room
today, I'm confident that all of you
will define a lot of how we uh will
experience AI and how the world will
experience AI in the future. So, thank
you.
I want to give a shout out to whoever
over there is injecting it. That's you.
Okay. Thank you so much. Um so with all
of your help we are making agents
explosively useful. Um and so now the
question is how do we get value out of
them? And you know that's not token
maxing. We have a term for this that
maybe you use as well. I don't know is
it on screen? Value maxing. So you know
when we talk to engineering leaders most
of the conversation is about some themes
relating to the idea of value maxing. So
we're going to walk you through a few
common topics that come up. some things
where we've already made a lot of
progress and some things where actually
there's a lot more progress to still be
made. So the first one of these is cost
efficiency. Everyone wants frontier
intelligence. Pick your eight favorite
eval. You want the best model. So with
terminal bench here for instance, that's
GPT 5.6 SUL. And like I said, we can't
wait for you to have it. But okay, you
also want as much intelligence as you
can get. And that's where efficiency
comes in. Cost efficiency has been a
focus for us for quite some time and the
results are continuing to pay off. So
for example, GPD 5.6 Terra, I think it's
in like dark blue in there, brings GPD
5.5 level intelligence, but at half the
cost. And Luna there beats some pretty
notable models in this eval, but at only
$1 per million input tokens and $6 per
million output tokens. I'll leave it up
to you to compare those costs, but that
is insane value. Yeah, we we really
can't wait to uh to see all of you build
uh with GPT 5.6 and this new family of
models. Now, the next thing I want to
touch on is speed, right? GPT 5.3 Codex
Spark showed you what speed can unlock,
but we also know that you all want
frontier intelligence. You don't want to
have a model that's like not as great as
what you can operate at the very best.
Well, this is GPT 5.6 cell running on
Cerebras. The frontier intelligence at
now 750 tokens a second. We can't wait
to see what you can build with this next
month. And honestly, to put that in
perspective, this is kind of like having
a pretty substantial PR written in like
10 seconds. And it's not just about
getting one answer faster, right? It's
about what can you do with that speed.
You can think about an agent taking
different approaches, maybe like five or
six in parallel, maybe like, you know,
coming back and picking the best one in
the time it would have taken to not even
generate just one. So, we really can't
wait to see what that can unlock when
you have frontier intelligence, the very
best at that speed. It really starts to
feel less like waiting for an AI to
respond and much more like a co-orker
that's like already showing you the
results as it goes. Speaking of working
with co-workers, um, can I get a show of
hands? Who who is familiar with this
kind of site in offices?
Okay. Okay. Wow. A lot of you are very
well behaved. I see some people up
front. Um, so yeah, a lot of people are
keeping their laptops open so that
agents can keep working. And this is
funny, but you know what we really want
is to be able to shut our computers. Um,
and we want to be able to run many tasks
in parallel isolated on their own box.
Now, we've been actually aiming at this
from the start. Our first major launch
was Codex Cloud, and it is due for some
major upgrades coming soon. But better
yet, as we think about this, the future
shouldn't have this awkward distinction
between like a local task and a cloud
task and you have to decide where to run
everything. Really, what you should have
is kind of going back to what I was
saying earlier. You should just have an
agent. You talk to it wherever,
whenever, about anything, and it should
figure out, okay, what do I need to do?
Which environment is right for my work?
And use whatever is available.
In fact, Theo made this prediction over
the weekend on this very topic and it's
a pretty acute tweet. Like, Alex, what
do you think? Sooner or later than six
months? I think the not maybe not exact
details, but the vibe of this tweet,
much sooner than six months.
>> Yeah. I mean, at the pace at which
everything is go is going, I would not
be surprised if it's sooner indeed. Um
well, so now you might be wondering
where's the live demo today? Uh well,
for this AI engineer, we wanted to do
something a little different. this time
around and we think it's a very unique
moment for all of us to kind of
reimagine how we work and how we build
and so we wanted to bring a special
guest who has bent what's possible with
agents and really has pushed us to be
more agilled at openai so with that
please welcome to the stage the claw
father Peter Steinberger
Peter take it Okay, thank you all.
>> Thanks all.
>> Good morning everyone. You know, I love
this picture because it reminds me just
how much has changed in a few months. I
was juggling 10 or more terminal
windows, always waiting for one of them
to finish so I could steer the agent and
cue new work in in January. That felt
like peak productivity. Today it feels a
little bit silly. I thought I was
orchestrating really I was Pauling. I
was the scheduler, the router and the
memory.
You know, at first I paired with one
agent with 10 terminals. I was no longer
pairing. I was managing 10 direct
reports.
Now I mostly talk to a longunning
manager which delegates work to a team.
For tricky work, I can still drop down
and pair directly with a worker, but my
default changed. I manage the manager of
a small company of agents.
Three changes made that possible. Number
one, serverside compaction made
longunning tasks reliable enough that I
stopped optimizing around fresh
sessions.
Coordination
lets one thread create and steer the
right projects. And third, automation
can wake the same manager when something
happens. So we have persistent context,
delegation, and triggers. There's your
loop.
And once the loop starts working, you
discover the next problem. The
bottleneck keeps moving.
You know, last year I was primarily
constrained by tokens.
Now I fixed that by joining OpenAI.
I know I know the strategy does not
scale.
Then my constraint shifted to token uh
compute.
All these threads run at the same time
and my MacBook starts sounding like a
jet engine. That's mostly fixed by using
test boxes. So agents can run tests on a
separate machine.
Now I'm primarily constrained by
attention. And unlike tokens or compute,
I can't simply add more of it. So the
most important skill
is today is deciding where to spend it.
Are you still staring at the agent while
the code flies by?
>> I know. I know. It's it it feels cool,
but
with the earlier models, this was
necessary. You know, you you you you see
the agent go in a direction you don't
like, you hit escape, you steer it, you
steer it back. But the latest generation
of models is so good at understanding
intent that it's a little bit of a waste
of time to watch the agent generate
code.
Imagine someone files an issue on one of
my open source projects.
The manager wakes up, reach it against
the project's goals, notes, and vision
and decides whether it might be a fit.
If it does, it creates a worker.
That worker investigates, implements the
change, runs the tests, and another
agent can review the result.
I don't need to watch those agents work
or consume every intermediary message.
When the manager needs me, it returns a
PR, the original issue, the proposed
diff, maybe a video or even a running
build I can VNC into. I review once, I
re leave a note, I maybe approve, the
loop continues and can land after the
checks pass. The agent runs the inner
execution loop. I set the direction and
I make decisions in the outer loop.
You know, Paul Paul Salt is already
running a version of this. He pinned his
chief of staff. It wakes up every 10
minutes and it coordinates his GitHub
work. The agent creates threads in the
sidebar so Paul can jump in whenever the
work needs additional steering.
And you know once the manager is long
lived tying it to a laptop just feels
wrong. Codex can already move work
between hosts. Open claw has a gateway
and notes, but neither feels like the
final form.
I don't even want to sync where I work.
My agent should be able to connect to
any of my machines. They should know
which work can be done in the cloud or
which work requires my local machine.
The manager
shouldn't be a session trapped inside
your app. It should be an agent that I
can text, steer from Slack, or hear from
wherever I am. Really, why can't I talk
to my agent and have it design the whole
loop for me?
We haven't solved that yet. Models are
advancing faster than the harnesses and
organizations around them.
Designing those things is the next
engineering problem and that's where all
of you come in. The future is not 20
terminals, it's better loops. Let's
build them. Thank you.
Please join me in welcoming co-founder
of AI engineer an editor at Leighton
Space, Swix.
>> Hi.
So, we actually were supposed to have
Tashan from Z uh joining us today. Um he
unfortunately couldn't make it in. uh to
the United States. Uh but we have him
dialed in. So Shan, are you live? Uh I
hope I hope he's we're the team
backstage is is dialing him live. Um one
thing I also wanted to uh thank people
for doing is this is a very very big
community effort. Uh I love that. Thank
you so much to the open open team uh for
and to Microsoft for bringing the energy
in the opening things. Um but even uh
all you guys have been organizing all
these side events uh and one of them I
just wanted to shout out in particular
the um AI engineer kids day. Um you know
we are very sort of adult professional
serious uh but we you know we also care
about the next generation of AI
engineers. So I wanted to play the
video.
We're here in San Francisco at AI
Engineer Worlds Fair which is the
biggest collection
of AI engineers and entrepreneurs in the
world and we're holding the first ever
AI engineer kids day.
>> And I really love this workshop series
because we're inspiring the next
generation of AI technologists. These
kids are the people who will be doing AI
in the future. They're very AI native.
They'll be the AI experts. Something
that makes this workshop stand apart is
traditionally when you work with 3D
games, if you don't use AI, it takes a
really long time and you won't get as
far. But in this workshop, because we
use codeex, we were able to get a lot
further than you normally would in a
workshop and be able to explore a lot
more advanced comp concepts than normal
as well.
>> Come here. It's really fun. Blah blah
blah blah. And you can train AIS and
create AIS and ask AIS to create games.
Really fun.
Give it up for the kids uh events. Thank
you to Stephen Chin for running that um
and basically generating the funnel for
us for 10 15 years from now uh for our
next attendees. We have to grow on TAM
somehow. Uh so uh without further ado,
we're going to bring on Sashen uh for
for his keynote. Uh if we're all set.
Hey, how are you?
>> Great. I'm here.
>> Uh yes, uh to the magic of the internet.
Uh it's really good to see you again.
Tashen has you've been speaking with AI
Singapore. Uh and obviously GLM is uh
the talk of the town right now. Uh
there's been an amazing booth downstairs
in the expo and uh I'm I think a lot of
people are just very excited to hear
from you on uh what all is going on at
Zai. So if you want to take it away.
>> Yes. Sorry again for
not showing up in person, but I have a
team, whole team coming to the town and
we have a booth. So you have any
questions, feel free to reach out to me
on a LinkedIn and also you can look for
my team on our booth.
And since I cannot see my slides though,
I will needs to help me flip through all
the slides for me. Yeah,
>> you're good. Can you share like what
which slides we are in right now?
>> Yeah. Uh so we're we're on the opening
slide. Uh we're talking about
intelligence and ZI.
>> Okay. So yeah, so you can you can see
that it's the first time for us to
introduce G 4.2 uh 5.2 to the world. And
also we're are going to share something
about Z.AI and GM because maybe people
will think Z.AI and GM they're
irrelevant, right? you or your company
is not G.AI or your model is called Z1
or Z2 and you can find my X and our
company's X account here. So you can
just search for my name Zishan Lee and
Zai or you can follow them for the
follow-ups. So yeah, we can go to the
second slide.
Yeah, actually
I cannot see the slide. So I I'll try to
>> so we
>> yeah try to make sure that it is
correct. So the company actually is
called
maybe some people have heard of it
and the model the models it's it's
called GLM actually it's not a a brand
name it's a generic term so GLM actually
represent general language model for
training with auto reggressive blank
fill and that paper was published back
in 2021. So actually we were the one of
the first labs to do explorations on
large models. So at the same time with
open AI and anthropic and deep mind and
even today we we no longer use GLM as
the architecture we still use the name
GLM as our brand name. So we use JGM 5.1
5.2 and it become like one of our like
most broad uh broadest product and
model. And the second thing that we look
for is intelligence upper bound. So in
terms of intelligence we we may feel
that it's represent IQ something
something like that and when deepseek
launched when 01 launched people are
talking about the models capability to
solve math problems physics problems but
what actually intelligence mean is not
just like IQ or A&E or other other
physics problem. So from GM 4.5 to GM
4.7 we are exploring like several things
like reasoning coding agentic
capabilities. So as you can see from the
slides so we add like uh yeah the last
slide. Yeah we haven't I haven't like
finished that slide.
Yeah. So, okay.
Yeah, I need to go back to the
to to slides
back.
I don't have a back button.
>> Thank you. I I don't understand clickers
that don't have back buttons. Like, why?
Okay. You know, anyway, go ahead.
>> Yeah, never mind. Yeah, because people
want to see the GI 5.2. they don't want
to see like GI 4.1 or five but like G4.2
actually specialize in coding energetic
task as you can see from the graph
because there are a lot of rumors
whether your model is close to mythos
fable but actually I want to share this
slides to all of you so you can see it's
somewhere between Opus 4.7 and 4.8 eight
and we use the hardest problems like
deep tunnel bench 2.1 which was
mentioned by the open eye team uh
several minutes ago
and all the like long horizon task and
benchmark shows that the capability is
on par with at least open 4.7 and it it
it shows a significant improvements over
1.1 also for G 4.2 to we add a thinking
uh level called high. So because we also
notice as we move to the harder task it
may consume more tokens and also we we
care a lot about the token efficiency.
So it's the first time we add the high
level for thinking budget but even
without thinking the non-thinking model
is better than the 5.1 thinking model.
So I think it's a huge improvement for
the open weight model that's really
impressed the world and why people are
talking about GLM 5.2 lately. Okay, the
next slide
and one one thing that I want to mention
is that GLM is more more than coding
model because people use it inside clock
codeex open code but actually we have
trained a lot of things outside coding
for example we improve a lot in GDP val
and also math problems we also care
about math problems frankly speaking and
also we train a lot of thing uh related
to role play general chat. We want to
improve every aspects of the model. So
you can see from the artificial analysis
intelligence index actually leads the
other open way model a lot and close to
the frontier model. So I want you if you
you haven't experienced GLM yet, you can
use GLM to do general chat, use it to
process your daily workflow, not just
for coding, but you can explore the
model like beyond the coding scope. Next
slide.
And GM 4.2 is a openw weightight model.
So people always ask me why do you open
weight? So do you care about your
business or like do you care about
losing market to some inference
providers but actually we open the
weights for several things because there
are users needs and there are ours needs
if we can meet their needs I think it's
okay it's definitely okay for us to to
open the model for example if our users
wants security and control and we want
to build trust we can open the
For for some cases if an enterprise or
government especially in the western
world want to use the model we open way
we upload to the hugging phase so that
they can use the model on premise I
think it's very beneficial for the whole
e ecosystem to explore the model
especially when the capabilities
is close to the frontier model and
second if people want diversity so in
terms of diversity Firstly, I mean the
capabilities in legal, finance,
security, they can fine-tune the model.
So, we need to open the model to let
them fine-tune. For example, Harvey is
fine-tuning G 4.1 and maybe they're
thinking about fine-tuning G 5.2 too
afterwards and I I have like talked to a
lot of other companies they are also
thinking about fine-tuning GLM as their
like next step or next strategy to
differentiate themselves from other
application problem and third if our
customer or an individual want to
co-design and predict the future
sometimes they need to see the
architecture of the model they need to
see the recipe of how you train the
model. So we want to make the norm. We
want to make right bets. So we want to
co-shape the future with our customers
with the open source uh community. So I
think our needs and our ecosystem pretty
like fits into each other and GI 5.2 to
couldn't succeed without you all the
open source community players like on
flaws and media and and some like
individual super developers they are
part of it and thanks a lot to
application builders like Peter right
because open source doesn't just include
open source model but also open source
softwares and open source other sorts of
support so all your
support and what you you're are doing
right now push us to to make better
models. I think uh you you are the true
hero. And the last I want to share a a
great resource for you to go through GIF
5.2 is our tech blog. So actually in
that tech blog we share several things
like our hugging phase uh repo how how
you can try the glm 5.2 to you can try
it inside the chatbot agent and also you
can call the API and also we have a
coding plan like the codeex or clark
code subscription for you to use your
tokens as individuals
and also we share something about our
training pipeline training recipe which
you can understand why it's a good
model. So there are a lot of things
behind the behind the model not just
um a a a model that had great data. We
also have fantastic technologies behind
the model. So you can explore the model
yourself. You can see what difficulties
we have gone through. And the last
slides actually it's kind of a one more
thing. So it's the first time we share
Zcode to the whole community.
So that one more thing is we actually
have our own harness. The Zcode actually
it's built for GI 4.2 but also support
all frontier models. You can bring your
own key. You can connect to Zcode.
Actually the I think the operations is
similar to codeex. Actually, you you can
try some techniques like goal or other
like compact technique techniques like
what you've been in in codeex and call
code and this harness I think it's the
perfect one for G.2.
If you haven't experienced it, you can
just search Zcode or you can go to our
booth. We have our team members showing
this harness to you. and welcome to to
our booth and welcome to like talk to me
in the future and next time I'll
definitely be in SF talking to everyone.
Yeah, thanks.
>> Thank you very much.
Um,
so uh trust me the very first World's
Fair I wasn't allowed to come back in
the country for for my own conference.
So I know exactly this feeling. Uh but
it's all good. uh the ZI team really
appreciate them uh making the effort.
They really want to meet you. They're
here to meet you and this is the whole
point of the world's fair to bring all
the top world's AI uh companies and labs
uh all in one place so you can do
business together. Uh meet the people
behind the models that you use ask the
questions that he cannot answer in
public but you can ask in private. Um
I'm also very proud uh he showed uh Zen
showed that that list of uh hugging face
uh you know top uh contributors. I think
we're are four for eight uh in that list
uh present at Willsfair. Uh we're
working with Nvidia and Unsllo and O
Lama and and uh all those sort of
finetuners as well to uh to make sort of
the inference and the local tracks that
you're going to see over the next few
days. Um with that, thank you so much to
Shen. Uh I'm going to invite on uh the
next uh couple folks. I think I think I
might be doing Alli's job here. So uh
we'll we'll talk to Hugging Face uh next
and and Minia. Thank you.
Joining us on stage is the co-founder
and chief science officer at Hugging
Face, Thomas Wolf.
>> Hello everyone. Hello Olive. Nice to
have you on stage.
>> Hi. Nice to Thanks for having Yeah. So I
think you're on for a treat today
because you just saw uh GLM
which is current number two on the
artificial analysis table. I take fab
fable out because nobody can use it and
now we have number four. So basically
you will have all the top models at
least the top open source model in a row
and we're very lucky to have a leave who
has a pretty amazing path in life. Uh so
she came to the US Pennsylvania she was
studying doing PhD at NYU uh in the lab
of Yand
working on JPA but we decided we won't
talk about JPA today right something for
another day um and then instead of
joining hugging face which was in New
York also that time she decided to go
join Mini Max so uh for those who who
maybe don't know all the all the nail
labs around the world and you're you're
forgiven because I think there's like 64
nails right now. Minimax is one of the
top of what we call the AI dragons in
China. So these are the new there's uh
there's deepseek which is very well
known now. Moonshot who does Kimmy Z and
GLM that you just saw and now we have
Miniax. They're all extremely good,
extremely talented team fighting for the
first spot. uh so the the the latest
release of minimax was M3 uh just
earlier earlier in June which was the
top model at the time top open source
model uh very impressive there's a lot
of very interesting things about this
model so we'll quickly dive in them and
then talk a little bit about uh what's
what's what's specific about minimax
what's what's great there
so uh maybe Olive to to start a little
bit can you can you give us you know a
little bit of your your view of of M3,
what you like about this model, how is
the release?
>> Yeah, M3 we released M3 earlier this
month and it is a smaller model with 400
around 400 billion total parameters and
20 billion activated. Um but it is very
capable in terms of both coding
performances and also it understands
vision. So um that's uh what open source
models don't usually have is that they
can the model can only deal with coding
but it can also understands videos um
images and it has a super uh long
context of 1 million um with our new
architecture called MSA minimax sparse
attention. So we you we really put these
three things together uh because we know
that they are they will be very
important in future AI applications
coding capabilities agentic capabilities
longer context and multimodel
understanding. Um yeah I think that
would be very interesting about the
model.
>> Yeah. So, so there's a lot to unpack
unpack in this model and it's um it's
it's still I think the only top five
model open source model that is actually
multimodel. So, we need to talk about
that. But maybe first about the long
context because that was also the first
one that really had this real one
million token long context that's
actually functional and you guys had
also the the minimax pass attention
which is this one technique to to make
that efficient that you also published
and and share extensively. So can can
you talk a little bit about this maybe
how the project went from from the
attention how to make this long context?
Yeah, I would say the story about long
context went back to even Miniax M1 and
Miniax01
where the model was actually was able to
perform tax of 10 million um token
context.
>> 10 million
>> 10 million. Yes. Um but then it was not
an agentic model, right? It was just um
10 for example dumping a book, it would
be able to give reviews on it and stuff
like that. So uh what we realized was
that you know longer context actually
unlocks a lot of capabilities especially
when interacting with users and now when
you know the agents is interacting with
the whole environment and getting all
the tool responses um getting multi-
rounds
the like shorter context wouldn't be
enough to perform the complex tasks. So
for this version we said oh we have to
have our longer context backs and so
what we pursued was with our miniax
sparse attention
um which you know was the architecture
that was scalable and had a simple
design. So I would say from a higher
level right it has an index branch um
that you know selects
on a higher level what is what matters
more in the context and then we have a
sparse attention branch that calculates
performs the calculation on the selected
blocks uh to actually performs the
tasks. Um and so yeah like that we
really designed um an elegant
architecture so that we can scale the
length and then scale the model size in
the future with that.
>> That's beautiful. I like how for for
those who've been in the field for quite
some time we we had a lot of work on
attention right this N square and there
was a lot of linear attention. Yeah. And
then some that somehow all of this
disappeared at some point when flash
attention came around. We discovered we
just needed more efficient camera. Now I
like how we come back to thinking you
know first principle what is attention
how can we make that more efficient. So
1 million token is crazy right GPT2
was24 and and everyone was like oh
that's really big we we we never need
more. Where do you see this coming like
going in the future? Like Jeff was
pitching me the other day a trillion
token attention. You think we should go
token attention? That's definitely
something we can explore towards, right?
Ultra length of the context. Definitely
that's something that's very exciting to
explore with and something that
architecture design along with hardware
um would require a lot of research on to
that.
>> Yeah, you think there's still a lot of
lowhanging fruits. So typically today we
saw open really reducing I mean we don't
know how as a phone but like reducing
their their inference bill by half by
probably having some more efficient
processing around tensions. Do you think
there is still a lot of lowhanging fruit
that can be get in how we can process
that? So so one one thing still very
interesting about M3 is how cheap it is
in particular because of this part
attention or in part because of it's
small one but it's also very efficient.
>> Right. you think we can go even way
further maybe how did you guys invented
uh minmax passenture was it an agent
coming up with the idea was it a human
still coming up with the idea tell us a
little bit about
>> yeah um so we do think there's still a
lot of work that can get into
architecture and inference optimization
so that the model can be more efficient
especially if there are tasks that are
very task sensitive but require very
strong capabilities right and for that
those kind of task we really want the
model to be efficient. Um and who came
up with partic I think an intern from
our team worked on that that yeah an
intern uh that doesn't usually happen in
a lot of labs. Um because I think in
some labs interns don't have access to
the data the work and stuff uh but yeah
we are open to anyone who would like to
contribute to our models. So um the
architecture was actually designed by an
intern.
>> That's really good. still some work for
interns here. Good, good news. Um,
that's also a good segue to also how
minmax is working internally. So, so we
were discussing before coming on stage,
you were saying everyone can propose a
project. Can you tell us a little bit
about how you are organized, how you do
research? Mhm. Mhm. I think that is very
different from uh even in school or even
in earlier you know the earlier tech
companies is pretty pretty different is
that um what we what we make sure is
that we have good foundation and good um
infrastructure so that anyone can play
with the model and can think of what
they can improve with the model and then
after model releases when they are free
Right? They can play with the model.
They can think of their own evaluations.
They can find their own weaknesses and
propose a thing that they want to
improve on the model. And then other
people who are interested in that would
you know propose to join the project and
they will work on for a couple of weeks
or even a couple of months and when they
work out the final thing is shipped to
our model. It it is you know we use that
in our final training and it's shipped
out to the audience.
>> Interesting. So you can have people
working for a really long time on
project. When you say a couple of
months, it can be like really deep
exploration of possible.
>> Yes, I would say for example
architecture might require longer time
of investigation, research, experiments,
even redoing the evaluations for pre
pre-training. Yes. So it might require
longer time.
>> Really nice. Yeah. And I know you're
also very big on evaluation. I agree. We
could talk about that. I think one one
thing probably related to that is this
unique specificity that M3 and your team
has um around multimodality. So not just
text but this model can also understand
image and video and as I understand but
but please expl explain better when we
read the model card on hugging face it
say the model was trained from the first
step as a multimodel not just at a like
user one as after salt right can you
tell us a little bit more about that and
why you think it's important and and and
why starting from the first step on
multimodel training and not just
training
>> um so we call it native mortal modality
um And so it is somehow typical for
model labs to train the multimodel let's
say vision understanding capabilities
after the text pre-training is done. Um
they put adapters and then train that
part. But what we found out was that
that would actually harm the text
performance
and the vision vision understanding
performance wouldn't converge that well
because the model is kind of converges
towards the model uh the text
understanding um and it's just not the
most optimal and also not the most
scalable if you think about it. we want
to scale the data right and also we can
also some labs um train this capability
from halfway through the pre-training
for example continued pre-training but
what we found that this would be very
you know uh recipe sensitive it is
different for the recipe would be
different for different architectures
different uh you know data mixtures
different learning rates um it's hard to
control hard to you know scale to you uh
you can't really scale your experiment
results and conclusions to a larger
model and so for you know what we
thought was why not just training from
the very first step that comes the most
natural. We know that a lot of labs run
into problems doing that. uh the model
would collapse after a couple of steps
of training you know both text and
vision understanding but we managed to
solve that problem we did a lot of work
on um vit and we did a lot of work on
the data that we actually training um
for example we do interle data what we
call interled data um it's actually
natural data but we keep the um images
and videos in instead of mass masking it
out and we do some pretty good cleaning
and masking on the data and we do very
good reward modeling so that we train it
from the first step and scales up
a lot. Yeah, it does does not collapse.
>> That's really impressive impressive.
Should do should we expect much larger
model in the future? So, this one is
still fairly small, right? It's it's 428
billion parameters, 23 active billion.
Um well do do you think you will go past
the trillion?
>> Definitely. Yeah definitely in the
future uh there are many tasks that
wouldn't be able to the more model
wouldn't be able to perform or good at
with smaller parameters. We are
definitely going more ambitious than
this.
>> It's great looking forward. Um, another
interesting thing I always find
fascinating about Miniax is how how you
also have this whole range of of apps
and product, right? So I remember
already so so Miniax started to open
source things on the on the HuggingFace
platform in January last year. So 18
months ago and and we were chatting a
little bit about the team to understand
what you were doing and I remember so
you were already having a huge usage on
some of these uh of some of these apps.
Um can you tell us a little bit how how
this started right so was it basically
you had a lot of apps and then you
thought we have we have all these data
why not training a model and then they
build up research team how is how is the
story there
>> um our our story is model from the first
day so um I believe that multimodality
model a model that can understands all
visions and outputs all modalities was
the first thing that our um CEO planned
on the first day even before the company
even started. So that was the dream of
AGI. I think that was very very early
even before Chad GBT came out.
>> Wow. Um yeah and then apps were
something that comes along because you
have some model capabilities you want
people to experience it well not many
people can use it with API right we
can't expect everyone to experience with
API so we need good um user interaction
you know interfaces good apps good
scenarios that people can can you know
experience experience the model with I
think actually those apps covered more
than 300 million people around 200
countries globally and I think over a
million companies as well. Yeah, this
was uh mind-blowing when I heard about
the size and we we don't often realize
the size of of of this type of usage
already and and that that kind of brings
me to the question around um opensource
business model and and all of that which
is the always existing question which is
right now it's nice to open source model
but you you also need to have some
revenue stream right so I guess M3 is
something you you decided for instance
to give for free and I think It's it's
great for the world. Um, how do you see
this? Do you also have some specific
models you use for the app? Do you think
about do you think in the future you'll
keep it's probably hard to say for sure,
but do you think you'll keep open
sourcing models? How is the culture
around open sourcing right now?
>> Personally and also for the model
research team, we always hope to open
source the models. Um that is our plan
because we really see how the open
source community together can help the
model build better. For example, we
receive a lot of um feedbacks on the
model performance from the great
community and we receive PRs on um
whatever we open source right and those
are very very valuable and come comes to
our later versions. So definitely open
sourcing is great.
>> That's great. And actually do you have
some ask for the audience people who are
using M3 or minimax is there something
you would love them to send back to you
as feedback? Do you do you for instance
do you read when people try to modify
the models or play around you know
tweaks or what is the best thing you you
think you can take from the community uh
for the future models for instance?
I would say whatever um issues that
people are running into especially with
multimodality right this is the first
time that we're combining it together we
are definitely going more ambitious on
that in the future it might have some
flush right now but we are improving on
that so whatever that's uh feedback that
model is not good doing that great we
will definitely improve that in future
versions and also whatever features that
um people want say you know for example
um thinking effort right some people ask
for that um like everyone can ask and we
will try to accomplish that in the
future models
>> yeah do you see a lot of usage right now
already in multimodality in terms of
coding agents I feel like it's it's a
little bit underexplored
>> it is it is but um it can actually
unlocks a lot of capabilities and a lot
of uh agent applications say that for
example you want the model to read the
PP PowerPoints, right? Or to read some
reports that is not very structured um
and you wanted to understand a very long
video say that you dump in a long
playing video and then you want the
model to act uh using some tools uh
after understanding it and it unlocks a
wide variety of um agent use cases.
>> So like the agent could finally watch my
YouTube tutorial and understand how to
use my coding tools how I described it.
Is it something like that?
>> Huh?
>> Could the agent finally watch YouTube
tutorials and understand things from
them?
>> Yeah. Yeah, I think so.
>> Do you use a lot of uh agent coding
tools internally? Is it like I mean
coding for sure, but like is it also
already in terms of research? Is it
automated part or not? How does this
>> Yes.
>> Um we have our own research harnesses.
Um we build our own research harnesses
that automate our workflows. I would say
a lot of our workflows are automated.
You can see how um the latest frontier
models all pursues capability like
kernel optimization, right? Like let the
model pulse train other models. Um let
the model build data, auto data, stuff
like that. Um you can see how more and
more models are capable of doing those
including M3. Actually, we were very
good at those cases longer horizons and
kernel optimizations. Um, and so we can
use that model capability, harness it
together and help with our um, daily
routine and make our iterations even
faster.
>> Is M3 building M4 already?
>> Um, building M3.1.
>> M3.1. Okay,
>> the gem
>> already.
>> Um, I would love to finish on what what
you find exciting in the coming month.
What do you think? It can be Asia in
terms of feature or or things you want
to see happening in in AI or or more
generally in terms of whatever whatever
really is top of your mind. I would say
it's going to
>> happen.
>> A lot of things are very exciting. Um
but what I recently find the most
exciting would be a multi- aents that I
think a lot of AI applications are using
model routing multi- aents um that
unlocks even more capabilities even comp
more complex tasks and also it tells us
what the models are capable and not
capable of and you can you know do a lot
of things with that is pretty exciting.
>> Thanks a lot. Pleasure to have you.
Thanks for having me.
>> Thanks.
Ladies and gentlemen, please put your
hands together and welcome back our MC,
member of technical staff at Keycard,
Ally How.
Wow, what amazing content so far. Super
excited to tell you more about our next
speaker who's introducing the security
track. Software factories are only made
possible if security is in the loop.
Today, engineers have to navigate an
ever evolving agent supply chain between
skills and software packages that seem
to be compromised almost daily.
Organizations have to manage identity
sprawl as agents increasingly do work on
behalf of users and other agents.
Security teams have to find ways to
govern agents and make sure their access
is scoped to only what's necessary for
the task at hand.
Today, there's an enormous shift that's
happening across the industry from
traditional application security to
agentic security.
Randall Daggs, VP of marketing
engineering and AI orchestration at
Sneak, is helping large enterprise
customers navigate that shift. Randall's
here to tell us more about AI engineer
security track, which was made possible
by Sneak. Please welcome to the stage
Randall Diggs.
Hello. How's it going everyone? Uh, I'm
Randall. Thanks for the nice intro,
Ally. And I'm only up here for a couple
minutes. This is going to be very brief.
But what I wanted to talk about in the
time that I have is kind of the state of
AI security and the things that I've
been thinking about quite a lot lately
and maybe things that you've all been
thinking about, too.
So, I've been a developer and security
professional pretty much my entire life.
And even though I've been in the
security space, the thing that makes me
excited in these recent years with the
rise of generative AI is being able to
build better quality software more
quickly. There's nothing more fun than
shipping the things that you're working
on to actual users and sparking that
sense of joy, right? It almost feels
like a cheat code. And I think that
there's really a few obstacles to
allowing all of us in the room today to
do these things at scale in today's
world. So the first thing is something
that all of us probably learned the hard
way a few years ago, which is when
you're building software using AI, uh
there's always the risk that the code
that AI generates might have a security
issue. Everybody knows that. It's
nothing new, right? And I think the
reason that that's not a big deal is
because first of all, everyone kind of
intuitively knows that when humans write
code, we generate security issues. When
AI models write code, turns out they
also generate security issues. And so
having security as part of your
development life cycle is just like a
core part of like modern engineering
work. No questions at all. I think the
second thing though is a little more
interesting. It's when you're trying to
deploy actual autonomous agents into
production. How do you do that in a way
that allows you to go to sleep easily
and not worry that the agents you
deployed are going to go off the rails,
do something they're not supposed to do,
harm your business or your users or
something else, right? And that's a much
more difficult problem to solve. And
then the final thing that I think is a
barrier to us, you know, really
innovating and moving quickly is almost
geopolitics at this point. Like I don't
know about all of you, but how many
people were kind of annoyed when access
to Fable got pulled? Show of hands.
Yeah, a whole lot of people, right? How
many people are a little annoyed they
can't use the brand new OpenAI GPT 5.6
model right now? Yes, a lot of people.
And I think it's interesting because
this is all related to security, right?
Like fundamentally the biggest problem
that I feel we have to still solve in
our space is being able to use AI
fearlessly and have it be secure by
default. And so that's why I'm really
excited to announce that right after
this keynote downstairs on the second
floor in room 2005, we're going to be
running the first security track at the
World's Fair for the entire day with
some of the best companies and
presenters in the world talking all
about these problems and how we can fix
them going forward. So if security is a
concern to you like it is to me, please
come downstairs, join us again. Room
2005, second floor. Uh we have
presenters from Nvidia, Anthropic,
Keycard, where Ali works, uh Sneak, of
course. We have a ton of amazing content
and it's hopefully going to allow you to
level up the stuff that you're building
and do it without any worry at all. So
that's really the goal. So with that
being said, thank you so much for the
time and hopefully I'll see you down
there. Um I'm Randall and I'll be ming
the event all day. All right, take care
everyone.
Suddenly your team is on on call
rotation to figure
what actually went wrong. Pretty common,
right? Now, as per the standard engine
response, your gut will tell you to pull
the raw prompt from the telemetry logs,
pass it to the same model using the same
prompt and run it locally to isolate the
bug, which we'll all do. And
surprisingly, it will work as well. Run
it again, it will work again. You run it
10 more times, it will be just perfect
every time. But now let's talk about
that one run which costed you and that
will be gone. You can reproduce it and
if you can reproduce it, you can debug
it. But if you can't debug it, you can't
promise it won't happen to your next
customer or user. Right now I am Tisha.
I have Sushin with me as my
co-presenter. We both run agents against
real production backends. You know the
kind of place where a bad right isn't.
Oh well, run it again. It's you on a
call with a customer explaining where
the data actually went. This whole talk
is going to be about that one thing you
lose the second an agent goes hey buy in
production which is being able to
reproduce it. That will be a not for the
next 10 minutes to follow. Now let's
look at how this actually blows up.
We've got an agent hooked to a broker
API which is the scenario I'm taking.
The user says, "Hey, sell $1,000 of
stock." Now comes the interesting part.
Instead of doing the math, the agent
sells the raw number 1,000 and dumps it
straight into the quantity field. Guess
what? It sells $1,000 shares instead.
Now, at 190 bucks a share, $1,000 in 10
will become how much? $190,000.
Disaster, right?
And the terrifying part is that the API
or my infrared returned a clean 200.
Okay. In 30 milliseconds, we got zero
exceptions, zero alerts. If you see the
trade is completely wrong, but your
dashboards are sitting there perfectly
green, perfectly flawless.
When such a scenario as we last
discussed comes up, what's the first
thing which you will do to try and fix
this? The reflex here is to, you know,
just turn the model temperature down to
absolute zero. Assuming greedy decoding
will make everything deterministic,
right? But that's a complete
misconception. Setting the temperature
to zero doesn't fix a broken reasoning
path. It just means the model is going
to make the exact same logical error the
exact same way at the exact same time.
And honestly, even worse than that, to
back up the scenario we just discussed,
look at the engineering threads on
Reddit and hacker news. The hard data
shows that temperature zero isn't even
truly deterministic on a hardware level.
Running the same proced a thousand types
can still return dozens of completely
different responses just due to the
underlying GPU non-determinism and the
NOA architectures which are there.
So to understand why this actually
happens, we'll have to look at it from
first principles. It comes down to four
simple things. One,
sampling determinism is in system
determinism.
Temperature zero just means always take
the AG max, but it doesn't guarantee
that the underlying scores stay
identical run to run. Two, floating
point math isn't associative. The order
you add your decimal matters, right? But
a tiny shift in matrix operation alters
the final logic and which in turn will
flip the winning token. See, it's not a
concurrency issue. Run the same matrix
multiplication alone on the GPU a
thousand times and I'll guarantee you'll
get this exact same bits. So the real
culprit is batch invariance here because
a request gets grouped with whatever
else hits the server that millisecond.
Four mixture of experts routing has the
exact same bottom line. Experts have
strict capacity limits. If a patch
overflows a specific sub network tokens
get rerouted. Whether a token makes the
cut depends entirely on the traffic you
got batched with. So the ultimate
takeaway here is that chasing text
output is a losing battle completely. We
don't need the model to return the exact
same token back every time. We just need
our system to execute the exact same
state transition.
Which means we've been asking the wrong
question all along. Right? The wrong
question is how do I make the model
deterministic? And I've seen teams
burning weeks on that and walk away
deciding the system's just unknowable.
The right question is how do I debug and
retest a run I can't reproduce? Because
determinism was never the northstar.
debugging was two words we keep mixing
up which I'll talk about now is bitwise
determinism and replayability. Bitwise
determinism is same input, same output.
That's controllability. You're not
getting it from a hosted API and you
don't actually want it because the
randomness is what makes the model good.
Once the model explores more, you'll get
more creative answers. The other one is
replayability which is rebuilt a run
that already happened well enough to
debug it. That's observability. You
don't need the model deterministic. You
need the run recorded and you don't
freeze the model. You capture what it
did.
Now the question which we are all
thinking about is where do you record?
For sure not at the network layer
because half your agent will never touch
the network. the local retrieval, the
inprocess tools, the memory and the
parts that do not shred under streaming
and async
record at the boundary instead because
you need to capture what enters each
node and what leaves it. Imagine
imagine something your agent didn't pro
was wrong. Co the wrong tool. It wrote
the wrong thing and now suddenly your
team is on on call rotation to figure
out what actually went wrong. Pretty
common right now. As per the standard
engineering response, your gut will tell
you to pull the raw prompt from the
telemetry logs, pass it to the same
model using the same prompt and run it
locally to isolate the bug, which we'll
all do and surprisingly it will work as
well. Run it again, it will work again.
You run it 10 more times, it will be
just perfect every time. But now let's
talk about that one run which costed you
and that will be gone. You can reproduce
it and if you can reproduce it, you can
debug it. But if you can't debug it, you
can't promise it won't happen to your
next customer or user. Right now I am
Tisha. I have Sushin with me as my
co-presenter. We both run agents against
real production backends. You know the
kind of place where a bad right isn't.
Oh well.
>> Hey everyone, I am Kushan. Uh I worked
at Som as a founding engineer for two
years. Let's talk about what I'm
interested in right now and that is
browser agents. Browser agents as an
idea are so cool, right? Browser agents
should go crazy, right? I personally
have not seen that adoption and me
myself, I don't use browser agents that
much. I've been exploring that for some
time. Been trying to understand why that
is. So on my screen right now, we have
the browser challenge. But uh this is a
very interesting benchmark for browser
agents because there are so many things
that you have to do long rising
sequencing of your tasks. And this
actually reveals, you know, why browser
agents suck. If you saw at the beginning
of the video, uh the browser, this agent
took like maybe 10 20 seconds just to
click the start button. And now we're on
step one. There are 30 steps and it has
taken so long just to click one button.
Um so enough of this. I want to show you
what I've been building. So same
website. Um I've tried to sort of
replicate the feeling of seeing what's
happening. You know, you can see what
the browser agent is thinking. But as
you can see, it is so much faster and so
much quicker and I'm using a much
cheaper model. Right? The hypothesis
here is models are pretty smart, but
it's the infra around them that sucks.
If you noticed in the video earlier,
maybe I'll put a screenshot, the agent
is trying to debug what's going on. It's
trying to click something, but it
doesn't understand what's going on. So,
my core thesis here has been give a nice
environment for the agent to use, right?
So, where it can plan long sequences, it
can figure out where it failed, what is
going on, and it can plan the click
correctly. I have figured out is
scattered across not just a codebase or
a single repo but across things like
Slack and email meetings and documents a
bunch of other stuff right and then half
of it is actually just stuck in someone
else's head and so I'd have to have my
AI reach out have them answer questions
and move forward
and you know when I was a individual
contributor maybe it's very easy to just
write code but as you sort of scale
yourself you find that a lot of the
knowledge work that is happening today
is just figuring out like what has
happened who is waiting on what and
which loose threads needs attention. And
so if you want to take anyway from this
talk, you can just leave right after
this if you want, is these six things.
One, compaction works. Now you can
really feel comfortable pinning a very
long thread and knowing that it's it's
generally going to remember uh what
you've told it. You should also start
getting really comfortable with talking
to your computer. Voice is really good
and voice is only going to get better
through time and you're going to be able
to do even more with uh dictation rather
than a keyboard.
uh computer use and appshots are very
great. It's a great way of bringing in
context and I'll talk a little bit more
about what that looks like. And then
most importantly, really start investing
in what your personal memory looks like,
right? What are the skills that you want
to use and what are the skills you want
to automate? But also, what are the
plugins you want to share with the rest
of the team? And once you have that set
up, you can start thinking about these
pin threads and automations like
teammates. And more interestingly, I
don't know if many people know this, but
every thread in codeex can talk to each
other. So maybe today you can work on
having a pin thread feel like a
teammate, but very quickly you might
have threads that run automations that
communicate to other threads. Now you
can have this idea of a manager. And
these are some of the really big
concepts I want to bring to you today.
And so if you've used something like
chat tobt uh in the past, maybe you were
taught, okay, you know what, you have to
really have these very short threads.
you know, um, they only happen every
once in a while. After a couple
messages, the context is going to run
out and you really need to create a new
thread to capture context. Now, all of
my work happens in a pinned thread. You
pin it, you give it a name, it runs over
time, and with automations and triggers,
you can start waking these things up.
And so, codeex really happens in three
acts, right? You bring the context into
the system. You do work on this pinned
thread, and then you figure out how the
computer can then act and write back to
the rest of the world.
And we can talk about these things
pretty quickly. How many people here
actually use dictation? Just show show
hands. I'm curious like how many people
Yeah. You know, maybe like 30% 40%. I I
I can almost assure you that by the end
of the year more and more people will
do. So, right. Tony Stark is not like
typing into a keyboard talking to
Jarvis. And I really want you to sort of
recognize that by the end of the year,
you're going to feel like Tony Stark.
You're going to be automating a lot of
your life through voice. Voice is like
three times faster than most people
type. And I have like a hand injury. I
can't even type anymore. I just use a
foot pedal to control dictation. And
it's pretty awesome.
And I'm also really lazy. So if I had to
type, I would just send a message like
fix this, right? And and I hope that the
AI can figure out what's going on. And
then when it doesn't, I complain on
Twitter that, you know, the AI sucks.
But in reality, when I use dictation, I
will just blabber, right? Take a look at
this issue, check the browser, there's
some white space I'm not happy with.
Maybe it's a screenshot from the
website, maybe it's on Figma. then like
make a pull request, edit only the CSS,
and then also like when you're done,
message the guy on Slack and then wait
for the preview link and then send him
the preview link too. I would never type
this, but this basically is very easy to
say and the the model can figure out how
to actually take these actions.
Once you have all this input in place,
you just have to connect it with the
rest of the world. And this is where you
want to install plugins, right? Most of
my work is just Slack, Gmail, Calendar,
Notion, Linear, Obsidian. By having
these plugins, you can really just give
your AI the ability to reach out into
the world and read more information.
Once you do this, I just want you to try
out a very simple prompt, right? Triage
what's changed around my projects. Bring
me the important things. And you're
really going to be surprised at how much
these newer models can just figure out
what you do for work and how you can
become more productive and what's
important.
Once you trust a plug-in's work, you can
start also thinking about your own
plugins. So, I work on the developer
experience team. A lot of the time I'm
also just dealing with all of the
messiness of the feedback on Slack and
on Twitter. And so, I built out some
skills that just do delegation and
triage. It knows given some feature,
who's worked on it, and what Slack shall
I need to share this in, right? And I
can invest in this for myself and then
share this with the team. And you can
kind of become the plug-in hero, right?
You you build these automations and you
can scale not only yourself but the
entire organization.
But sometimes, you know, the context
doesn't really come in by asking codeex
to read Slack and figure out what I just
saw or read Twitter. There's this really
cool feature called appshots it. It's
one of my favorite features of all time.
All you have to do is press both command
keys beside the space bar, right? It's
just like and it'll take a screenshot of
the application plus all the context and
the accessibility tree. And then half my
conversation with codeex is just I take
a snapshot of something I'm have a
conversation on Slack and I just go like
answer this question reply back also
make a poll request if it's important
and turn this into a skill. I've
actually invested so much in my triaging
skills that usually I just feel like a
manager now. I take an appshot I send
the question mark and the AI has to
figure out oh someone asked for like
credits from Twitter based on some
outage and let me go handle this.
Right? So if you just do anything today,
you try try an appshot workflow, right?
Maybe you're reading some feedback on
Twitter and Slack. You take an appshot.
Codeex will then trigger some kind of
triaging skills or some comm skills to
communicate between the internal Slack
versus the external Twitter. And then
you can just pin that thread. Okay, this
is some outage or this is some rate
limit issue that people are facing on
Twitter. Let's figure out how we can
manage this. And you can pin this and
work with it over time.
And that's brings us to part two,
working on the work. So now basically my
sidebar is just every single project I
manage. There's a chief of staff thread
that just wakes up every once in a
while. I have a single thread that runs
all the documentation for OpenAI, one
for this these slides. I do I maintain
the open source community and also I
just have a thread to monitor X
feedback.
And if you wanted to do something like
keep an eye on it every 30 minutes, you
just ask it to. And just by doing that,
it will just wake up every 30 minutes,
check for any updates, and update the
context that's around you.
You can do this to babysit a poll
request, right? You can just say, make
sure the tests are green, check every
hour, address all the feedback. If CI is
broken, fix it, and make sure it's
always mergeable into main. And they'll
do that, right? I also do things like
coordinating support. Uh check that
someone on Slack has answered a
question. If you can answer the
question, then report back on Twitter.
And then also my chief of staff threat
that just wakes up every 30 minutes. Uh
I don't pay for my tokens. I do 30
minutes. If you are using your pro plans
like doing it like twice a day is very
very productive.
But not only can you run these
automations on your computer, you don't
have to be glued to your computer,
right? These are where this is where
features like remote control really come
in. So remote control is the ability to
view every local and remote thread on
your computer in the cloud from your
phone. And so a lot of the work now can
be done like at a park or riding a bike.
It's actually pretty convenient. Last
week I was working on a launch video,
right? This is not like a codebase. This
is a launch video. Someone giving me
some feedback. And so I pulled out my
phone and I told my computer to go find
the video, make some changes in iMovie,
share the video on Slack, and just
monitor that Slack thread and say,
"Okay, every 30 minutes if someone says
the wording is off or the timing is
weird, try to fix it and send a
revision." And when I got back home to
work on this video,
there was no more feedback to execute
on.
But threads really just work across a
single workstream. One of the big things
I really also recommend is just setting
up like a memory base, right? Like I
just use an Obsidian vault. It generally
looks like this. I have a people's
directory. I have a projects directory
and some agent notes. And if you scan
this QR code, you're going to get a
template of how I set up my my system.
And so you can just pull this repo. Tel
code as I set it up for you and it'll
install all the skills that I use and
introduce the same structures that I
really recommend.
And then lastly, you can sort of choose
the forms that you want to interact
over.
For example, the same plugins that can
read context, right? Uh you can read an
email, it can also draft things. I I
don't know if people here really trust
AI to send emails and Slack messages on
your behalf. But generally, most of my
automations now also will prepare
drafts. So every email that I ever has
when I review it, there's already a
draft. Every Slack message where
someone's asking me a question, I
already have a draft set up there. You
can also do a lot of progress, make a
lot of progress with artifacts. You can
make PDFs and slides and Excels and
documents and they all open within the
Codex app and that way you can just
annotate and give feedback directly in
the application. And then recently we've
launched a sites feature. So now you can
just like byput your little
applications. You have login with chatbt
and you can connect your databases and
you can effectively have applications
that you share across the org. And so
more and more instead of sharing a
Google doc, I might actually just share
a website with a database to communicate
with the rest of my team and track the
progress of some kind of work, right?
Maybe it's launch readiness or maybe
it's some kind of migration.
And if there's no integration, if
there's no plugin to do something, this
is where things like computer use comes
in, right? Codeex has a very powerful
browser built off the same technology we
built Atlas with. And so you can do a
lot with things on the Chrome extension
side, right? You can have uh
authentication. You can have multiple
tabs running in the background. And if
it's a native app, then you can use just
general computer use, right? With
computer use, it doesn't take over your
screen. it still uses the accessibility
tree and allows you to control your
computer in the background. And so
oftent times I'll just be doing work and
I'll switch it to a tab or I'll switch
to some other application and I realize
that Codex is just doing what it needs
to do to get the job done. And these
things are also incredibly powerful. Uh
in the past week I've had Codex do a
bunch of really fun things. It's gotten
me refunds on a plane ticket, right? It
just checks the customer support channel
every five minutes and it's it just
wants me to get my money back. Uh, every
time I see a really long form, I just
hit an appshot and I say, "Fill out this
form for me." You know, recently I had,
and I don't recommend this at all, but
recently I had Codex use docuign and
sign a document and then send a fax
message to my doctor. And I was like,
"Oh, I need to send a fax message. This
is like, you know, faxpdf.com.
I just need your attention to put in the
credit card information and then we can
go forward from that." So, a lot of
these things are automated now. Really
fun. You can also use this to test
native applications, right? Most of the
time when I'm working on the Codex app,
I just spin up another version of the
Codex app and the main codeex is just
testing the future it's building and I
can watch it do this automation or I can
just go and do something else and you
know ride a bike.
And recently, I didn't know this until
maybe like you know two days ago, it
somehow can also control the iPhone
through screen mirroring. I don't know
what you can do with that just yet, but
I think it's a very cool experience to
not only be able to control your
computer, but effectively control your
iPhone just through technology like
through screen mirroring.
But then you might ask, okay, well, can
can computer use control codecs?
And the answer is that you don't really
have to
because like I said before, these codeex
threads can already talk to each other,
right? Which means you already have
managers.
So in the earlier example where I say
maybe someone is giving me
model feedback or or on Twitter or on
Slack, I might take a screenshot, take a
appshot, I might have the agent gather
some context, triage of the right
engineer, figure out how to communicate
this outage and then I might pin the
thread, right? But this still requires
me taking the appshot or taking having
the agency to take some kind of action.
But because threads can now talk to each
other, you can really change the way you
do your work. Now I have a single
monitor thread and that thread wakes up
every hour and it just using computer
use or using the CLI reads all of Slack
and all of Twitter and then it will try
to figure out what are the big issues uh
that we have. Then instead of doing the
triage in the coms itself, it'll make a
new thread. It'll rename it. It'll pin
it. And then that thread's job is to
figure out how to triage. that jobs that
thread's job is how to do communications
and then that thread is the one that
does this automation and maybe in a in a
day from now maybe someone else also has
some feedback about this issue. the main
agent can say, "Okay, this is still an
ongoing issue. It doesn't seem like
anyone's addressed this. Let me send a
message to this thread about the like
rate limit outage, right?" And that
thread might decide to post a message on
Slack or ask a question or maybe read
the docs or just see if any pull
requests are pending review.
And these are the kind of really cool
things that you can do once you
understand these basic concepts around
pinning these threads, enabling
heartbeats and computer use, and then
just allowing these agents to talk to
each other.
Right. So I really hope that in this
quick session I've really convinced you
that the the nature of work has changed.
Compaction works. Right. Generally
speaking, I feel like we're pretty close
to things like continual learning by
just having a memory base and a pinned
thread. And by taking actions using
plugins and computer use and making sure
you write things down in your memory
vault, you can get a lot of results in
terms of how you can improve your
productivity. And by just having
something like a heartbeat, just by
telling codecs, keep an eye on this, you
can now run these automations that carry
your workstream across uh different
sessions.
And so I think if you're a busy
developer or a manager, an executive,
this is a really great way of using
codeex not just for coding. you know, if
you want to keep track of everything in
your little uh Obsidian vault, if you
want to use a chief of staff thread to
manage your daily briefs or your
meetings research, or if you just want
to use loops to basically automate this
work,
uh check out the Codex app. Try some of
these ideas out. And then today at 2:50
p.m. at track 4, we're going to do a
longer like hour-long workshop where we
can actually have a longer conversation
and deeper conversation about what we
actually do. and I can give you guys
some feedback on the specifics of how
I've been using these kind of
automations. And uh lastly, come say
hello at the OpenAI booth. We're right
in the middle. You can't miss it. It's a
lot of fun. And uh that's it. Thank you.
And now suddenly your team is on on call
rotation to figure out what actually
went wrong. Pretty common right now. As
per standard engineering response, your
gut will tell you to pull the raw prompt
from the telemetry logs, pass it to the
same model using the same prompt and run
it locally to isolate the bug, which
we'll all do. And surprisingly, it will
work as well. Run it again, it will work
again. You'll run it 10 more times, it
will be just perfect every time. But now
let's talk about that one run which
costed you and that will be gone. You
can reproduce it and if you can
reproduce it, you can debug it. But if
you can't debug it, you can't promise it
won't happen to your next customer or
user. Right now I am Tisha. I have
Sushin with me as my co-presenter. We
both run agents against real production
backends. You know the kind of place
where a bad right isn't. Oh well, done
it again. It's you on a call with a
customer explaining where the data
actually went. This whole talk is going
to be about that one thing you lose the
second an agent goes hey buy in
production which is being able to
reproduce it. That will be a northstar
for the next 10 minutes to follow. Now
let's look at how this actually blows
up. We've got an agent hooked to a
broker API which is the scenario I'm
taking. The user says, "Hey, sell $1,000
of stock." Now comes the interesting
part. Instead of doing the math, the
agent sells the raw number 1,000 and
dumps it straight into the quantity
field. Guess what? It sells 1,000 shares
instead. Now, at 190 bucks a share,
$1,000 in 10 will become how much?
$190,000.
Disaster, right?
And the terrifying part is that the API
or my infrared returned a clean 200.
Okay. In 30 milliseconds, we got zero
exceptions, zero alerts. If you see the
trade is completely wrong, but your
dashboards are sitting there perfectly
green, perfectly flawless.
When such a scenario as we last
discussed comes up, what's the first
thing which you will do to try and fix
this? The reflex here is to, you know,
just turn the model temperature down to
absolute zero. Assuming greedy decoding
will make everything deterministic,
right? But that's a complete
misconception. Setting the temperature
to zero doesn't fix a broken reasoning
path. It just means the model is going
to make the exact same logical error the
exact same way at the exact same time.
And honestly, even worse than that, to
back up the scenario we just discussed,
look at the engineering threads on
Reddit and Hacker News. The hard data
shows that temperature zero isn't even
truly deterministic on a hardware level.
Running the same procedes
can still return dozens of completely
different responses just due to the
underlying GPU non-determinism and the
MO architectures which are there.
So to understand why this actually
happens, we'll have to look at it from
first principles. It comes down to four
simple things. One,
sampling determinism isn't system
determinism.
Temperature zero just means always take
the AG max, but it doesn't guarantee
that the underlying scores stay
identical run to run. Two, floating
point math isn't associative. The order
you add your decimal matters, right? But
a tiny shift in matrix operation alters
the final logic and which in turn will
flip the winning token. Three, it's not
a concurrency issue. Run the same matrix
multiplication alone on the GPU a
thousand times and I'll guarantee you'll
get this exact same bits. So the real
cult is batch invariance here because a
request gets grouped with whatever else
hits the server that millisecond.
Four mixture of experts routing has the
exact same bottleneck. Experts have
strict capacity limits. If a patch
overflows a specific sub network tokens
get rerouted. Whether the token makes
the cut depends entirely on the traffic
you got batched with. So the ultimate
takeaway here is that chasing text
output is a losing battle completely. We
don't need the model to return the exact
same token back every time. We just need
our system to execute the exact same
state transition.
Which means we've been asking the wrong
question all along, right? The wrong
question is how do I make the model
deterministic? And I've seen teams
burning leaks on that and walk away
deciding the system's just unknowable.
The right question is how do I debug and
retest a run I can't reproduce? Because
determinism was never the northstar.
Debugging was two words we keep mixing
up which I'll talk about now is bitwise
determinism and replayability. Bitwise
determinism is same input, same output.
That's controllability. you're not
getting it from a hosted API and you
don't actually want it because the
randomness is what makes the model good.
Once the model explores more, you'll get
more creative answers. The other one is
replayability, which is rebuilt a run
that already happened well enough to
debug it. That's observability. You
don't need the model deterministic. You
need the run recorded and you don't
freeze the model. You capture what it
did.
Now the question which we are all
thinking about is where do you record?
For sure not at the network layer
because half your agent will never touch
the network. The local retrieval, the
inprocess tools, the memory and the
parts that do not shred under streaming
and async.
record at the boundary instead because
you need to capture what enters each
node and what leaves it the meaning of
each step and not the packets. What
replay adds here is a deterministic CI
where you stop the model you'll rerun
the exact failure offline with zero
model calls.
Let's talk about the loop end to end.
Now it starts with annotation,
recording, visualization, understanding,
fixing, then the part we working on
which is replaying and finally
verifying. All right, let's now see how
to bring the workflow we just discussed
into action.
>> So we've established that replayability
is a core tenant of productionizing any
AI agent. But how do we build this in
code? As a proof of concept for this,
what we have done is we have built
something called Chronicle. At the heart
of Chronicle lies the concept of a
boundary. Think of a boundary as a
bounding box around any node in your
agentic workflow. A node can be a tool
call. It can be a call to an LLM or a
retrieval from a rack. It doesn't matter
as long as it's a method. It can be
annotated with the boundary annotation.
Now what does this annotation do? It
ensures that anything that goes into the
method and comes out of the method gets
recorded. So any input and output pair
will get recorded. On top of that, you
can define parameters like your model
version or the version of the code that
is running so that the entire state
during which the agent run happened gets
frozen and saved as a trace. Now let's
see this in action. We've been talking
about this stock selling agent which
went haywire in production. This is a
representation of the same. You have
your initial planning step which takes
into account the user input. It can use
the place order tool to do the actual
selling and buying of the stocks and
then finally it delegates to the final
Uh hi everyone. Hey what's up? I'm
Theresa. Uh and today I will be talking
about software factory. Uh everyone is
talking about software factory but only
few people are actually building one and
even fewer people know what it actually
takes to build one and how to define it.
So I will be talking about what is a
software refactory? Should I build your
own or outsource it? What works in
production already? What are the main
challenges and how much is this all
going to cost?
Uh my name is Theresa. I work at a
company called factory.com. And we've
been building uh this concept of the
software factory for quite a long time.
But finally uh the technology is
catching up and it's possible to build
this in production for enterprises like
EY or Adobe. uh I would define the
software factory as the whole loop the
whole life cycle of developing software
with autonomy which doesn't mean just
coding and generating code by that I
mean collecting all the signals reacting
to user feedback to logs prioritizing
what's important then orchestrating it
all executing validating doing really
good uh testing in production and then
iterating on all this uh while also
continuously improving in the process
and gaining
new knowledge and new skills. So this is
just our dashboard how our software
factory looks if you if you look at it
and it's catching the whole cycle there.
Uh this is just some history and by
history I mean 2023 in AI. So the
software factory wasn't really possible
before even though we always had this
idea from the beginning of CH GPT lounge
and others we had this idea of the
continuous loop there was autog baby agi
already with the concepts of iterating
on the software but it didn't work
before because the LMS were
hallucinating there was problem with
context length uh problem with the
reasoning quality uh different problems
like this or we were missing good
environments where the agents can
actually work in the isolation. So all
this kind of led to why the software
factory is the paradigm that's starting
to be popular now and actually useful.
I like to define things by what they are
not. So I want to say software factory
is not just coding agent and it's not
even a swarm of coding agents even
thousands of agents because generating
code writing code that's the easy part
compared to all the others. Uh engineers
don't even spend most of the time uh
just writing code the challenges are the
rest of it. uh so this is what I want to
enhance and it's also not just some
consultancy or just some abstract
strategy that someone will try to sell
you and to your organization
uh I think the approaches are of course
different but we believe you should
really rebuild your organization from
ground up to be ready to become a
software factory like you can't invite a
consultancy and just throw something in
the middle of your organization you
should really be mindful and rebuild
build it from scratch.
Uh this is the approach I like uh
showing to building the software factory
and I think it's similar to building the
real team of humans because there is a
lot of agents as I said they will be
testing validating iterating and it all
can end up as a big chaos. Uh so you
need to be mindful and I would say the
three important things is being agnostic
in the software factory. So being
independent of LLM choices uh of how you
already work as the organization then
you need to be autonomous. So you need
to give the agents the right trusts and
all this permissions and governance and
you need to trust it to run really for a
long time because the predictions are
that agents will run even a year or more
years without the human in the loop. Of
course that sounds ambitious but for
example our missions already our long
runninging sessions already build uh
things and run for weeks. So it's not
that crazy. And third thing, always
improving. So same as human
organization, you need to onboard any
new people in your team by giving them
good uh code base, understanding, good
structure, documentation and also let
them improve in the process and gain new
knowledge and share it share it within
the team.
So these are the three points and now
let's talk about the agnostic one. Uh I
think the important thing to point out
if you are a builder and building
different primitives of the software
factory you need to be ready for how
everyone is already working you need to
work across environments like slack,
github and connected to everything and
you need to also allow people to already
bring subscriptions they are using
because there is every every time there
is like new technology new frontier
models uh new benchmarks and it's so
difficult to catch up but also to
predict what we'll be winning. So it's
best to be agnostic for everyone.
Uh then there's the topic of being
agnostic to models. Uh this is a topic
of a lot of discussions recently and
this chart is from this chart is from
CEO of Coinbase uh who tweeted about how
they started uh started saving money in
their organ or organization on AI but
without reducing the token spend. So the
black line is how much they spent on
tokens. They continue growing and token
maxing but they stopped spending so much
money. Uh how they did it uh different
tricks like different default default
models for people. So stop pushing
people to use only the frontier as a
default. Then caching of course uh to
stop prefilling the stuff every time.
And then no limits on spending but just
needing to see the results if you spend
a lot. And the last thing that's really
important topic is routing. So smart
routing between LLMs and just a token
optimizing between uh the LMS instead of
just spending so much tokens.
Uh we built uh a thing in factory called
uh automatic model routing and there's
been a lot of questions around it but
what it does is it automatically routes
between different models in your
process. The important thing is it
decides first what model is most optimal
and then uh it can switch to different
model if it's failing the task or in
case of any troubles but it usually
doesn't happen and important thing is it
doesn't just help uh save money. It also
helps with reliability or with speed
because open source models are often
faster and uh if one LM provider fails
you can just switch to another one
automatically. So it really does more
things than just saving the money. This
uh is our benchmark which is very
conservative. I prefer conservative
benchmarks but I think the direction is
clear. You can save for example 25% but
even more probably
uh how the routing works. Uh there are
four parts. First you just assign the
task and you don't really need to do
anything but as an organization you can
for example give different permissions
and different default models to
different people which is very useful
like marketing or sales or engineers can
both uh have different default models
and then you have the classification
which is the important part. This is the
magic of the routing. You need to really
uh look at the structure of the prompt
of the uh code base of how difficult the
task is, what tools are being used, all
these factors and make a classification
of difficulty of the task. Uh after that
you basically do a threshold of what is
enough to accomplish the task and you
choose the cheapest model above the
threshold. So cheapest model that is
predicted to accomplish your task and
then you go.
Okay. So when we launched this we got a
lot of questions like does it actually
work? What if uh the model miss out? Uh
is it slower? Is it more expensive
actually? What if the model can't
accomplish the task or what if it needs
to upgrade? And how do we handle
caching? So I think these are all valid
questions and that's why it's so
difficult to build a good router like
you need to basically classify it very
well and the challenge is to not not to
need to switch too often but even if
you're switching in the middle of the
task to difficult to more difficult
model you still overall are faster
probably because it's still worth
uh this is just some overview of caching
uh lot of questions we got on this was
also So how do we handle caching? Do we
do discounts for users? Uh because LLM
LLM labs of course save a lot of money
by caching and skipping all the context
prefill all the time. Uh open models can
do this as well. I think people
sometimes forget this and you can just
host open models as well uh on dedicated
compute and you can take the same
advantage of the caching. Uh so I want
to enhance uh the final price for users
is just a pricing decision. It's not a
technical challenge because everyone can
do caching. It's just what price you
pass on the users and what deals you
make with the API providers.
So this is uh being agnostic and now the
autonomy which is the core of the
software factory. Uh everyone is talking
about loops. uh loops I think have been
here the whole time already in different
context. They are just now leveling up
and moving to the context of agents. You
probably heard about dal loop and
specifying the tasks and splitting to
subtasks for agents. Uh this is a known
concept and uh the question is not the
loop itself but the question is how how
you define what it means to be done in
the loop. This is one example from my
colleague. Uh he he made a loop uh of
agents building a 3D printing of our
logo. Uh I think here you can see what
is the challenge of the loops because
before in programming loops had clear
criteria of what it means to be done
while now the criteria become open-ended
because a lot of the tasks are very
nondeterministic. It's basically open
world. can do even real stuff like
printing something and it's really
difficult to define how do you verify
that the loop was done that the task was
accomplished so that's the difficult
part
uh yeah they just need to be verifiable
this I call the scary chart it basically
shows that the tasks and how long they
run autonomously with agents have been
increasing but still it's not that
reliable even if you can run for a very
long time it doesn't mean that it will
be reliable in production and you still
probably need to need to iterate on it
and uh provide feedback. So it's still
not solved and there are problems like
cheating. For example, if you write the
what it means to be done in the wrong
way, the agent can try to pass your test
but not really like not really verify
what you need to do and accomplish but
instead try to solve just passing your
test. So cheating by that.
uh we have something called factory
missions and this is like long
longunning sessions of the agents. We
just call it missions because we send
the agent to the mission and uh the
missions work in the loop and iterating
on task until it's done and they can do
it even for weeks and uh the main agent
is orchestrator and then it's uh assigns
work to workers agents and then to
validators who review the task. So this
is one example uh real mission from our
customers that run 16 hours and just
just to see how important is the
validation as well. It takes even 40% of
the whole process. Uh to summarize the
orchestrator just decides and writes the
conditions what it needs to be done.
Then it gives it to the agents called
workers. The agents work on it. And what
is interesting or worth noting is that
they work in a sequence. So they don't
work in a swarm or parallel. The agents
work in sequence and everyone
accomplishes something and passes it to
the next one. Uh we actually found that
if you do this, you end up with more
fresh context and kind of fresh head.
Same with when with humans have like
other colleagues verifying their code.
So similar thing we just let the agents
pass to the next one. But still every
worker of the sequence can have parallel
agents doing smaller tasks. So I don't
know researching on the web or building
files during that. So they are in
sequence and everyone has sub agents as
well and validators they review the
output and provide feedback and send it
back to the beginning.
Uh important thing is uh the validators
judge code that they didn't write. Uh
there is something from the orchestrator
agent called validation contract. Uh
that's written before any code is done.
And first type is scrutiny validator.
Second is user testing validator. The
scrutiny is the one who really verifies
how the codebase looks, the interest,
types, tests. It's really rigorous check
of the code. But the second I think is
really interesting is user testing
validator and that's the one who is
really in the arena trying the things.
So it doesn't care how it was made. It
just goes, it works in its virtual
computer and it clicks on the stuff and
really checks if everything works. I've
seen one engineer migrating uh code
bases with droid with our agent and uh
it really needed the agent in the end to
click through the stuff because with
other products it just created created
the product but it didn't work and was
wasn't interactive. It was just a dummy
result. So our agent that really clicked
on the stuff uh allowed to check that
it's actually working and not just
looking good in the code. I think this
is one cool thing that was also allowed
by the progress in computer use and the
persistent environments virtual machines
for agents which also wasn't here before
or wasn't that great but now it's really
great. So it's allowing to go in the
arena as an agent. Uh this is just one
example of real mission from our users.
I I like to just learn what users are
building and get feedback. And this is
just uh how it can look in your
dashboard. And this is how I visualize
the missions. What is interesting is
that it's just a loop with smaller loops
because every of the agents are running
in loops as well. But overall, it's like
one big loop. Okay, maybe this is a bit
weird, but I just like that it's all
loops with smaller loops.
Uh okay. And the third part always
improving, always learning.
Uh there is this elephant in the room
context with agents. A lot of questions
which are valid are like how do you
navigate the context blo because you
work on these long missions in the
software factory and how do you actually
keep the context clean and that's very
valid because enterprises especially
they use hundreds tools. They use Figma,
notion, Gmail, drive, Slack like
hundreds tools on average. So all these
have specification in the code. All
these have schema and parameters and log
descriptions. So uh it can cause agent
to really bloat with that and pick wrong
tools if there are two tools that sound
similar or to actually lose context
because they fill up the the context
window and need to compress. So this is
really dangerous. Uh for this we have
something within the software factory
called uh deferred context engine and we
build it such that we just progressively
disclose what's in the context and what
tools to use. So we basically have a
surprise tools uh that help later only
if they are actually needed. So it first
just has short list of the tools and uh
only a short descriptions and when it's
needed actually in the code uh they can
call the tool and fully load it. So
important thing is nothing is actually
removed it's just hidden and not
reachable until needed. So it's just for
later and important thing is it actually
saves a lot of tokens uh at scale once
you use more and more tools. uh the more
actually you save it really scales and
you can save 50% of tokens or more.
Okay. Uh another thing which is tricky
and was surprising for me for the first
time is that when adopting AI you either
succeed big or you can fail big the same
way. It's a bit of power law. So if your
codebase is not ready, if you don't have
structured codebase and all important
things, then adopting or turning into
software factory can actually make you
end up worse and make your code
degrading and uh there is a big and
growing gap in productivity between
those who just adopted AI versus those
who actually thought about it a bit
more.
And there is another data from Stanford
about yeah without structured uh code
base and being ready and documenting
well the AI can make your code worse.
And I think if you are engineers you
probably can agree that sometimes AI
really makes a mess and this can really
compound more and more and it's
difficult to go back.
Uh we have something as a part of the
software factory uh we have something
called agent readiness and it's a
framework. I don't like the word
framework, but take it as a hygiene
check of your codebase and things you
should do because there is actually a
nice correlation between how your
codebase is looking and all the details
there and how good you're going to adopt
the AI and end up productive instead of
uh with a messy code base. So there are
things like how how reproducible is your
developer environment or if you have
written good tests if you have all
things well documented. what's the style
of your code? All the te tests and
llinters uh everything that you would do
also to keep code base clean. So these
factors actually show to be very useful
and we have our bigger customers
actually go through this agent readiness
framework and do all checks and then
they can follow up with recommended
actions uh how to fix that.
Uh I think one more thing about the
context and the continuous learning in
the software factory is the most of the
time when working with AI or at least
from my experience is that you keep
repeating to agents how how do you want
the things done and you feel like the
agent doesn't really get you and I think
this is again nice parallel with human
organizations and teams because when you
join a new company there are a lot of
rules that are not really codified
anywhere like you just learn and observe
how things are done and there are a lot
of things between the lines that you
can't really learn anywhere else than
just observing. I think this is big
challenge for agents as well and one
thing we launched for that is plugins
which are like packaged reusable skills
and context and the things behind the
scenes that you can really codify or
autok which is automatically updating
our documentations and uh yeah and um
reviewing and documenting what you have.
So the question is what will happen to
us humans if we build software factory
like this? uh will humans just lose jobs
and go to permanent underclass? I think
they will not. And uh I want to be
positive. So I'm thinking of this
parallel of humans just moving up uh
levels up to the uh to the cooler tasks
than before. I think we actually had
before the same same experience of us as
humans abstracting some levels up and we
actually started ourselves as human
computers. We actually were the
computers doing all the most detailed
stuff at the beginning. Then we had
programming languages, codifying some of
it, abstracting and then coding agents.
So outsourcing some of it but uh still
being in the loop very closely uh and
very monitoring everything. And now we
are moving kind of up to software
factories where we manage these agents
as I said orchestrator agents and
workers and validators and all these
teams structured teams of agents that
work really continuously in the loop and
we just monitor and decide what to
build. Uh so I want to really end this
positively. We should be as humans
deciding what to build in the software
not how to build it. uh because that's
up for the agents and by this uh
continuous cycle of autonomous software
I think we can actually achieve that. Uh
this is one warning chart or if someone
thinks AI will take the cool cool stuff
from us. I believe actually it will take
the annoying stuff and in enterprises
and organizations you already spend a
lot on alignments on the meetings as I
mentioned basically the thing behind
between the lines that you really need
you need to get context from everyone
share your status sing on the things on
meetings so all these things could be
actually outsourced to your software
factory and you could be just talking
about the cool stuff
okay so this is it thank you so much go
touch some grass and let your agents uh
built for you. Thank you.
Okay. Hey everyone, I am Kushan. Uh I
worked at as a founding engineer for 2
years. Let's talk about what I'm
interested in right now and that is
browser agents. Browser agents as an
idea are so cool, right? But browser
agents should go crazy, right? I
personally have not seen that at auction
and me myself, I don't use browser
agents that much. I've been exploring
that for some time. Been trying to
understand why that is. So on my screen
right now, we have the browser
challenge. But uh this is a very
interesting benchmark for browser agents
because there are so many things that
you have to do long ring sequencing of
your tasks and this actually reveals you
know why browser agents suck. If you saw
at the beginning of the video, uh the
browser, this agent took like maybe 10
20 seconds just to click the start
button. And now we're on step one. There
are 30 steps and it has taken so long
just to click one button. Um so enough
of this. I want to show you what I've
been building. So same website. Um I've
tried to sort of replicate the feeling
of seeing what's happening. You know,
you can see what the browser agent is
thinking. But as you can see, it is so
much faster and so much quicker and I'm
using a much cheaper model. Right? The
hypothesis here is models are pretty
smart, but it's the infra around them
that sucks. If you noticed in the video
earlier, maybe I'll put a screenshot.
The agent is trying to debug what's
going on. It's trying to click
something, but it doesn't understand
what's going on. So my core thesis here
has been give a nice environment for the
agent to use, right? So where it can
plan long sequences, it can figure out
where it failed, what is going on, and
it can plan the click correctly. I
figured out is a cool representation
which compresses the website and lets
the agent see the entire page in very
few few tokens. Now I wanted to show
some actual uh examples. Let's say I
want to download my Aadhaar. Um, so this
is claw trying to do it. So I'd assume
that this is very simple for our browser
agent. I take a screenshot. You see the
button right there? Click it. Uh, but
then what's interesting is that it got
stuck after this point. So from 46
seconds until the end of this video, it
took a screenshot. It scrolled for some
reason. It took a screenshot. Basically
this entire process took 2 minutes.
Whereas in my case, in our video,
so it just boots and boom, done. And
that's the beauty of a browser agent.
Just how quick was that? And I'm using
such a cheap model for this. Another
interesting example is so my friends and
I are going trekking on uh on Sunday. I
was wondering, you know what? Because
this this site is in Canada and I am not
very fluent in Canada, like it took me
some time to figure out this website. So
I asked Claude like, "Hey, can you book
this for me?" And by the end of it, it's
unable to pick a date and it's just
stuck. This is the video of my agent.
So you can see it selects it and
puts in the date and boom, done. Right?
It's so simple and convenient to use in
theory. So what's next? Right? What am I
planning on doing? Thinking of open
sourcing this project because again my
this code is not super defensible. The
product that I want to give is again
maybe an an API that as you can see we
were running these commands. Maybe I
just want to expose this command as an
API. Give me a URL. Give me your intent
and I will execute it for you and give
it back to you and or maybe open this as
a website or expose this as a plug-in.
But yeah, so bottom line is I want to
make browser agents faster, cheaper, and
more reliable. And just make sure
everybody in the world is using them
because they can just do so much for
you. So yeah, that's the broad idea
here. Thank you for watching.
This entire markdown
presents the website that particular
page. And let's actually do this
interesting comparison, right? Let's go
to AIS2. The full DOM for this would be
around 20,000 tokens. But so let's say
we have this screenshot, right? This
screenshot is about 1,100 tokens. My
Macd about 1,800 tokens. And instead in
one screen where you can see only one
particular snippet, you can see the
entire website, right? A couple of other
things that it's important to give
feedback, right? So we say that okay,
hey, these are the new things that have
popped up on the page. This is now gone,
right? And similarly, we can say that
you know this thing that was blocking a
thing that you wanted to click has now
been removed. you know we give it
feedback that you tried to click this
but that didn't happen because you know
we're keeping track of the entire end to
end browser page right so all of this
together what I've built is a very clean
representation that that basically
compresses the website and you can give
this along with the screenshots pretty
cheap token wise um so the model can
reason well and then it can construct
this long sequence of tasks to execute
>> hi everybody welcome to our talk the
agentic AI engineer I'm
CEO and co-founder of Mutagent and I'm
here with my colleague.
>> Hi, I'm Burak. I'm the CTO of Mutagent
and today we're basically going to talk
about loops and how the agentic AI
engineer works.
So as you all are aware of now loops is
the hot topic how you build software in
an agentic loop and uh we apply the same
loop to the building of AI agents and as
you're all aware there's uh two concepts
here one is the offline loop where while
you build you iterate um on your agent
you test it you evaluate it you improve
it and you go on and then you have a
second loop which is we call the online
loop where once your agent is deployed
to production, you monitor its traces,
you diagnosis and then you feed it back
into your optimization loop. Uh yeah, to
iterate and have multiple versions of
your agents.
Yeah, up to until now um what we did was
uh this doing this loop manually it's
quite slow. Um the life cycle is
basically um you have an issue. Um you
want to change something to your agent.
Um yeah, you implement the change. Um
you maybe VIP implement the change if
you use coding agents for it. Um yeah,
you generate some samples for this new
feature or issue to test it. Um yeah,
then you look at the result. You look
through the traces. How does the outcome
look like? Then you maybe ship it. You
do AB testing. And all your feedback is
kind of manually. it takes very long. Um
yeah and uh the the bottleneck basically
becomes the human uh review and the
human yeah building time and uh yeah
that you can't scale especially if in
your organization you're now planning to
roll out hundreds of agents uh etc.
Yeah. And uh yeah, this is why we think
the agentic AI engineer is the natural
next step to build agents. And I'll have
Burak deep dive into how we improve
timing and the the road to production
reliability with the agentic engineer.
Uh so yeah the key thing here is
basically once you reach a certain
number of agents or AI based features
the human performing this loop again
cannot really scale in enough time. So
this is why doing this agentically is
the key to increasing the throughput
because then you can fit many more
cycles into the same time window. And
now how that loop works is
basically we have a few stages. So this
is when you are starting from scratch
like the current software development
practices. You first create a spec for
your agent or your skill in this case.
And here you need to define all the
responsibilities and the functions that
agents needs to handle the decisions
that it has to make on certain
conditions.
And here again this is only the
definition stage once you defined your
agents requirements.
Hello
I was at a wedding this weekend and it
was in New York and there were a bunch
of trendy people there and uh I I told I
was talking to someone who I'd never met
before and uh I told him I was prepping
for this presentation and he was like,
"Oh, that's cool. Like what's the
conference about?" And I said it was
about AI engineering. And I could just
see his eyes glaze over and he started
like looking behind me to find the next
person to talk to. And I'm it's like so
cool to actually be in a room full of
people who actually want to hear about
this stuff. So I I'm very excited to be
here. Um I am the co-founder of
Conductor. Um has anyone here used
Conductor?
Okay. Nice. Nice. Okay. Cool. So uh uh
for those who don't know, Conductor is a
desktop app for managing a team of
coding agents all at the same time. So
instead of having a bunch of terminal
windows for your cloud codes or your
codeexes or your uh whatever uh coding
agent, you have one interface to manage
them all. And one of the really cool
things about building conductor has been
that I've seen a lot of the best
builders up close. I've like watched
their workflow. I've seen how they work.
I've seen the things they do do and the
things that they avoid doing. And so I
thought I would compile a bunch of the
principles um that I've seen the best
engineers use um and give them to you
all. Um so here's what conductor looks
like. Uh can you can you guys see this?
Okay, nice. Okay, so here's what
conductor looks like. Um and here are my
principles for being the fastest builder
in your organization. So let's start
with number one. Stay near the frontier.
Staying near the frontier means you are
always trying the latest things
basically the day they come out. Uh it
means that when uh Ultra Code comes out
you're trying it. It means that when uh
uh slashgo comes out you're giving it a
go. Um it's really important to stay
near the frontier um for a few reasons.
Um if you are doing your own startup
then staying near the frontier means
that you will um come up with lots of
new ideas for what you should actually
be building. And this literally happened
to us. We were building a totally
different app called Chorus. Um, but we
started using we were such power users
of cloud code back in February of last
year that we uh started building our
whole workflow around cloud code and we
started cloning our repo five times and
then we discovered work trees and then
bit by bit we had built conductor as an
internal tool and we couldn't have
figured that out if we uh weren't
staying near the frontier. And if you're
not doing a startup, you should be the
person at your company who always knows
what the latest uh the latest workflows
are. Um it used to be that you could
just kind of like use your social graph
and the information that was important
about the best workflows to use would
trickle down to you, but things just
like move way too fast now. You're
you're always going to be three to six
months behind if you do that. Um so it's
a very important to stay near the
frontier. And there's an important word
here near. Um there is a danger if you
are at the frontier. Um you can you can
do what uh I call midwip memeing where
you're spending all of your time working
on your workflow and not doing actual
work. And so internally we've come up
with a heristic for this. Um we call it
don't beat the market. Don't try and
beat the market. Um uh the concept here
like the heruristic you should use when
you're trying to decide if you're near
the frontier or at the frontier and uh
too deep in into uh uh the latest trends
is you should ask yourself why isn't
this workflow the default. So, for
example, um when uh Ralph loops were
becoming a big thing, uh uh you should
ask yourself like should I spend a ton
of time optimizing my workflow to work
with Ralph loops? Um because if Ralph
loops work for everyone, like if they
are the default, um then you probably
should just wait for Anthropic or OpenAI
or whatever to build the uh workflow
into the into the default harness. Um,
you could think of this as sort of like
an efficient market hypothesis where um,
unless you have like real alpha, uh, you
shouldn't be optimizing your workflow
too much. Um, and what I mean by real
alpha is like some kind of information
about either your users or your codebase
that the models might not know about. So
an example for us is we it's we we're a
chat app. we have to render really long
chats really quickly and performance is
is important to us and so we need to
spend a lot of time optimizing our React
queries uh to uh render the chats
quickly and we're willing to make
sacrifices um in other parts of our
codebase to make that happen. Um so if
you have some kind of alpha like some
kind of information about the app you're
building that the models might not know
about then you should put time into the
workflow. Otherwise don't don't midweet
meme. Don't don't be the person who has
an amazing Emac setup but like doesn't
actually get stuff done.
Okay. Three, create slot free zones. So
at Conductor, we have this term we call
a slot-free zone. And a slot-free zone
is a part of the codebase or a part of
the app that requires really strict
human review. Um, and we're actually I
think a little bit unusual in this way.
I think a lot of people assume that we
are pure token maxers and we are like
ripping through like 30,000 line PRs,
but we're actually not. We're actually
quite careful with certain parts of our
codebase and then very loose with other
parts of our codebase. Um, the reason
this is important is because if you are
not careful about your slot free zones,
your your code your codebase can get in
a really tricky spot. Um, and this
actually happened to us. We we've had to
rewrite our whole app like a couple of
times because we weren't careful about
slot freezones. Um specifically we have
a uh migrations file and uh in our CI uh
any change to the migrations file
requires the a uh a human to review it.
Um we also assume that anything written
in Slack is slop free. It's it's not
written by the AI, it's written by a
human. all of our docs, um, all our
cloud MDs, like all our skills, we put a
ton of time into making them good. Um,
and this is also something I've seen
with all the the the best builders up
close, like they put an unusual amount
of time into the cloud MD or their skill
files. Um, and I I think like another
way that I've thought about this is like
if you had a a new intern that was
joining your company and you had the
opportunity to like whisper something in
their ear every time they started
working, like every day, anytime they
sat down, you could like whisper
something in their ear, you would
probably put a lot of thought into like
what it is that you're whispering in
their ear. And this is what the cloud MD
or agents uh MD is. It's like
information that gets loaded into the
agents context every time they start
working. Um, and so you probably want to
put a lot of thought into uh into those.
Um, okay. Four, feed the beast. Uh, at
Conductor, we have a uh internal tool we
call the conductor internal agent. Um,
and it is uh we also also known as the
CIA. And the CIA is basically like the
the uh centralized database of
everything that's happening in the
organization. So anytime a new Slack
message gets sent, the CIA picks it up.
The CIA agent will see that a new
message sent in Slack. It will pick it
up and it will save it to a Postgress uh
uh table. Anytime a user has a bug
request in Discord, the same thing
happens. Anytime we have a meeting, we
are recording it uh and it goes into the
CIA. Um, we call this feed the beast
because you you want to for your agents
to be effective uh in your company, you
want them to have as much information
and as much context as they can have
about the way you guys specifically
work. And the best way to do that is by
having a centralized place for all the
information to go. Uh, I think this this
tweet sums it up pretty well. uh uh it's
really effective to just put everything
in a database and then give your agent a
SQL tool and let it handle uh uh handle
the rest.
Okay, next is free range agents.
Give your agents a lot of space to play.
Give them give them a sandbox where they
that won't get killed, where they can
explore your codebase, where they can
work on really hard tasks, where they
can they know that they're not going to
get shut down when you close your laptop
lid. Uh give them give them
opportunities to create more of
themselves. Um give them ways uh to
collaborate with other agents and other
humans. Um, I think what's really
interesting about freerange agents and
like this this concept and why this is
important is the models are getting
better and they are able to run for much
longer and they're going to be many more
of them. And so if they are confined to
your laptop, then the they're not going
to be nearly as effective as uh as if
they are free roaming. Um, the other
thing that's important here is that once
you give them a a sandbox to play in
that isn't confined to your laptop,
there's a bunch of really cool stuff
that you can build on top. Um, and we
have built some of those things into
Conductor. And I uh I'll give you a
quick glimpse into into some of those
cool things.
So,
this is Conductor. I'm going to make it
a bit bigger. Um, and this is actually a
new version of Conductor that is uh
coming out this week and it is centered
around collaboration in the cloud. And
so the the import the thing I said was
you need a spa a sandbox for agents to
play. You need a free-range agent. And
so you'll notice that each workspace has
a little cloud icon at the top and I can
click it and get information about the
sandbox that the agent is running in.
Um, and what's what's awesome about this
is I can close my laptop and the agents
are going to keep running. Up up up
until basically this week, every uh
every task in conductor was built on a
git work tree, but now they're in a
cloud sandbox. They are free range
agents. But what's also really cool um
that you can that we have built on top
of uh cloud is collaboration.
So you'll see here I'll make this even
bigger. That's me and here are lists of
the things that I am working on. And you
can see that I'm in the conductor or But
if I scroll down, I can see what Kaden's
working on. I can see what Lewis is
working on. I can see what Tywin is
working on. And I can I can I can see
that I can see Jackson's face pop up
there. I can click in and see what he's
working on in real time. Um, and I think
collaboration is the the one one of the
most important new concepts uh in these
tools that no one is really talking
about right now. Um, collaboration is
important because not only as not only
is it true that all great things are
built with teams of people, like they're
not built by individuals. They're built
by teams. Um, but also as the models get
better, um, as we've seen this with the
two days of Fable, you can get a lot
more ambitious with the kinds of things
you're building. And if you're getting
more ambitious, you're going to need
more people and more agents to work on
those things. So, I'm going to go into
an a workspace that Kaden is working on.
uh this one. And I'm gonna say um I can
review the changes that he's made. Um
I'll make this a little smaller. And
this looks fine, but I'm just going to
say uh can we actually use tabs spaces?
And Cadence should be able to see that
message happen in real time. And he can
actually chat in the workspace as well.
So, we can see here that he's typing.
So, I see Ken is typing. Let's see what
he says.
Seems like he's typing a lot.
Okay, maybe he stopped typing.
I'll give him a second to take a look at
it. So the point is we can now have
collaborative workspaces that are shared
in real time with people on our team.
Um, okay, he's typing again.
Okay, come back. The agents have
escaped.
All right, so uh I'm really excited
about this and we're rolling this out to
uh all Conductor users this week. Um I
think I think collaboration is going to
be one of the most important uh one of
the most important new interface changes
uh this year. Um the other really cool
thing about cloud is that um and giving
the agents the free range sandbox is
that we can give the agents APIs to
spawn themselves. So I have here a uh
I'll bring up my open claw. Uh this is
my open claw called Lord Crandon.
And you can see that it has I don't know
h how well you can see this text but it
has access to a conductor API. And so
from my phone or from my telegram or
from really or from Slack or wherever I
am I can say hi can you create a new
workspace for me that makes uh yeah
makes all the buttons blue.
And so I'll I'll text that to Lord
Crandon and Lord Crandon has access to
the conductor API and so it can kick off
work itself. Um so let's see what it
does here.
Okay. So it just created the workspace.
The agent is on it and then I can go
into my conductor whe I'm out and about
but it's still setting up the workspace
and uh it will do work for me while I am
gone.
So, I'm pretty excited about all the uh
all the cool things you can build on top
of of uh freerange agents.
Okay,
the final principle that I want to talk
about today um and the title of this
talk is orchestras not factories.
The whole like talk track today is about
software factories and I honestly kind
of hate the term. I think it's the wrong
way of thinking about these new tools
that are emerging. I think like when I
think of a factory, I think of
automation and I think of uh like
there's a lot of amazing things about
automation and like it makes our lives
more efficient and we can like create
more of everything. But the I don't want
the future to be built around factories.
I want the future to I want to feel like
a human. I want to like be in the flow.
I want to be like in front of an
orchestra like waving my baton and and
like I wave it this way and this this
team of agents starts working and then
this intermingling of humans and agents
starts working as I go here and I when I
want to I can zoom in on the details but
most of the time I can zoom out and I
don't think the future should be we are
like managing swarms of agents and we
are like factory line managers like
pushing buttons getting the agents to
like pump out the next feature like we
we we tried this like 10 years ago with
the term feature uh feature factories
and it just doesn't work. Like I want my
software to feel human and crafted. Um I
want to feel like a human at the center
of it all. And I think because we're all
building these tools, we actually have a
responsibility to make the tools um
great for humans. I think it's really
important to like use the words that
make us feel excited and like feel uh
feel capable and feel uh like we're in
the flow and having fun. And so I don't
think the future is uh is is something
like this. I don't want to be I don't
want to be in in my dark factory. Um I
don't want to be a line manager. I want
to feel like this. I want to be in the
flow. I want to be having fun. I want to
be crafting things. I want to feel like
I'm Steve Jobs designing the Mac with a
team of amazing humans and AI agents all
in the same place. Like I want to feel
like I'm in an orchestra.
So, here are my principles for uh for
being the best builder in your
organization. Uh stay near the frontier.
Don't try and beat the market. Create
slot-free zones. Feed the beast. Free
range agents. And think about
orchestras, not factories.
Came up with this handy acronym for for
remembering it. Stickfo. All right. So,
thanks thanks a ton for uh for having
me. I'll be around. feel free to ask
questions and uh I'll see you on the
internet.
Okay, I want to tell you a story about a
factory that taught itself how to
remember. Hi, I'm Rushab. I run machine
a 100 people factory in India. No data
science team, no ML budget, none of
that. And somehow we ended up building a
36 AI agent that runs our entire go to
market. I think that's still a little
ridiculous. Let me show you how it
happened and why you can do the same
thing.
So here's the thing about our company.
From the outside, it looks like machines
and metal. But the actual company, the
part that matters isn't the machines, is
the knowledge. who the customer is, what
we quoted them in 2019, why that one
machine needed that weird custom tweak.
And for three generations, all of that
lived in exactly three brains.
Initially, my grandfather's, then my
father's, and now mine,
which is a genuinely terrifying way to
run a company when you sit with it. A
lot of people have joined us. People
have left us. The revolving door never
stopped.
And every single time someone walked
out, a chunk of our brain walked out
with them.
We weren't scared of the competitors. We
were scared of forgetting or waking up
one day and realizing the whole company
only existed inside two increasingly
tired heads.
So, I had an idea. I'll be honest.
Sounded insane first. But what if
instead of writing the knowledge down in
some document nobody ever reads, what if
we grew a brain that just held it? Not a
chatbot you poke at, a twin of the
company. I didn't hire a sales team. I
tried to build one.
A quick detour because you need to know
how messy this is. We make
thermopforming machines. They heat up a
plastic sheet and shape it. same core
machine, but it ends up making
hydroponic farm trays, spa bathtubs, EV
car panels, medical casings, and even
packaging.
Seven totally different worlds, seven
totally different buyers. So, this brain
couldn't just memorize a brochure. It
had to know which universe
a given customer lives in.
Step one was almost boringly simple.
Feed it everything. And I mean
everything. Years of courts, drawings,
payment schedules, timelines, email
threads, hundreds of gigabytes of our
own private history. Not the public
internet, our internet.
And here's the plot twist, the part that
surprises every engineer I tell this to.
We never trained a model. No GPUs
humming in the basement, no fine-tuning.
We just looked at all the history,
chopped it into bite-sized chunks, and
let offshelf models, read it, and pull
out the facts. We stored the meaning of
each chunk as vectors and relationships.
Who's connected to what as a graph? The
brain is in a smarter model. It's
actually a really, really well organized
memory.
Now, this is where it gets a little
weird in a good way. We stopped thinking
of era as a software and started
thinking of it as something we were
raising. So we gave it a body modeled on
biology senses to figure out who it's
talking to, a gut to digest the
documents into facts, a memory, a dream
cycle, an immune system to fight off bad
information. Why biology? Well, because
evolution already spent a billion years
solving, how do you stay coherent over
time? We just copied the homework.
Okay, so the big question, why 36 agents
instead of one genius mega prompt?
Because, and you already know this if
you've ever tried it, one prompt that's
supposed to do everything ends up doing
everything badly. So isn't one mind.
It's a pantheon. A whole cast of
specialists.
Each one has exactly one job. Athena
runs the room. Prometheus owns the sale.
Plutus does pricing. Hippastas knows
every machine spec gold. Vera fact
checks everything. And Memon, my
favorite, guards corrections. So the
second a human fixes something, it stays
fixed forever. One agent, one job. It's
a team, not a hero. And here's the cool
part. They hold meetings. Athena pulls
in specialists. They actually argue and
a single answer comes out the other
side. It's like having a boardroom that
never sleeps, never gets tired, and
somehow has no ego.
So, what does all this actually run?
Honestly, the whole front business,
everything between a stranger exists
somewhere and now they're a customer.
Nine concrete jobs every single day.
Outbound emails that actually reference
my real world. Account briefs build from
cross-cheed truths before a call.
Quotations. A swipe left, swipe right
mode for outreach. Reviving dead leads,
which I call blast from the blast.
Inbound replies and figuring out before
we waste an hour whether a company is
even a fit. Nine jobs, one operator who
never sleeps.
Where does all this live? One cursor
tab. That's genuinely it. You type and a
reaches out with a dozen hands, searches
the knowledge base, reads the inbox,
drafts the email, builds the code, and
then shows you before anything actually
goes out. Under the hood is genuinely a
real stack, not a demo held together
with the tape. databases for vectors for
relationship graph for the CRM. Three
different model providers each picked
for the job it's actually best for tools
for Google for swallowing documents for
every communication channel plus
monitoring so we can see what it's
thinking. All of it, every capability
exposed as 213 tools over one protocol.
And the golden rule, the one we never
break, era drafts, human settings.
Now, memory, and this is the part where
most AI quietly lies to you because a
raw language model is basically a
goldfish. Brilliant for about 30 seconds
and then you close the tab and forgets
you ever existed.
So we engineered memory on purpose in
layers, working memory for the last few
minutes, pinned facts about someone who
is episodes, whole conversations as
little stories, relationships with
warmth that grows from stranger to
trusted and a bouncer at the door. A
salience gate that decides what's even
worth remembering so the brain doesn't
fill up.
achieve without making things up.
>> Hey, my name is D. I am one of the
co-founders of a company called Grapile.
And at Grapile, we are working on AI
agents that review and test poll
requests with full context of the
codebase. The way we do this is when you
open a pull request, Gravile reads all
the files. It uses a knowledge base of
the codebase to understand what could
potentially be affected. It also runs
your code in a sandbox to find various
issues. But I don't want to talk about
reptile today. What I want to talk about
is something very interesting. So when I
first moved to San Francisco 3 years ago
was when AI coding had really just
started to work. And what we had at the
time was copilot with tab complete and
later cursor with more advanced tab
complete. In 2024 AI agents got a little
bit better and we started to see
multifile edits. This was with cursor
and early versions of cloud code. In
2025 something interesting started to
happen which is the agents got
increasingly autonomous. And December of
2025 was the turning point for anyone
that's working in AI coding or using AI
to code. They understand that those
models were fundamentally different from
the ones that came before and that they
were completely autonomous. They could
go from ticket to pull request. And from
there, Twitter seemed to be full of
stories of people experimenting with
polyphasic sleep to keep their agents
alive and building large amounts of code
all at once. And to me, it seemed like
this was something that was possible
inside the realm of maybe indie hacker
projects or startups, but not in the
enterprise, which was all of the
companies that we were working with. And
this notion that I had that truly
agentic coding could not take off the
enterprise was starting to get
challenged because I heard many reports
of people doing this stuff in the
enterprise and that it was really
working.
And so I got really curious. Are these
fully vibr?
Can you do this in a large scale company
with real customers? And in what ways
did they fail when they did fail? So as
an amateur data scientist, I decided to
dive into the data and see what came of
it. And the first thing I discovered was
it's actually very hard to figure out
which PRs are fully vibe coded. At
Grapal, we work with tens of thousands
of teams. And we have this interesting
place where we're not the coders, but
only the reviewers of the code. But all
this code goes through our system at any
of these companies. Companies like
Nvidia and Coinbase and Scale, real
companies with real customers and
critical workflows. Identifying which
PRs were vibe coded was difficult, but I
decided to give it a shot. And the first
thing that I tried was I looked for the
GitHub author field. Every commit in
GitHub has to have a field for the
author. And I figured that if the author
was attributed to codeex or cloud code,
that was pretty strong evidence that
that was a fully vi PR. But I found of
all the PRs and again more than a
million poll requests go through GPU
every month. Only about one out of every
hundred were attributed to an agent in
the author field. Intuitively, this
didn't make sense to me. couldn't be
that only 1% of all PRs were fully
vioded.
And so I started looking for PR
description fitters. Turns out these
agents are as narcissistic as humans
are. And they like to leave traces that
they were the ones that worked on the
code. And so Claude would leave a
co-authored by Claude and Codex would
leave a co-authored by Codex. And that
seemed to help a little bit. The third
thing I looked at was branch prefixes.
Codex actually names the branches for
you. And it seemed to me intuitively
that if someone was using codeex to
produce the branch names, there was
pretty good evidence that most of that
PR was vioded.
I found that in the month of April, more
than a quarter of all PRs that Gretal
reviewed had evidence of being, if not
fully, at least largely vibecoded.
Then I tracked this number back to the
previous 12 months and it turns out that
the rate of change is incredibly fast.
About a year ago, less than a percent of
all poll requests had evidence of being
fully vibe coded. And in April, that
number was more than a quarter and
trending upwards.
And then became the real question. Are
these PRs any good? Are real companies
doing this? Are they any good? Can you
merge this stuff? Is this just slop or
is it real good software?
And of course, then the question
becomes, what does it mean for a poll
request to be good? What does it mean
for a vibe coded or a human written poll
request to be good? So then I started to
do some statistical analysis around PR
quality.
And the first thing that I looked at was
revert rates. GitHub lets you revert
pull requests. And it seemed reasonable
that if a pull request was reverted, it
must have not been very good. And so I
started tracking reverts across our
entire customer base. Conveniently,
GitHub labels reverted branches with
revert dash and then the name of the PR.
And so I started looking at the rates at
which poll requests were being reverted.
This is the data that I found with
Codeex. about one out of every thousand
poll requests seem to be reverted. For
Devon, that number was three and a half.
And for humans, interestingly, for PRs
where there was reasonable evidence that
it was written largely by a person or at
least owned by a person, that number was
around two and a half. These numbers are
fairly within range. They're all small,
less than a percent. And all kind of
within range of each other.
So, I started looking at some other
pieces of evidence because I was very
convinced that these vibe coder PRs
aren't good. So, I was really looking
for evidence that that was true. So the
next thing I looked at was are the river
rates different by size because it
seemed that it was possible that people
were making agents do simpler work. It
was the straightforward well- definfined
tickets that agents were working on and
humans were taking on the more complex
tasks and that's why the revert rates
were similar. And it seemed like PR size
was a good proxy for complexity of a
change. But it turns out that revert
rates actually stayed relatively stable
across different sizes. There wasn't
even a real pattern that said that
agents were working on smaller or
simpler tasks. It turns out revert rates
were pretty even across the board for
agents and for humans.
The next thing I looked at was Graptile
comments. If Gretile's the reviewing and
testing and validating agent for all of
this code, it seemed reasonable that it
would find more issues in code that was
worse. And Gretile conveniently labels
all the issues with P 0, P1's or P2s.
And so I started tracking the rates at
which Graptile finds P 0, P1's, and P2s
across poll requests that are written by
people versus ones written entirely by
AI.
Once again, there just was not that much
of a difference between the human
written and AI written pull requests. In
fact, humans were actually more likely
to make P 0 errors than Devon and CEX or
claw.
Similarly the case with P1's where both
Devon and Codex created fewer P1s and
P2s were even closer. Once again, there
just wasn't that much evidence that the
agent written PRs were meaningfully
worse or more critically damaged than
their human written counterparts.
The next thing I looked at with review
rounds. A very common pattern for using
Reptile is that you have it review a
pull request, give it some comments, and
then you let the agent fix those
comments, make another commit on the
pull request, and usually two rounds is
enough for all of the issues from the
pull request to be addressed and for the
pull request to be ready to to be
merged. It seemed reasonable that a
smarter, more capable author for a poll
request would be able to get to a
mergeable PR with fewer review rounds.
That seemed intuitively true to me. And
so I started tracking average number of
review rounds. With Devon, a little over
two. For people, 2.2. For Codex, two and
a half. Once again, entirely within a
range. The mean number of iterations it
took for an agent or a person to get a
pull request to a mergeable state was
fairly consistent throughout. Once
again, no evidence of agentic PRs being
worse.
So now that there wasn't any strong
evidence that these were quantitatively
worse or better, I was interested in
seeing if there were patterns of failure
that were different in agent written PRs
and human written PRs. Were they bad in
different ways? And so I started
tracking some interesting data around
that.
Here's how I did it. So Guptile leaves
comments on all of these pull requests.
It tends to identify all kinds of logic
performance and security errors. And so
I decided to run a very simple text
search and said, "Okay, are types of
errors in different agents different for
different sites." Now the data set here
is quite large. It's in the millions of
poll requests. And so this data is
reasonably high confidence. And of
course, you can't use old data. So I
only used about two months of data since
prior to that the agents are essentially
obsolete. And I saw some very
interesting data points. Claude, for
instance, is one and a half times more
likely than people to produce a SQL
injection error. off bypasses are half
as likely coming from Devon than from
any other agent and for people.
And another interesting data point, but
N plus1 query errors were much more
common in cursor than any other agent.
Far more common. And so it was
interesting to me that there were this
much variation in the qualitative
aspects of what these agents were
getting wrong when there was so much
consistency in how good or bad they were
measured in many different ways.
So it might turn out that autonomous
agents are actually quite good. And this
is very exciting to me because to an
extent I'd kind of become a programmer
before AI had taken off and I was used
to like many of us the craft of
programming and it seemed like a lot of
the vibecoded agents that we were seeing
in 2024 and 2025 were a lot more
promised and substance especially when
applied to professional commercial
settings. But the trajectory seems quite
clear. These agents are getting really,
really good. And they're getting really
good at coding not only in general
environments. Reptile's customer base is
made up much more of larger companies
than it is of individual coders. Of
course, individual coders don't really
review their code or don't need to. And
so this sample set is essentially
created from companies with real
customers. And it turns out that they
actually can do a lot of true vibe
coding in a commercial setting.
So we started thinking about what that
means for code review and code
validation. If most of the code is going
to be written entirely by agents and it
seems like the agents are writing pretty
good code then what should code review
look like? I think a couple things are
very clear. Interesting data point that
emerged from my statistical analysis is
that there was quite a bit of a
difference between the 99th percentile
of coders and the 50th percentile of
coders in terms of how much code they're
writing. In fact, the median coder that
uses Graptile is writing fewer than 50
commits a month. The 99th percentile is
writing close to a thousand commits a
month. At that scale, it is completely
infeasible, especially if this is going
to be the standard for how people code
to do anything resembling manual code
review. It also seems not very intuitive
that we would be maintaining large test
suites. As Grubile, we got really
excited about this idea that we could
build truly autonomous code validation.
We started thinking about what that
means. And of course, code validation in
the prior era was made up of these three
general facets. You'd have testing,
you'd have review, and you have quality
assurance. But to us, these seem like
implementation details. The goal of code
validation was actually just to answer
three very simple questions. Does this
change violate the user contract? Two,
does this change increase the future
propensity of a user contract violation?
And third, does it fulfill what the
author intended? And so we've designed
Reptile from the ground up to do exactly
that, to answer those three questions.
We do this by reviewing the code of
course in a more traditional sense where
we use agents to look at the code, look
at the blast radius of the change files
outside of the diff that could be
affected or related and then we run the
code in a sandbox, click around with web
browser agents to try to break things,
simulate users in a sense. And that has
turned out to be a much more effective
path towards truly autonomous code
validation because it's hard for me to
imagine that this idea that humans would
be reviewing large amounts of agent code
and that will become the new job of
software engineer is quite dystopian. I
I don't think I want to wake up every
morning and review SLO all day. I would
much rather spend the time coming up
with the genius ideas and letting
machines figure out how to turn that
into commercial grade code.
That's my talk. My name is D and you can
try Reptile today.
You should also come visit us at our
booth. We have an arcade machine. Thank
you so much.
Hi, I'm Amole, CEO of Nori Agentic. We
deploy an AI employee that understands
your company, your code, docs, Slack,
and other kinds of data. We spend a lot
of time thinking about how coding agents
really work. Most people think coding
agents only write code, but if you ask
me, that's just bad marketing. Forget
the name for a second. Coding agents can
do almost anything. There's just one
trick. You have to be able to think like
an agent to get it to do what you want
it to do.
Today we're going to talk about how we
use coding agents to do something most
people think agents are terrible at.
Make visual artifacts like slides, docs,
and yeah, even video.
Every day, the world pours something
like 34,000 human years into making
slide decks. Most of that time isn't the
thinking, it's the fiddling. A deck that
takes 10 hours should really take about
25 minutes once you remove all the
formatting and the branding and the
moving things around. Say you need to
make a slide. What do you do? You open a
tool, PowerPoint, Slides, Figma, Canva,
and then you start manipulating a
canvas. Every one of these tools is
built for human hands and human eyes.
Click, drag, drop, resize, snap to grid.
All motions and patterns that make sense
for our geospatial view of the world.
There is a data structure underneath,
but it's in a format that only the
application can read. What happens when
you hand these tools to an agent? Well,
the output comes out all wrong. Things
overlap in weird ways. You can't see the
text. There's no alignment. It's just
garbage. AI skeptics say that it's not
just the tools. agents fundamentally
can't reason about space. And there are
whole benchmarks like Arc AGI that are
built exactly around that premise.
There's a famous little test for this
from developer Simon Willis. He asks
every new model the same thing. Can you
draw a pelican riding a bicycle? But
there's a trick. The agent is only
allowed to use SVG.
It's a quick gut check for whether a
model can reason about space at all.
Here's some examples of what the models
actually give you on this test. And
yeah, these are pretty bad. Like
genuinely, deeply really bad. So, does
that mean it's hopeless? Agents are just
doomed to be bad at graphics? No, I
don't think so. If you ask me, it's not
the model, it's the medium. If I asked
you, someone who is presumably human, to
handw write an SVG of a pelican, you
wouldn't be able to do that either. SVGs
are just a wall of numbers. You can't go
from a wall of numbers to a pelican. You
just can't see that way. That's just not
how people think. We think graphically.
So, we build tools that let us draw on a
canvas. Figma, MCP's, PowerPoint, CLIs,
screenshot and replace loops. What do
all of these agent tools have in common?
They all approach the problem like a
human. But an AI is not a human. Asking
an AI to use a canvas is like asking a
human to write SVG by hand. It doesn't
really make sense. You need to give the
AI tools based on how it thinks, not in
pixels, in language. Words, tokens,
structure. That is its native medium.
Imagine a language that's incredible at
describing layout, that models have seen
and trained on billions of examples of
that they understand intuitively, that
renders to pixels and can run
everywhere.
Oh, right. HTML lets a model think in
structure. HTML tags have meanings built
into the language, a heading, a chart, a
grid, and the browser turns it all into
pixels. So the model never actually
places a coordinate and you can get all
sorts of visual effects, charts and
layouts, fonts and motion, all of it for
free. Remember that pelican from
earlier? Now ask it to do the same exact
task, but in HTML. Same bird, but now
it's in a structure that the model can
reason about. And you can read and theme
and edit every single line of it.
I spent my whole life building slide
decks with PowerPoint. So, I always
thought that those two things, slide
decks and PowerPoint, were synonyms. But
that's just not really true, is it?
PowerPoint is a tool that you use to
make slide decks. The deck itself,
that's just the presentation mode. And
as it turns out, no one in your audience
is going to care how you got to the
presentation mode. The editing format is
totally arbitrary. So you can just pick
the editing format that the agents are
already good at HTML and if you need to
render to a different format like PDF
later on. We use this HTML trick to
build all of our slide decks, our board
decks and our sales decks. These are
real things that we actually present and
send out constantly. We use it for our
docs, too. It gives our docs color and
vibrancy all while following our brand.
And of course, we also use it to make
videos like this one. What you're
watching is just HTML and CSS. It's
literally just divs all the way down.
Almost everything is better with a
little structure and a little bit of
color. Plain text is a choice, generally
a choice of convenience, but it's
usually the wrong one if you're actually
trying to create something of use.
Now, I do want to take a quick beat here
and point out that a beautiful deck on
its own is generally not worth anything.
You still have to go and get all of that
content, all of the things that actually
populate that deck, right? Well, again,
we can think like the model. If you just
give the model access to your data, say
your call transcripts or your emails,
you can have the model build the deck
end to end. Let your agents do all the
grunt work while you focus on vision and
story. That's what Nory Sessions lets
you do. I've built entire board decks
for my phone on the subway during my
commute. Why? Because our Norybot lives
in the fabric of our company. Of course,
Nory ships with everything you need to
make this all work. So, don't bother
reinventing the wheel. That's my little
Thanks for listening. If you have just
one takeaway, it's this. Stop thinking
like a user. Think like the model. Give
it the right language. And for graphics,
all you need is HTML.
Hi everyone, 10X. You feel it yet? Hi,
my name is Zion and I'm a mobile
software engineer for the last 14 years
and I'm here to talk to you today about
10X, reimagining the mobile dev
workflow.
So, you know, back in the old times when
cursor was that thing you make with your
mouse and AI agents were that dystopian
character from sci-fi books or movies,
whatever fits your style, you know, just
a few months back then when we thought
that we will still be using our IDE just
maybe slightly better. And now we know
that we already switch to like chat
style um engineering when we discuss
with cloud code codex cursor whatever um
and we just tell them what to do and we
don't use our IDs unless it's for
debugging or something that the agent
couldn't figure out and that in theory
should have made us 10 times more
productive right that's what everybody
says right with are we 10 times more
productive do you feel it I don't know
because I can't feel that we are 10
times more productive not as single
engineer and not as a whole group and
not as the whole company. So why is
that? Why don't we don't see the promise
of 10 times more productive came to an
actual life.
So you know they tell the story about
how when factories switched from steam
engines to electric engines at first
they didn't see that big of a gain. So
yeah, the electric engines were better.
They were more efficient, but they
didn't see that 10x, 20x, 30x uh more
productiveness that they have been
promised. And the reason for that was
that they only changed the steam engine
with the electric engine. But the real
gain came some years afterwards when
they understand that it's not only about
changing the engine, it's about changing
the whole workflow. Because you see,
they used to have like one giant big
steam engine in the factory and all of
the machines were rearranged
based on their power consumption and
their proximity to that steam engine.
So it wasn't organized by the workflow
that it should have been like from the
start to the end of the workflow. No, it
was designed by proximity to that
central engine. When they realized that
and they also realized that they could
take the electric engine, make it
smaller and put it inside each machine
and then they rearranged the factory to
make it work as the workflow should
because now it it was made possible.
Then the real gain came. Now they were
10 times, 20 times, 30 times more
productive than they were before. Not
because of only changing the engine but
of changing the whole workflow. And that
is what I want to talk to you about
today. Let's think how AI make things
that weren't possible before possible
now. And we can change our workflow and
then becoming 10 times 20 times more
productive.
To do that, let's look at the current
workflows. The PMs have an idea. They
iterate with the designers. They iterate
with the user. They iterate with the
dev. They iterate then back with the
designer. Then they iterate with the QA.
And they iterate back with the dev. And
maybe after all those iterations maybe
you have something in production.
So what was that word that was repeating
so many times? Yeah, iteration. And this
is the problem
because iteration creates friction.
Each iteration creates context switch
create time waste creates communication
that needed to be done syn
synchronization that needed to be done
and AI didn't eliminate all of that AI
sped up code but didn't eliminate the
friction didn't eliminate the iteration
why is that so let us reimagine what we
could do bear with me for a moment what
if what if What if instead of using one
tool for designing, another one for
testing, another one for coding, and
then another one for releasing, what if
we could use one tool, one codebase?
What if instead of designing on Figma,
then sending a design doc to the
developer in order for them to figure
out how to um make those uh designs
alive? What if designers could actually
design own code and then send the
developer a PR? What if QA could iterate
with the agent itself, just getting a
link with the simulator and they can
tell the agent exactly what to test,
what to be cautious of, and if they find
something, exactly what to fix?
What if we could make the dev workflow
works on the code itself? What if God
was one of us? No, sorry, I got carried
away there. And you're probably asking,
how can we do all of it? So one way
would be to tell everyone to just
download their Xcode and and their
Android Studio and teach designers and
PMs and QA how to build and how to uh
test on simulators, emulators and blow
to their laptops with a 200 GB on
storage and uh whatever they do to the
to our memory. That's one way.
But let me guess that most of them would
reject that idea and for good purposes.
So we can make another way. Maybe we
just put it in our CI, right? So we let
the agent iterate with the CI so they
don't have to download Android Studio
and Xcode and everything.
But you actually know that CI builds
take between 20 to 40 minutes. And we
can't actually let our agent wait for 40
minutes just to understand that the iOS
code that it pushed actually failed to
build.
So what else? What can we use?
Introducing cloud sandboxes.
So cloud sandboxes are actually concept
that has been around already for many
years just not for mobile development
yet.
Using cloud sandboxes, you can tell the
agent here's an here's a CLI. Talk to
the CLI. Create a VM, a small VM that
runs only for this iteration.
The VM boots up in 30 seconds or less.
Make the build. show them a simulator on
their inapp browser in the cloud code,
codex, cursor, whatever. And then they
can iterate over it, tell it to change
that button, uh to go back and test
something and change the code and they
push and open a PR and then the designer
can work on code, send a PR to the
developer after they done. Developers
make an iterations make one, two, three,
four different VMs uh to run in
parallel. They send the PR for review.
QA can take it from there and tell the
agent exactly what to test and tell it
what to fix and from there it goes
straight to the stores for review.
So let's see it. Let's see how it should
work.
So imagine you see this screen. Imagine
you're inside Codex for example. You
have the chat interface to your left.
You have the actual app to your right.
The designer is iterating with the
agent. tell it exactly what they want
them to do, what they want to change and
see the changes immediately on their
screen. Build time is faster. It's done
on the cloud and preview time is faster.
Then they either some more not with the
developer but with the agent on their
laptop without the need to install Xcode
or Android Studio. And once they done,
they can tell the agent to take that
code, open a PR and send it to the
developer. This workflow is what makes
us 10 times more productive. Not only
because of using AI, but because of
using AI to change the workflow,
reimagine it and remove all that
friction that we took from for granted
in the old times.
That is how we become 10 times more
productive. Thank you.
>> Okay, I want to tell you a story about a
factory that taught itself how to
remember. Hi, I'm Rushab. I run machine
craft, a 100 people factory in India. No
data science team, no ML budget, none of
that. And somehow we ended up building a
36 AI agent that runs our entire go to
market. I think that's still a little
ridiculous. Let me show you how it
happened and why you can do the same
thing.
So here's the thing about our company.
From the outside, it looks like machines
and metal. But the actual company, the
part that matters isn't the machines, is
the knowledge. Who the customer is, what
we quoted them in 2019, why that one
machine needed that weird custom tweak.
And for three generations, all of that
lived in exactly three brains. initially
my grandfather's then my father's and
now mine
which is a genuinely terrifying way to
run a company when you sit with it a lot
of people have joined us people have
left us the revolving door never stopped
and every single time someone walked out
a chunk of our brain walked out with
them
we weren't scared of the competitors we
were scared of forgetting or waking up
one day and realizing
the whole company.
All right.
It's great to be here and today with me
here I'm I'm Gerge, author of the
pragmatic engineer and I'm excited to
have a chat with Simon Ericson uh
founder CEO of Turbopuffer a very
technical CEO and we're going to have a
pretty technical discussion but before
we jump into it Simon I wanted to ask
where did you fall in love with
computers?
um through PowerPoint.
>> PowerPoint
you I don't know if any of you know this
but in power well you probably know this
but in PowerPoint right you can make the
the diagrams and stuff when you click
them go to another slide
that becomes turning complete real quick
right you can sort of you know create
very complicated convoluted games and
then at some point you know you make it
through the Microsoft Office suite and
you discover Front Page. Do you remember
Front Page?
>> Yeah, I remember Front Page. It it it
was supposed to eliminate the need for
all any front-end developers.
>> Exactly. And it it only worked in
Internet Explorer. I remember a
heartbreak I had one day when someone
opened a website I created in Firefox
and it just it was it was all over the
place. And then one day I accidentally
clicked the HTML
thing in front page and it just showed
all of this stuff that I couldn't make
sense of and I just started looking at
it and then going online and finding
little snippets that you could add in to
make the cursor change and all of these
different uh different things and then
it just sort of escalated from there.
Then you upgrade to Dreamweaver and now
you're coding and then you're like well
how do you make the pages dynamically?
you learn PHP and then for me I
exhausted the internet on Danish
language programming advice.
>> Mhm.
>> Um and I was I was around 11 or 12
and so I just you know went and got
addicted to World of Warcraft for four
years but that gets you really really
good at English.
So you kind of start hacking get into
deeper. Now the logical step would have
been to just you know go to university
and learn properly about this stuff. But
that's not what you did did you? I mean
I just um I I started just I I mean you
know then I learned video games then I
learned English and then you know this
like massive arsenal of the web. I now
it'd be very interesting because the
LLMs would just speak Danish to me and
you could just you wouldn't have hit the
wall like I did. Um, so that would have
been very interesting. Maybe I would
have been better at programming. That
would have been nice. And then I Yeah.
Then I just started picking up jobs and
things like that throughout high school.
And when I was in high school as well, I
got exposed to this thing called the
International Olympiad in Informatics.
You heard of this thing?
>> Yeah.
>> Um, and I had a I had an internet friend
and she lived in Australia and she was
on the Australian team
>> and she told there's probably something
for the Danish team as well, but I had
never I'd never heard about it before.
And so I found it on some like little
mysterious website and then applied and
then solved these programming problems
that look very different from the HTML
and PHP things that I'd solved until
>> were like the algorithmicalish programs.
>> Exactly. It's sort of like this is not
actually the kind of problem you would
see there but I think it illustrates
well the kind of problem that you might
get right is you could imagine something
like okay here's like n trucks here's m
packages the m packages have these
dimensions
give me which trucks which packages
should be in right and then do something
optimal like that's an npmplete problem
you can't solve that but you could
compete with everyone else in the
competition of doing the best thing so
it's these kinds of problems right
>> um and so I started doing that. In high
school, I was working um I was working
as well um for a startup. Um and then I
just Shopify found me while I was still
in high school.
>> And and the whole like Shopify found me,
was it through your open source
contributions? Was it was it something
else? It was because I had written an
article where I had I had I dropped my
iPhone and it was you know the iPhones
are a lot like there used to be a time
right where you drop your iPhone and you
just knew it was over for the screen.
>> It doesn't really happen as much anymore
like the screens have gotten a lot
better but back then it was like yeah
one drop and it was dead and it just
couldn't use it anymore. And so I went
back to one of these old Nokia brick
phones and this is back in 2013 and
people hadn't really realized all the
pernicious effects of smartphones at the
time. And so I wrote this article about
how oh my god I'm like calling people
and I have my sense of direction back.
Um and I wrote an article about it and
this article it went on hacker news
briefly and it um New York Times decided
to feature it.
>> No way.
>> Yeah. And so a lot of traffic was driven
to it and then some astute Shopify
recruiter put it all together and um and
I had a call with them and then I don't
think they realized that I was still in
high school but um but I had a great
call with them. They invited me on site
to Ottawa, Canada. Um I had no idea what
Ottawa Canada is. I think the email says
something like what's an Ottawa? I had
no idea. Um, and so I went there and it
was just like walked into the building
and it was just a just felt right. Um,
and so I I I interviewed with them and
then said, "Well, I got to finish high
school first and then uh and then I
moved to Canada uh to to to work at
Shopify." Yeah. In 2013.
>> Yeah. I think that's that's a like legit
excuse for like not even worrying about
college and and university.
>> But I did it crossed your mind.
>> It did. I thought I was going I thought
I was doing a gap year. I thought I was
like, "Okay, I'm going to go work at
Shopify for a year and then I'll
probably go back and do but I would just
I was very insecure at the time about
the fact that I hadn't studied computer
science and my only exposure had been
all the II competitions. It's a pretty
good crash course in a lot of computer
science. And if nothing else, it had
really taught me that you can just sit
down and read a paper and just figure it
out if you spend enough time on it. So I
did I did that repeatedly and in my
first year at Shopify I just every time
I heard something that I didn't know
what was I noted it down on a piece of
paper and then I went home and then that
evening I would just read about it
because I felt insecure that like well
if someone mentions mentions like TCP
surely they know exactly what's in the
three-way handshake and how TLS is like
layered on top and they've looked at
Wireshark and all of that. I don't think
that's true but that's what I thought.
>> So I went and did that for everything
that I encountered. Um, so that was a
really good crash course and then very
quickly it became clear that well I just
want to continue doing this. I don't
want to go go somewhere else and then
come back to this because I felt like
I'd already found what I wanted to do.
So it sounds sounds like it was a pretty
good combination of like you just having
this like very natural insecurity like
you know you're young, you know, you
don't have the education that everyone
else has and inside a company that's
just doing pretty like cutting edge
stuff even at the time and even even to
today, right? Like they're they're
leading. So you just kept self-seing
yourself like just catching up and go
then do I understand that you just went
deep in every concept that you
understood you didn't like just like try
to understand a surface level but like
go as deep as you can search on the
internet buy books whatever that is I
think it was just that
I just wanted to know keep learning how
computers work and I think that this is
something that I now look for when we
interview engineers is that you just you
can't help yourself but trying to peel
back the layers and for me that ended up
with the infrastructure layer. That was,
you know, the people closest to the
metal at at Shopify. And I would just
always sit next to them at lunch because
I was working on the on the product
side. But I just I couldn't help myself.
I was so I just wanted to learn what it
was when they were talking about a
reverse proxy. I'm like, why is it
reverse? I I still can't answer that.
I I I mean okay you know
well what's in reverse because it's
proxy right
I don't I don't know I don't know it's
like an inverted index like what's
inverted it's like it's a terrible name
anyway yeah
I I mean it's still better when when you
get the not tables the lookups some of
those things like some of that but yeah
I hear you there there's some like weird
names with
But at at Shopify,
what were some of the kind of like hard
engineering challenges that you
engineering challenges, outages
like like learnings that kind of defined
you that were really also fun at the
time or interesting to learn, but it
would have been hard to get it
elsewhere. Yeah. So I think it was, you
know, in the 2010s there's like a bunch
of SAS companies that that scale really
quickly and I felt so fortunate to have
a front row seat to that and so I ended
up on the infrastructure team and this
was back in you know 134 and uh Docker
was coming out and so we were
containerizing everything and we were
just every single year we had to you
know the growth rates of of of SAS
sometimes seems quaint in comparison to
the growth rates of companies today but
it was a company that was growing at you
know 120 40% year-over-year. Um, and so
every year we were just preparing for a
Black Friday that was going to be a lot
worse than the last. And this is back in
the day of we're buying physical
hardware, right? We have to like place
an order at a particular point in time
and do some interpolation based on that.
Um, and the software also had to scale.
And when you're scaling most software, a
lot of the application layer problems
end up back at the database layer.
>> And so I just naturally found myself at
this layer between Rails and the
databases. Shopify didn't at the time at
least contribute many patches to the
databases themselves but mostly just
spent time orchestrating. So we were
doing sharding because as um my my dear
boss Camilo used to say you can't cash
rights. So there's a fundamental point
where you you just you have to move
beyond a single shard. Um so I wasn't I
joined around the time and they did the
sharding and they did it I think they
did the cut over a week before Black
Friday which is mindblowing.
uh and very but it worked and then the
the subsequent years we worked on things
like going into multiple data centers.
We also had this big mysterious reddish
server that was like you know 128 GB of
RAM which was a lot at the time. Today
it's not that much and no one really
knew what was in it and then it went
down one day and people were like well
that's super terrifying. Um because
people had just been treating it as this
KV store. Um and so we started splitting
it out. We did all this stuff around
making sure that if you if you if you go
visit a Shopify store and the thing that
stores your sessions is down, the right
behavior is not just for the entire the
of everything to be down. But that's
kind of the default failure mode, right?
You're not going to rescue all of that.
Um unless you're in a programming
language that really forces that
decision. So we did things like um build
this matrix out of okay well this
service when this component is down
should act this way. Um and I found
myself writing the test suite for a
bunch of that. And then I was like okay
well we can't just mock all of this. And
so um I came up with this idea at the
time of like oh what we're going to do
is we're just going to um shell out to
GDB and then into the process and then
close the file descriptor to the
database to simulate through the entire
layer that the database fails. That was
a little crazy and we never shipped that
on CI but it did uncover a massive
amount of issues in Rails that' be
upstream and things like that of around
just like handling failures at the
connection layer. So then I moved on to
create this proxy called Toxyroxy and
>> have you heard of this before?
>> No. No.
>> Yeah. Toxyroxy is it's just like a layer
7 proxy that sits in between um you and
well layer four but in between you and
the databases. So you basically have
just like this proxy and then my SQL
whatever doesn't speak the protocol but
then you can do an API call say take
take uh take the database down make it
slow um and over time it also added
layer 7 things of like do a bunch of
failures this way you're not mocking the
low-level drivers but you're testing the
drivers and their failure handling as
well. So then this entire matrix could
be implemented in CI. So the basically
the proxy was just like a really thin
layer which like was passed through but
you built the functionality to like
simulate problems with database or
things like data corruption or whatever
you wanted to do. So you could just do
it in there and then you can anything
that built on top of it but but then Oh
yeah and then everyone had to like call
this proxy or it needed to be on in a
layer.
>> Exactly. So you could do like do like my
SQ you know toxyroxy.mmysql
downdown and then pass it a lambda of
what you wanted to do like get this page
do a checkout whatever with the sessions
table down and this just uncovered
tens of issues right in the myql driver
in the rails like it's just like no one
in the ecosystem had been testing for
this and it was very difficult to see
this in prod right because in myql down
you're focused on just getting back up
and not like what could the application
actually have done. Yeah, it's
interesting. Of course, we're going to
talk a bit more about databases
obviously, but just thinking about how a
lot of the problems or some of the most
gnarly problems in large systems are
always to do with state and I never
connected until now that I mean state is
usually there's a database. If there's
no database, if you have stateless
services, you know, I mean you still
have problems, you have nodes going
down, you have I don't know corruption,
whatever, but it's usually like more
isolated. But basically like if we have
state, we typically have databases. is
if we have databases and if you can
simulate these problems suddenly you can
I mean you you can like predict a lot of
things the problem with state often time
is it's really hard to simulate problems
happening ahead of time unless when they
happen so did you it sounds like you had
pretty good success with
>> yeah I think to my knowledge it's still
um running in like the CI system of
Shopify today I don't know if anyone in
the crowd is from Shopify but I'm pretty
sure that it still does um and so we
wrote all these tests against it to
implement and all of these different uh
different failure conditions and it just
yeah it was it was it worked out great.
So you spent eight years in total at at
Shopify. So like starting from like all
right just a gap year it just went on a
year a year another year. Um at what
point did you think about leaving and
why and what was your kind of decision
framework? It sounds like you or you
were like on Epic right now even today
Shopify it's doing wonderful. It's
probably doing even way better than like
you know that growth kind of kept on. So
I'm sure there would have been an
argument to stay and you know stay on
the rocket ship.
>> Yeah. So I I spent I spent eight years
there from 13 to to 21. Um and I I think
there just came a point where
I wanted to see something different
again. I've been inside of Shopify since
I was 18 years old, right? I'd been seen
one other startup in high school. I was
like if I want to learn more about
computers and learn faster, it might be
time to inject some novelty into this
function. Um, and so I I left in in in
21 and I'd worked on so many different
parts of the infrastructure like
caching. Um, me and Justine, who's now
my co-founder, we wrote the entire
storefront um, storefront for Shopify
um, which powered almost 100% of traffic
18 months after we embarked on it. Um,
we've worked on running Shopify in
multiple data centers. We've worked on
so many database scaling projects like
caching, all of these different things,
right? Um, a lot of the a lot of the
scalability came from the Kardashians
launching lots of products on on
Shopify, which would force a lot of
traffic. Um, but that's that's
eventually how I left. And so when I
left, I didn't really know what I wanted
to do. And so I one of the projects I
had while I was at Shopify was this
napkin math project. Have you seen this
>> napkin math? No.
>> No. Um, so napkin math was essentially
just this table that I maintain on
GitHub of how much bandwidth can you
drive to DRAMM, what is a roundtrip to
S3 cost, and how long does it take, how
much bandwidth can you drive to an NVME
SSD, how much bandwidth can you drive to
an EBS volume? Just a collection of
probably there's probably like 50 of
these numbers and then a RS script that
generates them all. um what all these
things cost? What do you like? What does
a gigabyte of memory cost? $2. What does
a gigabyte of S3 cost? Two cents. What
does a gigabyte of um this cost 10
cents, right? What does it cost on spot?
What does it cost on a three-year
commit? Like I had just have a massive
table and then create flash cards for
almost every single cell. So I know all
these numbers. And this was a project I
started taking on at Shopify because I
found myself in um this role a lot where
I would go in and review a project,
right? So some product team would be
like okay we got to do we got to build
this thing so we got to build this
infrastructure to support the feature
and a lot of the times they would say
okay well we've gone and benchmarked it
on database A
but the benchmarks are not very good so
we're going to go with database B
and I hate benchmarks so much because
that's not a satisfying answer to me to
me it's like
this does not jive maybe my intuition
ition database A that you're saying
takes 10 seconds to do this
should take 10 milliseconds if you do
the napkin math right if it's a search
query right it's like okay you're
searching for three terms there each
term has this many documents that match
it that's this many megabytes we inter
intersect these many this many lists
you have DRAM bandwidth on multiple
cores of 100 gigabytes per second this
should take 10 millisecond you tell me
the benchmark takes 10
one of us is wrong. Either there's a gap
in my understanding, which is very
likely, or you would benchmark the wrong
thing. And in some ways, some reasons,
right, it's like, okay, you've done a
benchmark, you don't didn't realize that
your benchmark is doing a distributed
query across a 100 different nodes. And
so, of course, the P99 is going to be
really, really high, right? Unless
you've cut that off or or made some
different set of trade-offs. So I just
found myself in these discussions
repeatedly where people were making
infrastructure decisions based on poor
benchmarks. And so I needed some I I
needed some ammo to go in and just be
like okay we can just do the calculation
right here and then. Um because I was
always doing these like little demos or
like writing little prototype scripts to
to demonstrate this. But it was just I
just the argument of here's how a beach
tree works. This is how many pages we
have to visit. This is what a random SSD
read takes. It takes one millisecond.
you have to visit a thousand blah blah
blah blah blah and then percent it back
and see this is the difference to your
query well like is the query plan
correct like is there a bug in my SQL do
we have bad discs like what's the
discrepancy here and I just got caught
with that bug and so after I left Shab I
was just writing a lot of articles about
this I was just like well how long does
should this query take and then I one
hypothesis I had at some point like okay
well how many writes per second can my
SQL do well shouldn't the amount of
writes per second that my SQL do equal
the amount of f-syncs that you can do
per second. That sort of makes sense,
right? Every time you do a ride, you
f-sync to persist to disk. So, how many
f-syncs can you do per second? Well, an
f-sync takes one millisecond. So, you do
a thousand rights per second. That well,
that doesn't really match up. Like, feel
like a database can do more than,000
rightes per second. Why can it do that?
So, that was one of those things where I
tested and it's like, okay, well, my SQL
on a little dinky box could do 10,000
writes per second. Well, how is that
possible?
>> And now you would just ask, how is it
>> Because you batch. So an f-sync happens
on usually a 4K.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. But it's like that's not
intuitive. Like it's actually I I I got
caught. It was like just like you know
probably some like 24-hour period where
I just got obsessed with this question
whereas like you're writing like the BPF
traces and all of that to do all of
this. This is like preLLM so it took
forever and you and then I found out
that oh every f-sync was like much
larger than I would have inferred like
oh it's batching. you go into the code
and you read it and then you found some
obscure article by it's always somewhere
in like a central German town that's
like written some article about like how
some intricacy of my SQL works and a
patch that they did to it's like the
entire internet runs on small towns in
Bavaria. I'm convinced. Yeah.
And then you decided to start
Turbopuffer.
Yeah. Did h how did you decide? Did you
know what you wanted to build or was it
more like I want to build something
something databases because you were
clearly very into databases. You you've
done an awesome job benchmarking like
what is the theoretical like limits you
were very familiar with this probably
became you know like world expert in in
this niche and then how
>> did you want to go into databases again?
>> I think it was
there's three things that sort of came
to a head. Um the last project that I
worked on at Shopify was search and I
didn't have a good time.
>> What what what did you use back there?
Um I don't we don't need to name names
of other database companies, but it was
uh it was one of the one of the like
traditional search companies that a lot
of different um companies run and it was
just very difficult to get it to do what
I did and I was just like the projects
that touched that database just I
couldn't get them to perform at the
napkin math and like there's there's no
query planner and like I couldn't figure
out why it wasn't there and sometimes it
tracked and then sometimes it really
didn't track at all and so I tried to
learn as much as I could to figure out
and like start reading the source code
of it and I was just I couldn't get it
to track very often. It was very
difficult to operate and so I just that
was sort of like in the back of my head.
I never thought I would touch that
again. Then the second ingredient was
the napkin math project
because it sort of just gave me a lot of
facility with all of these napkin math
numbers of what might be achievable with
the machine if you utilized it perfectly
properly. Yeah. And then the third one
was that doing this you know leaving
Shopify in 21 having spent eight years
there and during that time I did this I
called it angel engineering so I like
joined my friends companies and then I
just vested equity instead of um instead
of just investing or something like that
and because I wanted to have my fingers
in it I wanted to like see what else was
out there that's why I left and this
problem kept coming up again again and
again and again right like ChachiBT came
out in 2022 and I was working with with
a company then and They wanted to
connect a bunch of documents to AI and
that's when the context windows were
really small. So you had to reach for
search very quickly.
>> So it's like a few kilobytes.
>> It was eight kilobytes or four kilobytes
depending on the model. It was very very
small. So you had to reach for search
very quickly, right? And
>> so I I I worked with them and I was I
was I created a little recommendation
engine and the recommendation engine was
actually quite good. Um, like I s I
found out that one of the co-founders
wife was pregnant through the
recommendations that I was getting when
I was running it on his feed. Um, like
it was it was it it
>> weird but
>> it was recommending. Yeah. I mean it was
just like you know he was reading about
like and I did get permission. I just
like I don't think anyone expected to be
good enough and just like okay it's this
this thing is working and then I ran the
back of the envelope math on what it
would cost to do this for everyone like
all the users. This is a company called
Readwise. So it's like articles that you
save and then and insert later. And it
was going to cost 30 grand a month. And
this was a company, it's a bootstrap
Canadian company, they spend about five
they at the time they're spending about
5K a month on all the other
infrastructure combined.
So it just it didn't the you know
fundamentally in a company if you're
doing an investment you have have to
earn some gross margin on top of
whatever you're paying, right? And it
just didn't line up. Um, and so we just
didn't ship it and I worked on I you
know tuned to autovacuum on Postgress or
something like that which is a good
pastime and then you I just couldn't
stop thinking about why it was so
expensive to store all of these vectors
that we were using for the
recommendations and I just sat and did
the napkin math one day of like can we
just use it all in S3 and do some
clustering and then organize the files
and just the way and it's like maybe you
could build that and then
one day I just kind of said did and
did it and like sat down and started to
like to write it out. Um, and I spent
the summer of of 23 just hammering my
head against the wall trying to find an
approach where I could get the latency
that I wanted. Um,
>> because the problem with S3 is it has
really good durability, but latency
we're talking hundreds of milliseconds,
right?
>> Yes. The P99 on a uh 256 or 512 kilobyte
object on S3 um is around 200
milliseconds. Um, and and you're saying
P99 because like when you're talking
large scale, you want to care about the
P99, right?
>> Yeah. I think when you're
>> That's why we're not talking about P50.
>> When you're designing a system, you want
to optimize for the P99. And especially
because when you're designing a system
on on S3, generally in every roundtrip,
you're not doing one request. You're
often doing lots of requests, right?
>> You're going to hit the P99 real quick.
>> Exactly. So, it's like if you're
navigating a tree on S3, right? It's
like, okay, you get the upper layer of
the tree 200 milliseconds. You get like
another layer of the tree 200
milliseconds. You get a bunch of leaves
of the tree in 200 millonds. So in
aggregate you have like you want to look
at the P99 probably even the P999 to
design the system properly because you
will need to minimize the number of
round trips that you had to make. So, I
just sat and sketched that out um and
tried a bunch of different approaches
and then and then finally in in in July
of 23, I I I got something end to end
that seemed to work and then rewrote it
probably twice and then released it in
in October of of 23 based on um based on
just that that summer of of of working
through it. And then you kind of you
built it on on top of S3 because I guess
durability and and all of and just
really good. How did you make it fast?
We didn't in the beginning or I didn't
in the beginning. Um it was just me at
the time and it was really like it was
it was it was a project. It was not a
company. It was not
>> it was it was it was to satisfy a
curiosity. It was not I did not set out
to do this like I'm going to go like
raise $10 million and do like I was like
I barely knew what a VC was. Like I was
like I just had to do this thing and I
was so focused on doing it. became so
clear to me that if I wasn't going to do
it, someone else was going to do it and
I just became fully obsessed that summer
with it. And so the first version was
the simplest possible thing. I think I'm
a very pragmatic person like I I didn't
get buried. I barely read any like of
the literature on LSM. I sort of like
you know read a bunch of it just like
got the basic idea barely implemented
that because that would have taken too
much time. It was the simplest possible
version of what it could be. Like really
what you have to imagine is that the
simplest way you could do this is you
run some clustering algorithm on the
vectors.
>> You get the clusters and then you put
the clusters in files. The cl the files
are called cluster one, cluster two,
cluster three and then you have another
file called centroidids of the clusters
and then you do the search by
downloading centroidids looking at the
centrids and then downloading the n
closest clusters. There's a few
optimizations around merging some
clusters that were JSON in files and so
on just to like control some cost and
some performance but that was basically
it and then getting that to scale. That
was the first version. And then how do
we make it fast? Well, I didn't even
implement a caching layer. I just put
the reverse proxy in front of S3 with
Engine X and then had it cached.
>> You know what a reverse proxy is?
>> I like I do know what it is. I just
still don't know what what the reverse
is about. But anyway, um the reverse the
reverse proxy reverse things
um the the performance in this case um
maybe that's what it's about by caching
right all of the all of the S3 objects
it again it was the simplest like it's
like I'm just going to put that in front
I knew how to configure engine X like
I've written more engineext Lua than u
than a lot of engineext Lua very good
software um just had that cache in front
and then the way that I would do things
like deleting in the cache was just like
shell out to XRX and just removed like
things in the in the cache and reverse
engineer the directory structure on
engine X and that's what we shipped and
it was just running on a single server
and a T-Ox instance. I was like okay
let's see if anyone gives a Yeah.
So so far I mean this is kind of like
cool engineering and like a cool side
project and like a bunch of novel ideas
and I you know like I think just some
hardcore engineering. How did cursor
come into play? Because like when I
learned about Turbopuffer, I was talking
with Cursor about like how they built
their their backend, their database, how
they scaled, and they're telling me all
these migrations and they were telling
me like, oh yeah, so we we were on
Postgress, but it didn't No, they did
something else in Postgress. It didn't
really work that well. They went to AWS
Aurora, which is managed service of
Postgress, and it didn't work well,
which is very surprising. And they're
like, "Oh, yeah." And then we went to
this thing called Turbopuffer, and they
worked well. And I was like, "What's
Turbopuffer?" And they're like, "Oh,
yeah, Turboer." I think I think they
said like we were one of their first
customers. And this never computed to
me. Curser was already massive at that
point. Yeah. How did you meet the folks?
And how did they become would were they
the first customer? One of the first.
>> They were the first customer.
>> The first
>> the first.
>> No.
>> Um they they they reached out um after I
just launched on on Twitter. I was like,
"Hey, I built this thing." And frankly
it was like in I exact you it was like
hey launch this thing and to me I was
like I am so sick of working on this
like I was like I've been working on
this all summer I don't know if anyone
cares I only want to work on this if
anyone cares. Let's put it on Twitter
again single Tox instance on a 8 core
node somewhere in GCP. I was like if
someone goes to prod I'll I'll set it up
properly on multiple and like I'll just
block on that but let let's see if
anyone cares. It was like the MVP of
MVP. anyone who's actually worked in the
internal on databases would never have
had like would have had too much pride
to ship anything like that.
Um, and I've just, you know, I've worked
on I was just releasing it like a SAS
project. Why can't you work on a
database like it's SAS? I don't, you
know, it's like if anyone uses it, we'll
do it properly. I know how to run
software with a lot of nines. Um, but it
was not a proper LSN like it was very
very it was the simplest version of what
it could be. And then I released on
Twitter. I was like, "Yeah, you could do
a million vectors for a dollar." And
before that, I think the the cheapest
was maybe $100 per million for something
that actually worked.
>> Yeah.
>> Um, and I knew it was reliable, right? I
knew like I had these invariants like if
you shut down all the VMs, like no data
is lost, like all the rights are
committed directly to object like it has
all the same invariants it had today. Um
and cursor reached out and knowing them
now I'm sure at the time the cursor was
maybe eight people and knowing the
founders now I am sure that they had sat
at the dinner table one day and we're
like the unit economics of what we have
right now where all the vectors are in
DRAM are not working why hasn't anyone
built it where we can put it in S3 and
the actual code bases that are actively
being used we can put in memory
>> and everything else just sit in opic
stores and then we just hotload it in
and out of the cache
>> makes so much sense right you open the
codebase few seconds and it's in RAM and
then the queries are as fast as anything
else. It made so much sense. So I mean
at the time they were if you look at
some of Aman one of the co-founders
early tweets he talks about uh using S3
for KV caching and things like that
which barely anyone is still doing even
though
>> um the economics
>> yeah price wise yeah it's and it's very
it's very uncommon and I think it will
happen right but they were ahead of
their time
>> and they I think they were I don't know
if they were thinking of building it
themselves I think that's quite likely
um and they found turbuffer and it just
perfectly pattern matched into that
again I don't know if this dinner
conversation happened or if this was
just inside Harvey's head. Um, but it
pattern matched something and so we
exchanged a bunch of emails and then
something compelled. I didn't know
anything about B2B sales. Now I love B2B
sales. Um, I didn't know anything. I was
just like I just want to help them
because they they were they had some
unit economics that didn't line up. So I
just went to San Francisco, right? I
live in Canada. I went to San Francisco
and I showed up at the office and when I
showed up at the office they um they
were having some Postgress problem that
they were discussing. Yeah, the AD as
Aurora problems. Yes.
>> Yeah. Early on. And I was like, "Oh, do
you guys have PG analyze?" And they
said, "Oh, no, we don't." I was, "Okay,
let's let's let's get that going, right?
Let's look at it." And it was the same
thing as it always is with Postgress,
which is auto vacuum hadn't run enough.
And so, they had all of these like going
to heat when they should be doing index
scans and blah blah blah. So, we were
talking about all of that. And so, it's
just helping them, right? It was like
my, you know, my database genes just
like kicked in. And I think this built
enough trust with them that okay, well
maybe if he knows how to help us with
the database, maybe he also would know
how to build one. And
um at this time I'd also approached who
I thought was the best engineer who ever
worked at Shopify, my co-founder
Justine. um and she'd come on and the
first thing that she did was um remove
the reverse proxy enginex cache with a
file-based cache just a direct cache
which again great like the S3 thing
worked um and so she was online she was
starting to work on it and um and cursor
cursor cursor then that night was like
okay well we're going to migrate and so
they migrated everything over the course
of like a week or two after that um but
cursor was a small company back then
right yeah and they were they just in
the beginning of their massive rapid
growth.
>> Exactly. And I I told them that I was
going to reduce their bill by 95%.
And I did like we did. Justine and I
did. We like they came on and their last
bill with their previous vendor and the
first bill with us, it was 95% lower.
Yeah. And you're you're nice for not
saying vendors, but I I can say talks to
them and and it's in the deep dive about
cursor. It was it was it was Aurora
specifically. Uh so
>> this was this was not this was not
Postgress. No, this was a
>> it was a different one, but it's
probably still in the write up. We don't
we don't need to name names, but uh
yeah, but they were the reason they went
there is reliability was their main main
pain point. I'm sure the unit of comics
would have been there, but yeah, this
was and then what Swallow told me is he
said like look like there's a few things
that we did that you should never ever
do and he said one of them you should
never ever bet your business on a tiny
startup where you are their only or
biggest customer except for Turbopuffer
and he said I love love those guys. So I
guess it just comes to show that even in
your case like to me what this story is
shows is is you can do things when you
build highquality things and you're
pushing for things good things can
happen and on the other side of cursor
when you're a startup it's okay to take
sometimes irrational risks when you have
conviction and it sounds to me that you
gave them conviction by showing up in
person by helping them by showing that
you know you know your stuff like you
suddenly brought in your your 10ish or
eight years of Shopify experience and
your curiosity and They probably took a
risk because of that, not because you
were some, you know, random vendor. They
probably would have never done that. So,
fast forward today, uh, Turbopuffer is
now a lot bigger. You're you're working
on some some some cool things. But
you have this very interesting business
where for you CPUs are important, right?
You run on mostly CPUs. And you told me
a story over dinner yesterday that
uh you met Jensen uh and Jensen he
really wanted to sell you on GPS. Can
you tell me how that meeting went?
>> Um yeah, Jensen Hong, right?
>> Yeah. I just I never met uh I'd never
met uh Jensen before. We were we were at
an event at uh at at Nvidia and we were
just doing um presentations in a big HQ.
Super impressive.
>> Yeah, exactly. They've invited a couple
of companies to go and and um and and
and talk about um uh talk about our
businesses and how we can partner with
Nvidia and so on. And
I I don't I I don't know. I was like I
think I was in a goofy mood that day.
And so I went up on on stage and I said,
"Um, hey, I'm Simon from from from
Turbopuffer." And uh and yeah, if you're
wondering about the name, it's like if
everything goes south, we can always
pivot into vapes.
I was kind of nervous. I This is what I
This is what I said. And then and then
he said back to me,
>> wait, who was in the room? Was it
Jensen? Was it a direct report?
>> It was It was Jensen and then I don't He
has like I don't know if it's just 50
direct reports or it was like, you know,
it was there was it was Jensen and then
a bunch of the um like Nvidia Nvidia
leadership, right? Um cuz you go there
and then you talk about that you find
opportunities to partner and work
together, right? And so I said, "Yeah,
you know, so plan B could be that we
could pivot into vapes." And then he
said, I was already nervous. He said,
"Judging by your slide, maybe you
should."
No, he did not.
And and
I didn't know what to say back to that.
So I said, "Well, Jensen, do you vape?"
He didn't he didn't answer the question.
And then someone um someone on the um
someone on the on the team um
wrote to the whole company, Turppuffer
Company, Simon just asked Jensen if he
vapes.
Um and then you know this is this is a
great start right and um and then the
team had team team had sort of talked to
me beforehand was like son we got to
make sure we don't say the c word we
can't say CPUs
and so I just couldn't stop talking
about CPUs. I was like AVX 512 is so
sick like we love SIMD and um like we we
we like there's so many CPUs. They're so
easy to get. like um it's just a riot in
CPU land. Like you know I I don't I
think I stopped short of saying I'm so
glad I don't need GPUs but
but it was just it I just couldn't stop
talking about CPUs.
Yeah. And so you know Jensen took an
interest in that. Yeah. So who who knows
like I'm sure you made you made a
memorable impression. Maybe he made it
his mission now to like at some point
get you guys onto GPUs. But speaking of
CPUs, can you tell me a bit what you're
seeing inside of the hypers scale the
cloud providers? You're now in AWS,
you're you're in GCP, you're on Azure.
What I would think naively is there's a
GPU shortage and when I talk with
inference companies, they are and and
and AI labs, they're just getting
whatever they can do. I would think
getting CPUs is should be easy. Is it?
>> No,
>> it's not anymore. Why? What's happening?
Can you tell us about dynamics on on on
the why and what you've learned? Yeah.
So, I think that
GPUs will probably continue to be
scarce. Like, I don't know, maybe
there's going to be some surplus. I I
refuse to speculate too much about the
macro, but I think as as RL is becoming
a very very large amount of the
workloads that needs a lot of CPUs. So,
the labs are sucking up a lot of CPUs
because you need CPUs to be like, okay,
we need to like teach this model how to
how to search. We need to teach it how
to use GP. We need to teach it how to
boot up bash. We need it needs to run
real things and learn from that takes a
lot of CPU.
>> Mhm.
>> Um and so I think as we RL is consuming
a lot of CPU and then also just all of
the agents are running on CPUs, right?
They need to do all kinds of very
general purpose things on a CPU and so
as as as the demand curve is sort of
shifting to the right and it's becoming
more and more applied and that feeds
back into RL by the way, right? because
as things become more applied like oh
the models are not that good at CAD or
ship building I don't know and then you
know you have to spin up even more RL
environments to do that so I think
that's what we're seeing and so we're on
the other end of that needing these CPUs
we need a lot of NVME SSDs as well um
and a lot of this right now is tied up
in DRAM right of of where like
>> you need a lot of that also for the GPU
servers um but I would assume that it
gets a lot worse before it gets a lot
better on the on the CPU side um and I
think even the big companies are
fighting amongst each other, right, to
get the allocations and even we, you
know, we're selling to companies that we
also fight for CPU with and against,
right? It's uh it's it's it's really
difficult and so you write things to try
to make sure you get these CPUs as f
fast as possible.
>> Yeah. And yesterday I was at a dinner
that you hosted with your team where you
actually have a bunch of Turboper
customers. A bunch of them are AI AI
labs or or AI startups but a lot of them
one of them uh reflection had have hu
massive amount of footprint and they
were telling me that they're in a
situation where they cannot buy more
like they when it comes to GPUs or CPUs
they max out they have the longest
contracts that possible and I didn't
realize how competitive it is in the
cloud when you're you go beyond a small
fish to like a medium size or even a a
large fish that now like It's it's
interesting. So So now you have this and
even you're having this this uh kind of
fight behind the scenes that is maybe
not as visible.
>> Exactly. And I mean you you work with
the clouds right you work with them to
talk about which regions have um have
CPU which regions are getting it comes
down to power right of like okay well
where is the power which is generally
where they're going to ship the new
CPUs. Um and so we have to work with
some of our biggest customers on that.
So these are real constraints right that
are that are making our way to us. We're
just very fortunate that it's very easy
for us to run lots of turbo power
clusters because all we need are like a
few CPUs and NVME SSDs and then S3 and
then we're in a good place. But there's
lots of changes that we can make even to
the architecture um to try to protect
from from a lot of this. Now I'd rather
spend that engineering effort on other
things but we are very very good at
using a lot of very different SKs,
right? So we don't need everything to be
a particular CPU or instance type. We
can run with many many different types
of machine types. Um Q meaning that's
the it's a fancy name for like the
different machine types.
>> Yes. Exactly right. Like you know C4D or
I AG or whatever they're called.
>> What's your favorite one?
>> Um we really like right now the um C4s
on uh GCP.
>> GCP. Yeah.
>> Um the Z4Ds are also performing really
well um now that we've done done a bunch
of of um of optimizations to them. Um
those are really really great machine
types. Uh we really like those. Um and
then the ARM C4As as well um on on GCP.
Um we like those. But I think that in
general like when you're yeah when
you're small it's very easy to suck up a
bunch of but at Shopify I was also part
of you know deciding
ahead of BFCM right a few months out you
have to tell the cloud providers how
much you're intending to use. do commits
on all of that, right? The the clouds
are not infinite as they seem when
you're small.
>> And one way, of course, to like get like
infrastructure and and also just like
credibility is venture capital. If you
raise $und00 million, a billion dollars,
some of your customers just raised $2
billion. Actually, I talked with them
yesterday. You know, it gives you
credibility, it gives you cash, you can
pay for this thing. Your specific
Turbopuffers relationship to venture
capital seems very interesting. I never
heard you announce a raise until m maybe
just very recently. Can you tell me how
you and and you told me that when you
started this thing you didn't think too
much outside of just building some cool
stuff. How did you think about venture
capital and how do you think about
raising because again I feel you have a
very fresh and different perspective
than what which is typical inside of
Silicon Valley. Yeah. So I think to to
understand my how I think about capital,
you have to go back to the the beginning
of Turbopuffer, right? Where I promised
Curser that Justine and I could get
their bill to 4K a month. And this was
based on some very rough napkin math on,
okay, if if Turbopuffer was a better
implementation than it currently is,
then it should cost this much. And
that's the pricing we ship with. And
that's what we guaranteed um guaranteed
cursor. Um but the software was not that
good. Like it was very reliable but it
was very simple, right? And that's like
a core engineering principle of me is
simplicity above everything. Um you and
I have talked before about how software
that ages well and some of the
advantages of seeing be having long
tenures inside of companies. You had a
long tenure at Uber. I had a long tenure
at Shopify. So you see simplicity just
almost always wins. Um, and at the time
I was not convinced whether this was a
venture scale opportunity because I
understood that if you take venture
capital, no matter how many smiles there
are in the room, everyone's sort of
expecting that you have to earn a big
return on that on some timeline that
makes sense to everyone involved. And
everyone involved are, you know, pension
funds in Canada like that. It's like it
there's like a whole stack, right, of of
of people that that need to. So at the
time I was like I don't you know I don't
know if this could be a billion dollar
company. I didn't know that in the very
very beginning. Um it wasn't completely
clear to me. It felt like a very niche
kind of product right to build this
particular search engine. Um and that
was completely fine with me. So I you
know it's it's it was fine. And
so then I just I just looked at the
cursor bill and I looked at my GCP bill
which is what we started on. and you
know as like a you know dumb Danish
person who's just like okay like this
number should just be lower than the
other number.
>> Yeah,
>> that's sort of like you know and it's
just I don't think I'd spend enough time
in San Francisco cuz I think the money
over here it works a little bit
differently. Um that's just that's all I
knew. You you were doing business 101 as
as long as you're making a profit you're
good, right?
>> Yeah.
It was like I'm I'm not kidding in this
exaggeration that it was just like that
just made sense to me that Justine and I
were just going to go optimize this
until these numbers were roughly equal.
And maybe if if if we could get some
other workloads, we could start paying
ourselves. But that was like very much
the philosophy at the time. Um because I
didn't know if I could go raise a bunch
of of of money. I didn't know anyone who
had the money. I I didn't have any
relationships. Um you were an absolute
outsider to the
>> I was I was an outsider. I was like an
outsider squared, right? I grew up in
Aus, Denmark and I um I then moved to
Ottawa, Canada. So it's like I'm an
outsider to Canada and in Canada I'm an
outsider to San Francisco. So I was just
thinking about this from first
principles like oh you're a venture
capital you need this return you need it
on this timeline.
I don't know if I can deliver that yet.
I would need more data to decide that
because I want to like I kind of want to
keep working on this and now I have to
get to this point for it to not be a
failure. Um in in in January then I uh
there was a person that I was at II with
in in uh in 2012 and 2013 and his name
is Buen and he was on the North and
Macedonian team um at II um and he was
he's he was really good. He was so good
that the North Macedonian team called
him God. Um
I don't know why but that was what he
went by. And he was yeah he was very
good. Grew up and and I really wanted to
work with Boyan but I couldn't afford to
work with Boy. Um and he was very much
like this is what I can live off like
you know I just like I want to build
this D like that would be like this is
what it can be. But at this point,
Justine and I hadn't taken a salary for
like 6 months. And we'd already we'd
already spent like tens of thousands of
dollars on like on GCP bills and all of
that. And I was like, I don't think we
can I don't think we can we we can do
it. And so I had met one one individual
in in Silicon Valley. Uh his name is
Locky. And it just I ended up just
calling him and saying, hey, I kind of
want to learn a little bit faster here.
Can I can we raise like 700k? That's
like what I wanted to raise. So, it's
just like I want to have like two
engineers for the rest of the year. Just
and I still don't need to be paid and
then a little bit of buffer room. It's
like this is what I need and if this
doesn't have PMF and is a big
opportunity by the end of the year, I
don't think we're going to bother and
we'll just shut the whole thing down and
we won't have it taking a dime. We'll
return everything to you. Um
I think there was the first time you
heard anyone say it like that. Um, and
um, I told some other VCs that at the
time and that was terrifying to them. I
think to someone on the West Coast, this
sounds like you have low ambition or
something like that.
>> Um, and to me it was just like I I don't
know, it just came from a when I don't
know how to play a game, I just play
with open cards. Like this is how I see
it.
>> And so I we were it was very clear to us
that we wanted to do this and but also
it became clear to us that we didn't
want to just like keep working on this
unless it could become big. And we were
starting to develop conviction
conviction that this actually become
really really big. And so we we we did
that and hired Buen and then became
profitable later that year. Um and then
just continue to hire. And then it's
like to raise more money you need sort
of there's six reasons to raise capital.
The first reason to raise capital is to
fund R&D.
>> Mhm. That was the reason that we raised
capital in January because we funded R&D
with a lot of our own, you know,
opportunity cost and not taking a salary
and then paying the bills ourselves. Um,
but we wanted to learn a little bit
faster and so we hired Buen and Morgan
as the first engineers. And then the
second reason to raise capital is to
fund growth. You've you you've built
something and you want to tell the world
about it and you want to spend more
capital to do that. Um the third reason
to to to raise capital is for the
founders's ego.
Um it's a very popular appreciate the
honesty.
>> It's very popular. Very very popular.
Right. Big numbers, lots of press like
um and I think this is a very very
dangerous reason to raise money. And I
wish that it was more talked about
because you're diluting all of your
employees when you do it. You are um
setting a certain price for future
employees and their upside. It's
it's it for some people it can become a
status game and that's not what it's
about. We're here to build a big
business together and
this is not a reason to raise money. Um
but I I do think that it happens. Um the
fourth reason to to to raise capital is
to reward your employees, right? It's a
you're on a very long journey and you
want to work with the best people in the
world and by definition there's not that
many best people in the world. So you
want to reward them. Um that was the
reason that we took more capital in
December um was to allow the employees
to liquidate as some of their equity um
instead of waiting for some like event
like an IPO or something like further
out. Um the fifth reason to raise is for
a strategic partnership. There are
strategic partnerships that have been
made in this in this city that have made
companies. Um and um the sixth reason to
raise would be do doing M&A or or
something like that. But it's like you
have to be very honest about what reason
you were raising in those six. First
reason we raised was one and second
reason we raised was four. Um so which
which ones? First reason to raise was
R&D.
>> R&D and the second reason was
>> um to provide liquidity to the employees
>> employees. Yep.
I I think it's a it's a nice and healthy
way and I think yeah the the e ego part
we don't talk about and the identity and
especially the closer you are to to tech
e ecosystems where a lot of people are
raising it it will be part of it as
closing I I wanted to ask you about the
way you have a remote culture these days
I'm seeing it especially for companies
that do anything with AI may that be
building AI infra or or or just AI
products a lot of them prefer in person
having a HQ often times in SF or
wherever your headquarters may that be
London or somewhere else because you
often these companies often find that
they have faster iteration uh it's just
fewer layers cut in between and of
course speed is is very very important
you have started full remote and you're
still full remote how is it working uh
and what kind of quirks or like or turbo
ways have you found to to make this work
better
>> yeah I think so the the company started
in in 23. So sort of like on the on the
on the cusp of COVID where a lot of
companies were just remote. Um the
Shopify infra team was remote since the
very um very beginning because it's very
difficult to get them all to move to
Ottawa.
>> Um and
so it was natural to me it's like okay I
think there is kind of maybe two cities
where you can build a database company
fast and that's San Francisco and and
maybe New York. There are maybe other
cities, right? But that's like kind of
where it's been done.
>> Yeah.
>> And so if you don't want to do that, I
think you have to go all in on on on
some distributed model.
>> And so we've tried to figure out what
does that distributed model mean for
Turppuffer? It doesn't mean the absence
of in person. We get everyone together
twice a year in in some in in some
location. Uh earlier this year we were
in in B, right? And then we were in
Mexico City and so on. So it's like
that's that's not that uncommon. Um but
one of the things that we we we've been
trying to do is we have this concept
called campfires. And the concept of the
campfire is that when a couple of people
just sort of randomly congregate in a
place, you call it a campfire and you
encourage as many people as you want to
come and join. So for example, this week
is a Turbo Puffer campfire in San
Francisco because I'm here for this
conference and a bunch of other things.
And so everyone is invited to come. Like
we're going to go meet customers, right?
We're going to put on dinners for our
customers and things like that. And we
just make a thing out of it and and
spend time together. And uh we encourage
everyone to come. We've also gone to the
extent now of um we want to encourage
that but not everyone not everyone needs
to go to the campfire all the time. Some
people just want to you know lock in and
hacks into tent and that's great. We
have people that just make it to the off
sites twice a year and otherwise they're
home they're with their families and
they don't they don't spend time on an
airplane. Um fantastic like that is
completely compatible with this model.
And there are other people at the
company who are on a plane probably
every two weeks. Um, we had someone the
other day where they saw a campfire
happening in New York and everyone was
dialing in from a meeting room in New
York and she had so much FOMO that she
took an Uber straight to the airport in
Ottawa and flew to flew to New York to
hang out with the team, right? And I
think that's fantastic. Um, and we've
also introduced these things where um,
if you if you uh, if you do a conference
talk or a blog post or something like
that, a turbop or something a bit
extracurricular, we give you a turbo
credit and a turbo credit allows you to
upgrade your next flight to business
class which again encourages spending
time together with the team. Um, and now
I mean turbo credits are probably going
to take on a life of their own. Someone
was talking about doing a central bank
and doing interest rates on the turbo
credits. um and doing a betting market
on the turbo credits. And so like this
might take on its life on its own. Um
and uh you you know if you um if you're
at a conference like this, there's some
of the our engineers here who are just
want to interact with customers and be
on like and standing on a like expo
floor all day is quite taxing. And so if
you do that for two days because you
want to do it, oh, you get a turbo
credit, right? And so it's just like
these fun little things that we try to
do to to to encourage people to meet if
they want to meet Thank you. Well, in
this session, uh, what I found very
interesting is Turbopuffer is a so many
AI companies are using you as an
infrastructure layer, but in this
conversation, we managed to talk very
little about AI and a lot more about
engineering principles, pushing, being
curious, and the human connection, how
important it is for people to work
together, to trust each other. So, just
thank you very much for that. So, let's
give a big round of applause for Simon.
>> Thank you so much. This is great. Thank
you.
infrastructure for the meta super
tangentes lab and their infrastructure
organization.
Today we're going to be talking about
production val for authentic systems.
When most people hear the word
valuation, they think about benchmarks.
A model scores 90% on a benchmark. A new
version scores 92%, the team celebrates.
But agent systems have fundamentally
changed what the evaluation means. Today
the systems don't simply generate
answers. They plan, they call tools,
they retrieve information, they execute
workflows, they interact with the
production infrastructure. The question
is no longer did the model generate the
right answer. The question is did the
system behave correctly. Today I would
like to discuss how evaluation is
evolving from model benchmarking into
production infrastructure.
This is the problem almost every AI
organization is encountering today.
Offline benchmarks continue improving.
Yet production reliability often remains
unpredictable. Why is that? Because
benchmarks measure model capability.
Production measures system behavior. A
benchmark doesn't capture tool failure,
API outage, context changes, user
variability, longunning workflows. And
as systems become more autonomous, the
gap between the benchmark performance
and production performance grows. The
result is what many teams
All
right. Hello everyone.
Um,
my name is Kevin. I'm going to be
talking about anti-gravity.
So, are there any World Cup fans out
there? Woo!
Imagine you are coaching Argentina and
you're in the 89th minute and you have
Messi on your team. What play are you
running?
It's called give Messi the ball and get
the heck out of the way. LLMs aren't
just role players anymore. They can be
your star player if you build the right
product around them. And to let your
star player cook, you have to get out of
the model's way.
We might want to get the slide. Are the
slides up? Oh, they are. Great. Um, so
anti-gravity is Google's agentic coding
product for technical and non-technical
users. Uh, we launched back in November
of 2025 and have been accelerating devs
both within Google and externally ever
since. My name is Kevin How and I lead
the engineering team on anti-gravity.
So let's talk a little bit more about
what anti-gravity is. We have and always
will be unapologetically agent first.
So, we debuted the anti-gravity IDE last
year with a brand new agent manager
concept and it was a platform to manage
and orchestrate many agents. Since then,
we've actually extracted our agent and
launched our own anti-gravity CLI. And
last month at Google IO, we had the
pleasure of launching anti-gravity 2.0.
In the theme of getting the model out of
the way, we actually decoupled the IDE
from the agent manager. So, now you have
two separate applications. Um, and now
you can use the agent manager in a
standalone app.
And since pictures are worth a thousand
words, here's a screenshot of
anti-gravity 2.0 in action. As you can
see, not only is it your own dedicated
mission control for your agents and
projects, you have sub agents, you have
all the new models, you have work trees,
scheduled tasks, voice mode. There are
so many things to unpack with the
product. But I don't want to spend today
telling you about the product. I want to
tell you a little bit more about the
behind the scenes, some of the
principles that went into it, and
notably some of the things that led to
its roadmap.
So, as some of you, for the longtime
AIGE fans, uh this is actually my fifth
time speaking at AIG. Um, and I've been
building developers tools since 2022.
And the one thing that has stood above
all other lessons that I've tal talked
about is the idea of scaling with
intelligence. This means that as the
model gets better, so should your
product and the frontier edge of
whatever model you are serving should be
apparent inside of your users's product
experience. So let's get into more
concrete examples of what this means.
So for those of you that follow me on X
or hear me just yap generally for the
last four years, you'll know that I've
been working on a number of these sort
of transformations year over year over
year. In 2022, I was working on
autocomplete and chat sidebars. This was
based on embeddings, rules, files, as
syntax tree parsing. Basically,
everything inside of that app is
deterministic because that's all that
the model could really handle. And in
2024, when agents came onto the scene,
it completely changed how developers
were going to do work. With it came new
primitives like MCPs, custom tools, and
permission systems. And with 2025, we
introduced anti-gravity's agent manager
with many other products following suit
in that similar form factor with users
managing many agents at once in
parallel. And this led to things like
skills, hooks, artifacts, and a couple
other primitives. Um, and that sort of
defined the 2025 era. So, let's talk a
little bit about 2026 and what those
primitives might be.
Before we answer this question, I want
to take you back to some of these battle
scars that are a little bit closer to
home. Scaling with intelligence really
is not easy. It's really hard to take
away something that users love and are
familiar with to lead them down
potentially, and that's a big keyword, a
better path. We aren't right 100% of the
time, but there are two that jump to
mind when I was putting together the
slides for this talk. The first one is
giving AI a terminal. We all remember
fears about son of Anton deleting your
entire codebase and doing catastrophic
things to both you know your startup
your company etc etc. But as models got
better and people invested in primitives
such as permission systems users ended
up building faster they ended up
shipping more and they did so safely. So
we were able to overcome this and as
models got smarter they were able to
make better decisions about what they
should and should not run in your
terminal.
The second instance is um this tweet
which is very representative of sort of
the yelling that I got uh when we
removed chat from windsurf. So a lot of
users were yelling at our team because
we took away something that was very
dear to them the chat sidebar and
replaced it with only an agent. Now at
the time this is something that was
familiar and rather difficult to
swallow. But when we look back models
have advanced multi-step research
agentic research and execution became
the new paradigm. And here we are today
using and loving all these agentic
products.
And so now I bring you to today's
battle. What is going on today? So we
decoupled the agent manager from the
IDE. And with anti-gravity 2.0, we split
them into separate applications. We
believe that the IDE is to the agent
manager what the debugger was to the
IDE. You don't always need a debugger,
but it definitely is helpful to have it
if you need to go a layer beneath and go
one step deeper into that abstraction
stack. And our prediction is that this
idea of agent orchestration, you can
call it agent teams, you can call it
swarms, you could call it software
factories, is the future. And we're
willing to bet on that future.
So here are the primitives for what
we're calling the agent teams 2026 era.
These are things like sub aents,
generative UI, and sidecars. And we'll
talk more concretely about what those
things are and some examples of how they
manifest inside of the product. But it's
really important to first understand the
why. What brought about these changes?
And what model changes? What model
properties actually led to the
development of these new things? And as
a product team, do you force the new era
of primitives or is it something that
comes to you by using the model and
experiencing the model? The answer is
kind of both, right? And the privilege
of being inside of Google DeepMind is
that we do have that relationship
between the product and the model.
So you remember the crux of anti-gravity
1.0 is to manage agents in parallel to
put the human in the driver's seat. And
if you remember my last talk, I talked a
lot more about this research product
flywheel. And now as promised, because
of the anti-gravity product, Gemini has
now learned a thing or two about how to
manage a team of agents. There's still a
lot of headroom to make multi- aent
systems better, more collaborative,
better at deconstructing tasks into
smaller tasks, but we've got a really
good head start with Gemini. And all the
basics have been imbued to the model so
that we can build a product like
anti-gravity 2.0.
Gemini 3.5 Fl Yeah, Gemini 3.5 Flash was
launched back in April. And this brought
to market a lot of those capabilities
that we had been working on in the
background with anti-gravity. And Flash
now isn't just good at executing tasks.
It's actually really good at leading
teams. It's faster and cheaper, pushing
the paro curve of what is intelligent
versus the speed and the cost at which
you run those things.
And putting this all together, we were
really excited to announce agent teams
in public preview inside of
anti-gravity. All you have to do is
simply type the slash command/teamwork
and you'll see a new mode where you can
enter and unleash a swarm of agents onto
the task at hand. So we'll talk a little
bit about how this works. You as a user
will specify your task. The more
specific you are, the better. Though the
nature of these agentic communication
styles is that if it needs something
more, it can actually ask you for more
until everything is basically clear.
You'll work with that lead agent and it
will manage a team of arbitrary size to
get that work done. And what I like to
say, it's kind of like the Avengers,
right? It'll take a bunch of specialized
roles. It may front-end engineers,
backend engineers, infrastructure
specialists, QA, design, the list goes
on and on and on. And there are infinite
possibilities for what each of those sub
aents could take on. Each sub aent is
dynamically generated and can operate
independently.
Um, and it can even actually select a
different model from what the main agent
is using. And this is done so by that
main agent. Again, we are scaling with
intelligence.
And one of the coolest aspects of this
is that it can use generative UI. With a
model that is as fast as Flash, things
can happen nearly instantaneously. If
you ask, hey, what is the status of my
task? show me a cananban of what's going
on or maybe you know you prefer
something a little bit more like uh the
the Chrome debugger tool. It can show
you a timeline that all these things are
generated on the fly because it's able
to generate UI on demand.
So some of the projects that the system
has implemented um we've built a photo
editor can actually edit raw photos
directly inside of your browser. Um
we've also built a messaging app that
might look a little bit familiar to
those in the room. Um, and each of these
took hundreds of sub aents uh and took
almost half a day to run. But to really
put it through its paces, one of the
hero runs that we did was actually
building an entire OS kernel. This is
something that uh we got to show off at
Google IO, but we built a complete OS
kernel from scratch and actually played
Doom on it. And my colleague Verun was
able to demo this at Google IO. We were
super proud of this particular milestone
because it really demonstrated that if
you throw more intelligence, you throw
more sub aents um at this sort of
problem, a model like Gemini 3.5 Flash
could do this in a way that was not only
very very powerful but also scalable and
you know mildly affordable. Obviously,
we're not going to spend thousands and
thousands of dollars to build an OS
kernel every day, though it is possible.
And some of the stats out of this, it
took 93 sub aents over the course of 12
hours, made 15,000 requests, two billion
tokens, and it was under $1,000, which
was one of the really cool aspects of
this project. And so, as you can see
with this particular example, sub agent
primitives are one of the defining parts
about building a 2026 era of agent
teams. So, agent teams are just that
first example. And I want to show you
another example that our team uses
internally that sort of demonstrates
some of these new primitives.
Um the second one is about automating
research tasks. So we work inside of
Gemini. We help sort of make Gemini
better at coding related tasks, agentic
related tasks. And this is where the
real magic starts happening with the
product. We have an internal version of
anti-gravity that researchers,
engineers, nontechnical folks can use.
And when they understand the primitives
that anti-gravity offers, it becomes a
very very powerful way to automate your
own workflows. So we'll take the example
of sidebyside eval analysis. So this is
a very common workflow not only at
DeepMind but just generally in the
industry. You essentially will take
multiple rollouts 1 2 3 4 etc. Um and
you want to compare them. So you'll take
a set of tasks, you'll do some rollouts,
you'll get some results and they'll
essentially be in two different tables.
Now you'll look at the control, you'll
look at the experiment and then you'll
have to figure out not only what the
difference was but perhaps what are the
reasons for those differences and how
can we actually iterate from there and
make a better version of for the next
experiment. Now traditionally this was a
lot of Jupyter notebook elbow grease
essentially but when you start working
with the new primitives in 2026 you end
up with a lot cleaner of a workflow.
So researchers were able to automate 90%
of this workflow by simply asking the
agent about the eval in question using
natural language. Then the agent that is
now primed with skills and an
understanding of Google's massive monor
repo codebase is able to crunch the
numbers and get back to you with a
delta. Now what's really cool here is
instead of just taking that delta then
handing it back to the user, it went the
extra step. It spun up for a research
agent specialist that proposes a hundred
different hypotheses over why those
deltas might occur. And then it uses sub
aents to then spit up one sub aent for
each hypothesis and basically drills
into that particular case in parallel
mapping back to a single response and
then telling the researcher, hey here
are some areas that I found. Now uh
here's a report that you can review. And
what's really cool is that it doesn't
stop at just the report. It actually
puts together a generative UI for you to
look through, interact, select
dropdowns, filter, segment, slice, and
actually interact richly with that data.
And internally, we care a lot about this
sort of workflow, improving the model,
improving the product, and understanding
the ways that users find success and
failure internally at Google. So, what
used to be a very manual process now
takes minutes. So, what used to be
handineering, you'd have to build your
own async pool of agents, you'd have to
set up your judges, uh you'd have to
tape together data pipelines, all of
this now starts becoming grounded in
these new primitives that we've
established earlier in the slideshow.
You have a sub aent graph that is
completely dynamic. The generative UI
comes in at the end to richly convey the
findings in a way that the user best
understands or maybe caters to their
learning style. And all of these things
can be regenerated and redone on the
fly. All the user had to do was load up
a skills file and ask away.
So with teamwork and this eval example,
we start arriving at these 2026
primitives that I keep talking about.
And these model characteristics really
change the way that we have to think
about the product and how we have to
develop the product. So the three
examples that we've talked about, first
we have the dynamic sub aent. And to
provide a little bit more color here,
basically no two sub aents are the same.
The main agent is the one that is
orchestrating this entirely on its own.
It's configuring and prompting and
seeding these sub aents on the fly. They
can operate in parallel. They can
operate in different types of secure
environments be it a sandbox be it a
remote execution system and they can all
take on infinitely an infinite number of
specialized roles. So the scaling story
here is quite obvious and from the last
two examples you can probably tell as
the model gets smarter your team will
become more specialized it will become
more collaborative and ultimately that
means it'll be capable of getting more
complex work done for you.
And now the second is this new concept.
We've alluded to it slightly in the
past, but it's called sidecars. This is
a new plug-in protocol that we're
bringing to anti-gravity. A sidecar
process is essentially it is a sidecar
process. The naming sort of reflects
what's going on under the hood, but it's
a longived utility and it's responsible
for listening. It allows the model to
listen to the outside world and set up
its own triggers for things that might
happen. For example, this could be SMS
messages. This could be web hooks, cron
jobs, hooking it up to GitHub PRs, the
the list goes on and on. But this is a
generic plug-in primitive. Anti-gravity
already uses sidecars for things that
are timebased. This is where the the
scheduled task cron concept comes from.
Um, but under the hood, this is all this
new sidecar primitive. So, we'll be
releasing the spec for this so that you
all can build on top of this new
primitive um later this summer. But
there are some really, really cool ways
that people internally have been using
this sort of concept.
And the third and final primitive is
generative UI. So we hypothesize that
human written specialized UIs are kind
of dead.
Gemini Flash on anti-gravity clocks in
at almost 900 tokens a second. This is
10x faster than a lot of the other
frontier model experiences. And in a
matter of seconds, you're able to go
from whatever you were thinking inside
of your head into a prompt into a use
case that is designed and embedded
inside of your conversation view
perfectly. And rather than rely on
templates or even HTML files,
anti-gravity can render your generated
UI in line. So you can do things like
this and play Doom, but this also
extends to things like bar charts,
graphs, um, tables, anything that you
would want to interact with and maybe
inspect a little bit further than just a
markdown file or just a conversation.
And generative UI in many ways reminds
me of the quote that the late Steve Jobs
said when unveiling the iPhone. He
justifies the removal of the keyboard
and says they all have these keyboards.
They are there whether you need them or
not. And they all have these control
buttons that are fixed in plastic and
are the same for every application. In
an analogous way, we built our product
to dynamically scale with the needs of
the agent. We skipped the heavy
infrastructure and mechanical UIs in
favor of sidecars and generative UI. And
that creates a product experience that
is not fixed in plastic.
So sub aents, sidecar triggers, and
generative UI are the latest primitives
that are powering anti-gravity. We've
tried our best to stay out of the way
and let the model cook. And if you're
building a product around an agent, you
should consider what are the primitives
that are in my product and how might
they scale with the model's
intelligence. We all are familiar with
shipping features is now quite easy with
all of these new tools. And it's about
deciding what features to actually add
um so that the model so that your
product can scale with the next release
of the next model which will inevitably
be faster, better, and cheaper. And so
with the right primitives, you as a
builder or you as a product owner, you
might be surprised at what the models
can do. And in classic fashion, I'm
going to keep using the slide until
we've actually conquered the TPU crunch.
So you can find me on Twitter. Uh you
can DM me for feedback. We're always
looking for new ideas on how to build
the latest and greatest. Thank you for
watching. Thank you Swix and Ben for
having me. It's always a joy to be here.
And I'll be at the anti-gravity booth if
you want to talk further, if you want to
get to know the product a bit more. Some
team members will be there. So, thank
you so much for your time. Excited to
meet you all.
Not for human.
In 2026, coding agents will quietly
retire their first software platform.
Not because it's bad, simply because the
platform is unnecessary.
I am Dominic Turno. I am founder and CEO
of Resonate. Resonate is a durable
execution platform built with minimalism
and simplicity as its core technical
values. And these properties will play a
central role in this talk. At Resonate,
we have a working theory where software
engineering is headed.
Generalpurpose implementations will
increasingly be replaced by bespoke
implementations
generated on demand, not as a new
library, a new framework, or a new
platform, but as a minimal extension of
the infrastructure that is already in
place.
If this theory holds true, reuse will
move upstream.
Instead of reusing a general purpose
implementation, we will reuse a
specification and we will derive a
bespoke implementation from it.
In fact, we can build many bespoke
implementations
tailor made for the infrastructure that
is already in place.
We just have to ask the agent. At this
point, the prompt is a platform.
Resonate is a dual execution platform.
We have an implementation of the
Resonate server. We have implementations
of the Resonate SDK for TypeScript,
Python, Rust, Go, and Java. So, we have
to ask what does this new reality mean
for us?
If implementations become generatable,
where does our value live? And our
answer, our value moves from
implementation to specification.
Now this changes how we think about
Resonate. The product is no longer the
implementation. The product is the
specification, the protocol.
And from that protocol, we want to
derive multiple server implementations.
One is a general purpose resonate
server, our reference implementation.
Others are implementations built with
infrastructure partners.
For customers and partners, this means
durable execution right on top of their
existing infrastructure with minimal
additional dependencies.
So the question is no longer can we
build a server. The question is can we
repeatedly synthesize trusted servers
from the same specification
and if so how?
When we talk about agentic engineering
we focus all of our attention on
verification.
How do we know the result is correct?
But today I want to focus on the
specification instead and more
importantly how can agents participate
in specifying the system not just
building or verifying it.
Now Resonate is partnering with multiple
infrastructure providers to bring
durable executions natively to their
technology stack. One of them is Senadia
the company behind Nats.io
an open-source messaging system designed
for building modern distributed systems.
for the rest of this presentation.
Okay. Hello everyone. I'm excited to be
here. Uh my name is Zach Lloyd. Um today
I'm going to be talking about
self-improving software factories, the
new open- source model, and basically
what I think is happening to
development. A little bit about me just
to begin. So I am a former uh principal
engineer from Google, lead engineering
on the Google Doc Suite. I've been an
engineer now for over 20 years. Long
time. I am still uh shipping frequently,
but I haven't written a line of code in
the last six months. Uh and I'm the
founder of a company called Warp. Uh
Warp, if you're not familiar, is a
open-source agentic development
environment. Uh you may know us as a
terminal. That is how the company
started. We're basically a terminal that
has agents built in. Uh we open sourced
it a couple months ago and I'm going to
talk a little bit about that experience
and the motivation for it. It's popular
open source project over 60,000 GitHub
stars. We've had a couple hundred people
contributing. We have over 800,000
active developers who are using warp.
And increasingly we are focused not just
on the terminal aspect and the
interactive aspect of development but
more so on how do you automate
development. I'm going to talk mostly
about that.
So the thesis that I have uh is that the
discipline of software engineering is
going to become something more like
factory engineering and I'll explain
what I mean by this in a minute but just
keep that in mind. That's that's what I
think is going to happen. Um if you look
at development over the past couple
years it's I mean it's crazy how it's
changed. We've gone from a world of chat
and AI autocomplete, so cursor co-pilot,
to the phase that we're in now, which I
consider to be mostly interactive
agents. So you're sort of sitting at
your computer and you are telling cloud
code to do something, you're telling
warp to do something. And I believe
what's going to happen over the next six
months, a year, hard to predict the
pace, is that we're going to move much
more towards a world of automation.
But before I get into that, just quick
show of hands. How many folks in here
are building with agents?
Every 100% makes sense. Uh how many how
many folks are building typically with
multiple agents at one time?
So again, almost everyone. How many
people are running an agent right now?
I'm not offended. I would Okay, that's
totally cool. I would be doing it too.
Uh how many folks are running agents in
the cloud out of curiosity?
So that looks like less than half but
still significant. Uh and how many folks
have have set up a system internally to
automate the whole software development
life cycle. So everything from like
triaging, specking, implementing,
reviewing.
So I see
some hand. So some people are doing
this. So this is what's going to happen.
Uh, every project of significant size, I
believe, is going to have something like
this. Um, and it's going to look kind of
like this big loop. And everyone is
talking about loops. There's nothing
that complicated about loops. This loop
says a cloud software factory. This loop
could literally just say like the
software development life cycle. It's
the same thing. Um, but just to go
through this loop, it's like ideas are
going to come in at the top. Agents are
going to do triage. If something is
complicated, they will write a spec. Uh
these little blue boxes are where humans
step in. Humans will review the spec. Uh
agents will do the implementation. A
human and agent will review the code.
Agents will verify. Human will review
the product. You ship and then you
monitor and round and round you go. Uh
and this is what software development
for better or worse I think is going to
end up looking like. So I repeat the
thesis which is that if this is what
software engineering is going to look
like um software engineers are going to
be the ones who end up building and
managing these factories. Now I promised
at the beginning and I put in the title
of the talk that I was going to talk
about open source and so I want to do
that for a few minutes. I'm going to
take a quick digression. Um, I bring up
open source because one of the main
reasons that Warp opens sourced was to
build uh build a public factory. Um, and
so this is a picture of this website
we've built called build.warp.dev which
shows
all of the issues that are flowing
through our system and what state
they're in, what agents are working on
them, what contributors are working on
them. And it's kind of like a
protoactory done at scale. It's not
working perfectly, but it is working.
And one of the reasons we open sourced
was to try to build this. Um, just in
general, I think it's interesting to
talk about open source in the time of
agentic development. This is a really
stupid graph, but it's like it just it
you get it. It's like it's becoming much
cheaper to build software. Um, a
correlary of that is that it's becoming
trivial to clone software. And so if you
are in the software business, and I
don't know how many folks in this room
are in the software business per se, but
it's very hard to build a software
business if it's free to build software.
It's hard to capture the value,
especially if a competitor can clone.
And so my big takeaway or big tip for
everyone in here is that the first thing
you should do is patent your code. I'm
kidding. Don't This is a complete joke.
Don't don't don't do this.
Uh my my first tip is obviously you need
to have a great product. Uh this has
always been the case. Um but I would say
a great product probably was never
enough. But even now more than ever, if
you think that you're going to build a
great software business just by building
and shipping a great product, you're
probably not going to succeed. Uh you
need advantages beyond the product. And
so those advantages could look like
distribution
ecosystem. It could be that you have a
great brand or a data moat. You might
have capital. Um, but if you're a
startup, again, I'm coming from the
startup world here, you just don't have
these advantages. And so, you you still
want to break through. Uh, and one of
the ways that I suggest doing this is by
building in the open. And so, to be
clear, it took Warp five years of
building closed to sort of make the leap
into building in the open. And I'll
explain why. But if you build in the
open, um it helps build your ecosystem.
It it can take you from being like hated
on hacker news to like tolerated. Uh it
can burnish your brand. It creates
community. And so there's all these
advantages to it. Uh and some of the
things that I think have traditionally
been a pain um can now be managed. And
so like the traditional, you know, pain
of open source might be something like
you get a lot of noisy issues.
You get sloppy PRs,
you can end up in code review hell, you
can end up having to spend a lot of time
verifying changes. And so the solution,
it's a kind of a long-winded way of
getting to this for open source or at
least for Warp in the case of open
source. The thing that made us finally
decide to do this was that we built a
whole set of automations, really a
software factory around managing the
open-source project. And so, like I
said, this is what I think the future is
going to look like. I'm going to drill
into it a bit just to get a little bit
more technical for folks who want to try
to build something like this for their
own projects.
So, what are the components of an
effective software factory? Uh it's
really not that complicated to start or
at a high level. You need a set of
automations. You need a way of providing
context and skills. You need a way of
bringing humans in at the correct time
to sort of like when things get stuck on
the factory. And then a really important
thing is you need some set of
self-improvement capabilities. So think
of this as loops.
And if you do this right, uh, in the
open source world, you can get a, you
know, world where agents are helping
contributors contribute. They're helping
maintainers maintain.
And I want to emphasize there's nothing
special about open source here. I think
every sizable project can benefit from
this approach. And I I predict that
every every company, every open source
project will have at its core a software
factory. kind of like the way that CI/CD
became just like, oh, of course you have
that. Uh maybe I don't know when that
happened 10 years ago. Let's tour the t
uh the factory floor for a second here.
So, you're not going to look at this.
This is too much. Uh the the point of
this slide is not to have you read the
workflow. It's that the factory floor is
basically a graph um of steps where you
are defining like okay, how does
software get built for my product? And
it looks pretty similar for every
product. Things come in, they flow
through, um, they get stuck at certain
points. Um, and you know, broadly
speaking, just to back out a second. So
there's the inputs. The inputs are
really ideas. Um, the inputs could be
coming from your team, they could be
coming from your users. Um, the inputs
themselves tend to come in through
certain channels that you should think
about as like your task tracker is an
obvious one or Slack, your teams, like
your communication channels. They could
come directly from like your terminal or
IDE. They could come from your
monitoring systems, but there's some set
of inputs that bring work into the
factory.
There's triage. This is a really
important step. So
again, I boil it down to something very
simple, but like you want an agent that
is looking at issues as they come in and
just saying, you know, if this is easy
and this is unambiguous, just implement
it and this is how you can actually get
going with a factory. If an issue is
hard, uh I recommend having uh an agent
that produces specs. Folks in here using
spec driven development, show hands,
people follow this. Okay, you can do
this many different ways, but I think
it's very effective. The way that uh we
do it at Warp that I recommend is having
an agent write what we call a product
spec and a tech spec. Product spec
describes the product invariance that
you're building towards. Techsp spec
describes the architecture and the shape
of the code.
Then you have an implementation agent.
This is basically a coding agent that
runs somewhere in the cloud. It makes a
diff. You can use all sorts of coding
agents for this. You have review.
This is in many ways the most painful
part. Like I expect that people are a
little bit tired of reviewing a gentic
slop. Uh I would have an agent do code
review first and then it becomes over
time like a riskmanagement exercise of
like when do you bring in humans to do
code review. But you want to have a step
in here where humans can do it.
This is a very important step uh for
certain types of apps. The verification
step. So this would be things like
computer use. Uh if you're building a a
sort of UI, having the computer actually
use the code that the agent produced and
producing videos and screenshots. CI/CD
still use it obviously. Uh and then
monitoring. So agents don't stop in your
factory when code is shipped. They
should observe what's been shipped. Is
it crashing? is it being used? And round
and round you go because you take the
output of this monitoring step and you
feed it back into the top of the
factory.
Now you could try and build this and um
I went to a talk earlier that my friend
Adam gave where Uber has built an
internal version of this um and it's
pretty cool. I would say for most,
you know, most organizations, it really
depends where you are. You'll be able to
build a simple version of this easily,
but to build a thing that actually
scales is probably like you should
probably be focusing on your own
product, not building this
infrastructure because there's a lot of
stuff that you end up wanting. You're
not again not supposed to read this. Uh
it's just a lot of stuff. If you do
build it um or if you buy it, you'll end
up with something that looks kind of
like this, which is um you're going to
have a bunch of ways of getting work
into your factory. That's what's at the
top here. You're going to have a sort of
control plane for figuring out how work
gets distributed across your factory
floor. You're going to have the actual
place where the work happens. And so
that's going to be cloud sandboxes.
It's going to be figuring out what agent
to run. So, what's the harness? What's
the model? And then finally, I think
this is a really important thing. You're
going to want to set up some kind of
data plane that sits below your factory.
And so, that's something that lets
agents remember what they've done,
learn,
um, improve over time.
The factory is not just like a product,
it's also a mindset. And this brings me
back to
the thesis I had at the beginning.
You need to measure and improve. So
factory,
this is where the I don't know, you can
stretch this metaphor as far as you
want, but like you should be thinking of
efficiency. And so that means like how
much software did you ship? How much did
it cost in terms of human time and token
time and you're going to want to measure
this and try to improve it over time.
A key part of this is creating loops.
So, uh, loops are again, they sound
complicated. They're not that
complicated. Loops are basically ways
of, uh, having agents improve, um, by
like observing what they're doing, where
they're failing. Um, and so a common
kind of loop that you're going to want
to put in your factory is like a skill
loop. That means you're going to have
your factory agents that are running
skills, and then you'll have observer
agents that are seeing how those skills
are being applied, looking for issues,
and trying to improve the skills. So for
instance, if you had a code review agent
uh and it was leaving comments and a
senior engine engineering or team was
going and correcting those comments,
you'd want an observer agent that would
look at that and basically uh improve
the code review agent for the next run.
This is one thought just to leave folks
with like what is where does this leave
engineers? Um, I think you're going to
have to get into this mindset,
and I'm trying very hard to get our team
into this mindset. It's not always easy
that you're not just building the
product, but you're building the thing
that builds the product. And that's like
it's just different. It's more like
process engineering or manufacturing or
something like that. Um, and you could
think like, okay, maybe that's a bummer.
Like, is that a bummer? is that uh you
know and it depends like it depends what
joy you get out of software engineering.
If your joy is in writing the code, I
think you're everyone in here who is a
software engineer is going to be writing
less code. But if your joy is in
shipping product, like it's never been a
better time. And this is actually where
I find my joy. It's like I like building
and shipping the thing. So everyone in
here is going to code less, but they're
going to ship more. And that's going to
be a trade-off.
But if you approach it like you're a a
factory engineer, I think you can see
like that there's still a really cool
set of engineering challenges. Um you
could almost think of it as like
meta-engineering like how do you
engineer your system of agents to be the
best possible engineering that I think
is a very compelling and interesting set
of challenges to solve.
So that's it. Um uh for folks who were
interested uh this if you follow the
link on this QR code I've set up um a
open source GitHub repo where anyone who
wants to try building their own factory
agents can do it. This uses Warps uh
agent platform as part of it. But you
honestly you don't have to use it. I'm
not trying to like push into our
product. But this should give you a good
sense of like, okay, if you want to set
up uh an agent that does uh triage or an
agent that does uh specw writing, how do
you actually do that? How do you get
from like the theory of uh working with
a factory to actually putting it into
practice? Um I don't know if we have the
capability to do questions in here. I
saved a few minutes for questions if
anyone has questions. Otherwise, I will
I will wrap up. Yes.
Yes,
>> it's a great question. So, I said
something that's almost contradictory. I
think um you should the way you should
think of it is like everyone's going to
deploy some sort of factory, but then
the tuning of the factory, the like are
these the right skills for my domain? Is
this factory building my product in the
right way? I still think there's a bunch
of interesting engineering challenges
and for some places you can build this
but again I I think I think that the you
should probably be focusing on building
the core product for your company for
the most part but there's a bunch of
like tuning and like uh figuring out how
to make the factory work for your
product that matters. That's a great
question. Yes.
>> Yes.
Yeah. So the the question in case people
couldn't hear was like if I was a
college student graduating and entering
the workforce right now. So I think that
the most important skills in this new
world are adaptability. I think that
that's critical thinking. It's like this
the speed at which you can learn. I do
think I don't know if you're a computer
science student, but I still think
there's a ton of value in understanding
like the underlying systems and
architecture and being able to reason
and understand the code, understand the
specs that agents are written, sorry,
our writing. So, I I would focus on on
those skills. Um, and like I don't know,
we're hiring more people than we've ever
hired. There's a lot of kind of like
misdirection around like you know people
not being hired because of AI. That's
not the experience we've had so far. And
what I'm looking for are like really
adaptable product focused thinkers who
can like basically be great problem
solving problem solvers uh even as the
underlying technology changes.
Yeah, I think I have time for one more
question. Yes.
What about the like so the question was
what about the the product taste and
like the how do you actually build
something useful I think is probably the
right like maybe the framing and like uh
where do the ideas come from and so I
think that um the problem with the
factory metaphor even though I'm like
leaning into it because I think that's
like there's something to it is that it
can kind of sound like uh mechanizing or
dehumanizing
um and I still think underlying ing all
of this, the only thing that matters is
like are you building something useful?
And if you have like a a factory that is
like
churning out that no one cares
about, it's like what's the point? And I
think that human taste, human input,
human product sense, um humans like
guiding at those touch points where you
can't automate stuff is absolutely like
essential. And like that's like what I
do like I'm trying to figure out what
what do customers want, what do people
want, what's going to be valuable to
them. So I think that's an absolutely
key point to it. I think I'm at time so
I I have to go. I hope folks uh enjoyed
this chat. Uh really grateful for being
invited to speak. So thank you all very
much. Yeah,
agents in production. Specifically how
open gov built and scaled ogassist.
Uh so um this presentation is going to
be jam-packed with just so much good
stuff. Uh we're going to talk about uh
AI agents. We're going to talk about our
harness. We're going to talk about um
eval observability traces. We're going
to talk about um tools and skills. Um
it's there's going to be a lot of good
stuff in here. We're going to talk to
you guys about uh what we do at OpenGV
and how we operate at the scale that uh
we operate at um in production. So
you'll be able to see a real use case
and workload uh with AI agents. Um so
without further ado, let's get started.
Okay, agenda. So just really quickly
going to go through uh high level what
we're going to talk about today. Uh I'm
going to tell you guys a little bit
about OG Assist and what uh OpenGV is.
I'm gonna tell you guys the origin story
of how this all kind of came to be. Uh
we're going to talk about OGs uh big bet
on effect uh a little bit into our core
agent loop. Uh we're going to talk about
the A2A protocol, eval.
We're going to talk about how we manage
long context. We're going to talk about
um monitoring observability, how we
collect feedback uh and how we iterate
on that feedback. We're going to lastly
uh also talk about tools and skills and
how at open gov uh we use um AI not only
externally uh that we uh serve to
customers but also internally to improve
our development workflows.
Just a little bit about me before we go
any further. My name is Gabe. I'm a
software engineer here at OpenGV. I work
on the AI agents team and uh I'm one of
the folks that helped build uh OG Assist
and some of the systems that you guys
will be seeing today.
So, a little bit about OpenGV. OpenGV is
a software company uh on a mission to
power more effective and accountable
government. Um so, OpenGV sells ERP
software. That's things like budgeting,
procurement, asset management, and
permitting. And um we were founded about
14 years ago. And what's cool is um we
have this thing called OG Assist. And OG
Assist is this little button on the top
of all of our products in the in the
navigation bar. And what's cool is um
all of our product suites and product
teams um have built tools and skills in
order to power this button. So, for
example, if I open up uh this this um if
I click this button and I open up OG
Assist, it says, "Hey, um I'm going to
ask about rate codes, which is very
specific to utility billing, the current
product that I'm in." And you can see
that inside of this kind of chat
interface, I'm able to speak to an
agent, and the agent is able to make
tool calls in order to um look up
information against data inside of that
suite. So, it's really cool um to be
able to kind of first party create these
experiences uh through the capability
that we've built called OG Assist.
Okay, so just a quick story about how
this all came to be. So, um, a little
while back, we we we saw that AI was
really starting to take off and a
principal, uh, spun up this new team
called the AI agents team and asked me
to join and, um, instantly I said yes
and OG Assist started to to grow and we
started to integrate, uh, OG Assist into
all our products and, uh, not only our
back-end capabilities, but also our
front-end capabilities as well. So,
you'll see that one of the capabilities
that we give the agent is it's able to
um see what's on the screen and and see
and and and take action on what's on the
page. So, you could see that um I'm
asking the agent here, hey, hey, what's
on the screen? Can you maybe highlight
uh some of the next steps that I could
take? So, you can see that the agent
here is thinking. It's saying, okay,
what tools do I have available to use?
And hey, let me go and highlight
something that you could actually click
on and and tell you more about it. So
just another capability of OG assist and
just a little short story about how this
all came to be.
So the big bet on effect. Um, so I
really wanted to include this slide
because um, here on the agents team, we
made a huge bet to um to to bet on
effect and suffice to say it's paid off
in dividends. Um, we write effect. So
effect is this library for Typescript.
It's open source and it helps you write
better um, TypeScript code. uh you know
it's got a lot of uh stuff baked in it
like a sk a schema similar to like zod
if you've ever used that. It's also got
um things for error handling uh for
logging for traces for uh it's just got
so much in there. It really helps write
better code and structure your code
better and uh helps with architecture,
spinning up new services for uh and and
for us on the agents team really helping
uh design and build the the core agent
loop. So you'll see throughout this
presentation sprinkled in um how effect
on our team uh has paid off in
dividends. So we we really love effect
here at open gov and we encourage other
folks to try it out and um yeah let's
keep going
the effect native loop. So originally we
were on lang graph and that was fine
until the team really started to scale
uh and our use cases started to evolve.
So we decided to move over to our own
kind of effect native agent loop to have
full regency over this uh agent loop
such that if we have complex use cases
or features that we need to build we
could kind of get in we we had full
control of the of the agent loop. And
not only that but now we're fully on
effect. So all the cool things you get
with effect is now propagated throughout
the entire agent loop like the tracing
structure currency, the logging,
everything is more fine grading control
and it it really allows us to really
unlock the full potential uh having our
own agent loop from the ground up. Um so
another thing I wanted to mention is on
the left side you'll see a code example.
This is really the basics of the effect
loop that we're using. Uh we're using
this thing called the effect AI package.
And in that package, there's this thing
called um there's a chat and a language
model. So with the chat, you can
instantiate like an a chat for example.
And then you could stream text using um
that that kind of stream text function.
You could pass in a prompt. And what's
cool is uh with a language model under
the hood of since we're kind of doing
dependency injection, we could pass in a
different language model if we were to
uh hot swap to another one for example.
So really just having full control of
our own agent loop just kind of gives us
all the levers and it really just
unlocks the full capabilities of the
model and uh for the team as well to
have full agency over this this loop.
Another thing I wanted to mention is the
agentto agent protocol. So here on the
agents team, we've had a lot of success
with this protocol. So this protocol
being the protocol that Google created
um kind of an open protocol for agents
to intercommunicate. But um we found
this very useful for uh defining our
agent routes for example in the back end
and our model and our schema to follow
this kind of uh agent protocol. So we
modeled so for example there's this
thing called an agent card which you see
here and it's got the name of the agent
a description etc right and having this
kind of rigorous protocol this rigorous
spec really helped drive our development
and drive alignment because you know all
we had to do was um align with this spec
and follow this spec and we knew that
this was kind of the contract that our
front end and backend and would both
consume and and produce. So, um this uh
I would say also has been uh very
helpful for us and and what's really
cool is A2A has a lot of extensions,
right? So, you could extend the protocol
uh add in like metadata. Uh there's also
A2UI.
Um so, lots of fun stuff uh with A2A
protocol, but uh this is kind of what's
worked for us. So just sharing that with
with you folks
feedback and eval. So here the quote is
shipping is the start not the finish. So
what we do here uh on the agency team is
we have kind of multiple ways we do
evals and collect feedback. Um obviously
you know we'll have folks uh call in or
or email us or or just let us know and
tell us. But the main way is we have
this thumbs up and thumbs down
mechanism. And here uh someone is able
to tell us, hey, this this worked really
well. This was a great response or that
wasn't a great response. And that signal
we take and we're able to iterate on uh
and we could take it back and help
improve uh you know the response in the
future. Um we also have automated evals.
So in in the in RCI we we have evals
that run against real completion. So we
could test the prompt against hey did it
hit some tools? Did it do what it's
supposed to do? And that also helps with
our accuracy. So, uh those automated
evals in conjunction with collecting
feedback really help us um improve our
our our tools, our skills, um our
harness and and that's really how we're
able to iterate so fast and so quickly.
Humans in the loop. So this is a really
cool feature we built where we
deterministically interrupt the agent
loop if there is a tool call approval
required. So if an agent tries
Okay. Hi everyone. Uh I'm Solomon. I am
the creator of Amcraft and I also
created MCPUI which became MCP apps and
MCP steering committee. I've done a
bunch of other stuff. Uh but we're here
to talk about why we're the bottleneck
and why we don't have to be.
So uh as you all know and use every day,
agents are amazing. There's so much they
can do. Uh from generating cat memes to
B2B SAS apps. So if they are so amazing,
we have to ask why aren't we all
unstoppable? Why doesn't everyone have
an army of agents that just does
whatever they want? So it should be
relatively easy. I mean, you just have a
bunch of monitors and you spin up 25
cloud code engines and you're done. So
the reality is that it's just not that
simple. To do something like that, you
need to a really want to use agents and
secondly, once you actually spin them
up, each one of these agents requires
you to steer them, direct them, review
them, and when it's at scale especially,
it's just exhausting. We need to find
the skills to allow us to do it without
burning out. So in reality, we are the
bottleneck.
And the the cool thing here is that
while we are the bottleneck,
the skills that we need to do these
things to uh find ourselves not burning
out every time we use an agent are with
us all along. uh if you try and compare
it to other stuff that you've been doing
outside of programming, for example,
playing video games, it's not really
that different. Like if if you're
playing Warcraft, for example, or Sims,
and you have a bunch of different uh
units running around, you need to
understand what they're doing and
supervise all of it. How different is
that from from actually inspecting
agents?
So I took this concept uh too far and I
created Agentcraft uh which is a game
inspired orchestrator uh that tries to
bring all that good stuff together into
work.
So let's take uh a quick look of what
that actually looks like and try and
understand the journey that we can go
through to really raise the ceiling of
how humans and agents can collaborate.
So uh this is a craft. Uh there's really
a lot to unpack here. Uh so we'll just
go through the basics really quick. Um
what you see here is an agent. Uh it's
an actual representation of a cloud code
or open claw whatever agent that you can
imagine. Uh it can be detected in your
device or you can actually spawn new
ones directly from Asiancraft. Uh so
like I said you have like codecs and uh
open code etc.
at your command.
>> Uh, and these agents can do everything.
They're just normal agents. Uh, so I can
just prompt them in this nice side panel
that also has voice. So there's
multimodality here. Uh, and just do
something for me.
>> Prompt prompt.
>> And now these agents can do whatever.
Uh, and if you look around you would see
that the map has a bunch of different
elements. So you have buildings. These
buildings represent functionalities. So
for example uh if you can manage your
plugins or skills uh you have like
integrated terminal integrated git uh
you can do in your all of your work from
within this space.
So now that we have this and we
understand the basics let's look at what
we can do uh to raise the ceiling. So
the first step is obviously visibility.
I need to understand what's going on.
What are my agents doing? So, I have
this nice side panel and it shows me the
different agents and what their task is
and what the last thing they did is and
what they're currently doing. Everything
I need to quickly understand who needs
my attention and who doesn't. The second
part of it is we're not just limited to
this. You have a map. So, I can take
let's say my file system, project it
onto the map and now I can see exactly
what my agents are doing. Not just by
looking at a list of stuff. I can
actually see, okay, this agent is now
working on this directory or this file.
And these files are represented as runes
on the map. So I can really look at each
one and see exactly what each agent did
and when. And now I can take this nice
information because we are the
orchestrator uh and use that to create
linkages. And now I can create cool
stuff like heat maps. So I can really
easily see what's going on. And the the
the other aspect is that now that we
have this visibility, that's not really
enough. We need to be able to react to
what's going on. If someone needs my
attention, I need to be able to quickly
jump to it. So much like video games or
RTS games or Civilization, whatever, you
would click uh spacebar and it would
just take you to the nearest thing that
actually needed your attention. So you
can really easily understand what's
going on and jump from one thing to the
other and answer questions or approve
plans etc.
That was nice. I mean it's a nice step
just to have that visibility but it's
not really enough. It's pretty
exhausting to keep looking at what the
agents are doing in the granularity of
what files are they using and what tools
are they using at the moment. So we need
something else. Uh and the reason is
that we have like two two main problems
here. Uh one is that there's just too
much to hold in our heads. Even if I can
understand what's going on and I can see
everything, I can't really do like 20
things at the same time. I can't even
think of the next thing I want to do if
I have this huge coding project or
whatever. So I need to find some way to
fix that. Uh so we can I mean we can
tell the agents uh you know go through
my codebase, find out what the next
things I need to do are, create these
tasks for me and I just click a button,
I accept the quest and there's some
agent that does it for me which is fun.
Uh it's cool. Uh but the next problem
here is that okay now I have 20 stuff
going at the same time and I have to
babysit each and every one and that is
completely exhausting. So you could ask
okay we have agents agents are amazing
as we've established
so I can just go ahead and tell the
agent to do it for me now it's called
software factories but at the time it
was just doing stuff autonomously uh so
you can give it like a general sense of
what you want it would spawn an
orchestrator and break it down for you
and run it all in well in this case it's
a local uh container so everything is
just done in isolation and I don't need
to do any babysitting the agent does it
for me. On top of that, you have loops,
which everyone really likes right now.
So, you can do cool things like just
tell it to, I don't know, scan Twitter
for cool stuff you want to build or scan
your GitHub and it will just create
these nice uh features for you in the
background without you needing to do too
much up front.
The bad thing is that I mean this is
nice uh but what do I do when I have
again I don't know I would say 20 but
even five things to review at the same
time it's very very hard to get that out
of the way. So what I did is create uh
this like review kit. So I get the
entire changes I need and I get uh what
files changed if you want to go like
file by file or you can get just get
visual evidence so you can actually see
videos of what changed or photos of what
changed so you can really quickly
understand what you want or even run a
few uh instances in parallel and just
pick the best implementation out of
these.
So now that we have this, we have uh
visibility and we have autonomy. Uh it's
pretty cool. Like we reached a pretty
good place in raising the ceiling of
what we can do with agents, but it's
still pretty exhausting. I mean, it's it
was fun. Uh but now I have to ask
myself, do I really need to be the only
one doing this? It's pretty lonely to
just talk to agents all day and trying
to and you know if you look at uh what a
team does for example if it's just me
that's fine but if I have a team I might
not even be the right person to review
what's going on. So I need something
else. Uh and that something is
collaboration. We can just have other
people join us. So the way that looks in
agent craft is that I can create these
uh you can call it you know war halls
war room whatever uh host them it's like
completely local but you can do like uh
tunnels and people can join you so I can
create a room and let's say I have a
product designer in my team in this case
uh it's my wife and I can approve uh her
otherwise she'll be mad uh so I can
approve her and she does her thing she
designs whatever and I as an engineer
here can not only see that that's that's
her. Um I can not only see that on my
map uh I can actually take that and
follow off off of it.
>> Prompt prompt.
>> Yeah, that's just like her. Um so I can
take that design, follow up on it,
implement it while she keeps working.
Uh, and the cool thing here is that not
only can I hand off or fork and kind of
have this shared workspace. So I'm not
really bound anymore to get. I can use
Git, but I'm not really bound to
something. Everyone is working together.
Uh, you can see that there's also some
kind of chat between not only between uh
the people within the room, but also
between agents. So we can have this
really nice notice board of exactly what
each person is doing, what each agent
doing. they're all aware of each other
and they can collaborate much more
closely uh than you normally would be
able to do. Uh so for example here I can
say okay I took off this design task.
Uh so now we have oh by the way this is
also from devices you can have like
mobile and and if you like telegram you
can use telegram whatever floats your
boat. So we have visibility and we have
autonomy and we have collaboration. So
we managed to raise the ceiling. uh it's
now possible especially if you're power
users to do really cool stuff and use
more agents and do more things. But the
interesting thing here was you know if I
looked at the feedback I got it's not
just that power users were able to do
more. The cooler thing for me was that
people that had even nothing to do with
agents or nothing to do with
productivity, uh, come and say, uh,
okay, my kids really loved it and they
use it all the time to to orchestrate
agents, which they didn't do until now.
Uh, or you know, someone that flunked
out of college because they play
Starcraft and now they can suddenly do
really productive stuff with it. uh and
a bunch of other examples of kind of
bringing communities that so far were
kind of behind into this new world of
productivity.
So we need to raise the ceiling but we
also need to uh lower the floor. We need
to have some kind of way to take no
probably around 90% of the people in the
world and bring them into this hygienic
future without having them burn out.
So again I took it too far. Um and
there's this uh currently named TBD um
potentially loopers. Uh the idea here is
okay why don't why do we need something
like you know Warcraft which is
potentially very complicated uh
especially or might be even daunting if
you're not into the granularity of what
files are there are or how uh complex
the UI is and kind of try to find a
lower denominator of what makes stuff
accessible especially now that agents
are much more capable. So instead of
granularity or having like exactly what
files they're working on, maybe I can
have it more of a mobile game level, uh
have projects that I keep returning to
and use loops and other stuff that rely
on agents being more autonomous to have
like a very basic level of I prompt, I
get the result. I don't really care
perhaps about the way I can see it if I
want to and I have this really nice
interactive and cool experience that
makes me want to come back to this. And
obviously I mean this is one
visualization uh it can really resonate
with some people but might not might not
resonate with others because we're not
all the same and what may appear like
amazing and easy to one person can
appear very difficult to another. Uh but
here uh I'm trying to look at a way to
make this more customizable. Try and
understand what it is that you as a
person need in order to understand and
want to use these tools. So this is a
very very early draft. Um but if you
want to use it, please let me know. So
we're the bottleneck. I think we've
established that uh pretty well until
now. But the skills that we need to stop
being the bottleneck and enable this new
future are already with us. So we are
the bottleneck but we don't have to be.
And I hope that you all can take what's
relevant to you in your life and apply
it forward.
So I would ask you for two things. One,
agent is already out there. Like you can
just npx install agent as a website uh
and do your thing. Uh this new thing
that I just showed you uh potentially
loopers uh is still experimental. I'm
still trying to understand the interest
and what people are actually looking for
to uh get the floor that they want or
the ceiling that they want. So please uh
go here and express your interest and
tell me what you're looking for so I can
know what to do with this. And thank
you.
and co-ounder of styling search and
today my top user signals die at
retrieval boundary. So we'll look into
uh what are agents essentially why agent
fails what is uh the cause of fails in
retrieval particularly and how to make
actually signal cross the retrieval
boundary and how to make your agent
basically outcome fair.
So uh let's get started. What is an
agent? An agent is an LLM that has
agency to reason, invoke tools, uh
interact with the real world, retrieve
uh the memory to complete the task. One
major loop here is missing is uh
learning. It should also learn from what
worked and what it didn't work. Suppose
uh if I have to uh
explain what is agent, I can explain
with react agent. So if I have to
explain uh what agent is, I'll explain
it with react agent. So basically user
prompt the agent uh and execute it in a
loop uh kind to a retriever search and
then pause when the task is complete.
This is very basic react architecture.
One thing that is missing is how to make
agent learn from the outcome.
So Asian keeps failing at the same task
got reported 85% of AI just fail.
So it's in McKenzie's 2025 report. The
problem came out to be most of the time
is that retrieval is static. 73% of uh
our app pipeline fails because of
retrieval not generation and context
stuffing. So a recent uh uh post from
Ram Shria the execto of Pine cone said
uh we have been optimizing for the wrong
thing. You are paying a lot for your
agent's memory. It is probably broken
and we have been optimizing for the
wrong things. We made wrong answers
appear faster and cheaper but we forgot
to make retrieval learn. So why this is
does does it matter?
Again uh the third column is agents are
not outcoming for.
So there's a missing layer between evals
and action. Your obsibility has all the
traces or all the stack that capture.
Observility is the stack that capture
every tool call every LM completion
every exceptions. Your EVA suite judges
whether the final output was correct or
wrong. Basically pass or fail. But these
evils are not reflected in agent uh
context, skills, MD files or agent
action in any ways.
Right?
So the agent doesn't has any access to
why yesterday's runs uh runs past or
fail. EVA signal dies in the dashboard.
This is a missing layer. a system that
consume traces, absorb eval and convert
both into retrieval guidance for future
runs.
So there's a manual improvement tax and
engineer actually has to sit and see if
the email and obserility perform well,
rewrite the prompt, redeploy it, upgrade
either upgrade to expensive model,
restructure to or harness or fine tune
the custom models.
Why are current memories failing? why
memories was designed to actually
address this but uh uh it's not.
So let's see uh what we have in as a
current system uh and current memory is
that they basically store user
preferences, profile, conversational
history or long lived personal
personalization.
So chart experience is not
self-improving learning systems for
production. If you see uh the already
existing approach in the uh market
there's a uh lang chain uh there's me
zero which does extracted f references
it uses retrieval signal is embedding
similarity
does it learn from our code? No. Uh so
we have come up with something called
utility score which is a similarity
weighted by how useful it is for the
agent to execute the task. It has
actually the history of past precess and
past outcomes.
So we came up with agent RX and that is
agents with runtime experience. It's a
runtime layer that let production agent
improve from experiences without
pre-training, fine-tuning or manual
prompt training. Uh it's a bit different
from compile time like DSPI because uh
you bake in all the lessons in the
prompt. Here it's actually improving uh
while it is executing.
So this uh again introduces uh utility
score. So you do not retrieve by
keyword. You retrieve by semantic
similarity the current task weighted by
whether those memories have historically
helped or hurt the execution or the
outcome. The EI outcome becomes a first
class signal in the retrieval reanking
and not just
one of the key things is it treat memory
as reasoning not as facts static fact
with no context and no history but
reasoning like suppose uh if uh if
there's a if there is a customer support
B looking for refund it will not say hey
user prefers uh uh dark theme or user
prefers uh to be called by a shorter
name. It's actually a reason about the
query like uh if some someone asks for
refund you should check the settlement
before refunding it so that the the the
customer doesn't get paid uh refund
twice. So rank based on usefulness
context is updated based on task. So
this is a very big thing uh because most
of the agents fail with context stuffing
and this has been brought up in the past
and learned from history and reasoning
right talking about benchmarks.
So uh we have benchmarked uh our memory
system reflect with on tow bench which
essentially measure if agents have
followed the policy well or not. So we
have seen uh the uh uh the performance
improve from 66 to 76% without baking in
uh skills and with skills uh reflect
performance at 80. So um once there are
uh enough memory like 10 uh memories uh
what we do is we bake in the uh
reasoning and the understanding into
skills so that your agent always remains
updated. What happens most of the time
we have seen suppose you have a product
SQL agent and there's a system there's a
column in system prompt even though that
column is not useful anymore it remains
in the system prompt so there's no
system right now that can update that
hey there's no column uh right now
called this so maybe probably you
shouldn't entertain it in the future and
this is possible with skills that uh
because agents always uses uh calls that
skill uh updated skill all the time and
the similar behavior has been seen in
GPT 5.4. Uh we have also benchmarked it
on agentic task which essentially test a
model's ability to reason, plan and use
tools over extended multi-step workflows
rather than measuring a static Q&A. So
you can see here uh with the suppose the
human last exam uh with rag you get 47.5
if it is starting from the baseline 35.7
uh with the memory system it gets to
58.2 but with the ref memory system uh
it gets to 61.3%.
So this uh this kind of trend is shown
in another uh agentic benchmarks uh as
well like big code bench like long TV
etc.
Okay. Hello. Okay. Before I get started
you guys this is a huge keynote room.
Can everyone like come forward because
I'm talking to like four empty rows and
disperse people. Do me a favor. I'm
spending 30 minutes telling you all of
our secrets. I can see you still. Thank
you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
We're just going to chat. It's a giant
room and there's 500 of us. This room is
way larger than that. Thank you.
Honestly, I knew you guys had it in you.
It's really not so hard. Thank you. I
also sit in the back. I also work during
talks. I get it. I totally get it. I did
all day, but not for me. Okay, I'm gonna
start, but I'm gonna still point at you
if you're in the back like you. Okay,
I'm Sarah. I'm uh lead our engineering
teams for AI at Notion. Um, welcome to
my talk. Um, it's about token town. How
do you go from not go from AI pled to AI
poor? Okay. Um, I know that today is all
about software factories. We're going to
talk about that, but we're going to talk
about how to do it sustainably.
This is me. This is on my first day at
Notion in a very sweaty subway. Um, like
I said, I lead our AI teams at Notion.
Um, and I negotiate AI contracts for a
living. My team jokes I act like Anna
Winter. So, this is a nice a nice image
of me with AI Anna Winter hair after a
press article referred to me that
externally. Um, and that's kind of the
idea, right? Uh, how do you think about
negotiating between different vendors?
um making sure that you maintain taste
for your company. I don't do it alone.
Um this is launch day of one of our
recent launches. This is just a subset.
Any good engineering manager points out
that we have a whole company of people
building this. I'm just the one that
gets to come talk to you about it. So,
we've been building a lot. Um this is um
an example of our AI usage um just in
2026. Um, and we've been really proud of
how we've been able to grow that usage.
And I'm going to talk to you about how
you can build an AI native product and
an AI native company. Um, but this is
just to give me some credit that that
we're doing it kind of well. Okay. So,
for those of you that don't know,
notion's always been that durable system
of record. It's always been the place
where you can collaborate with your
peers. Um, but today that point of
collaboration is a little bit different.
It's not just humans. Notion's always
been the place for collaboration. And
today that collaboration happens between
humans and agents, humans and humans,
agents and agents.
And we like to think about AI
transformations going through this
journey. And I'm sure some of you are
looking at the slide and wondering where
you are. AI as a thought partner is when
we all started tinkering. We all started
just going to the very first version of
Chat PT on Thanksgiving when it came out
three years ago, four years ago and we
started saying like
how can I send this email to my landlord
to say that I shouldn't pay for
repainting, right? Then we'd copy paste
it, enter it into our email. Eventually
we started getting to a place where we
could use AI like an assistant. AI was
able to maybe execute individual tasks.
That's how notion AI really took off in
the beginning. um and it was able to
save employee time but functionally was
limited in its capabilities based on
what humans asked it to do. AI as
teammates is what we were really excited
to launch almost a year ago now. Um but
this is true in many products. We can do
repetitive work and think about a
process and have AI do that process.
What I think is really interesting is
when AI actually becomes that critical
workflow where processes are interfacing
with each other and you have entire
systems running. How many of you guys
feel like you have AI as a system down?
Aren't you sad you came up now? Great.
None of you. Exactly. We have found that
no one has figured out how to do this.
Well, 88% of people can't even get past
AI as an assistant. And why is that? We
have a thesis that notion. It's because
there's too much silo data and not a
sturable system of record for that point
of collaboration. And we believe that
for your software factory to work, for
your company to work, and for your
systems to work, you need that durable
system of record. And that is notion's
mission.
So doing that is expensive. Um, you see
a lot of companies that try and commit
themselves to this vision, and these are
just a series of headlines all within a
week of how that's painful. So you can
put all of your money into a process to
try and make a system, and you end up
feeling like this.
Right? You end up using a blowtorrch to
light what is actually a large cigar.
But you kind of get the idea.
Cost is a structural barrier to entry.
It makes it hard for you to serve
products. It makes it hard for you to
build factories. And it is ultimately, I
would posit, one of the largest reasons
why things do not happen at scale
successfully today. And I would argue
for anyone working in an applied AI
company, it's something for them to be
really familiar with to understand the
trade-offs that they're making to build
durable and exciting and enlightening
product for their customers.
But that's not really how the market is
today, right? I'm not going to name
names here, but you guys have search
engines. You can figure it out. Exhibit
A. A reasoning model gets upgraded.
Amazing. The per token pricing is the
same. What's not to love? You try it
out. It uses three times as many output
tokens. Right? Exhibit B, a model gets
upgraded, but it has an entire new
digit, right? Whatever marcation system
that model family likes, it's brand new.
It's 40% more than its predecessor,
which is being deprecated in the next
four months. These are real scenarios
that we faced at notion. All of you are
nodding because these are common pretty
much monthly now. But here's the
problem. Are you growing 40% in that
time period? Are you making 30 3x more
revenue? No. So, how do you navigate the
system? If you just auto upgrade your
model and everything that you're doing,
you're you're giving someone a bad deal.
Either your customers or your investors
depending on how you charge and where
you get your money. Neither are good.
Fortune 5 million companies have the
capability to navigate this. They can
hire large consulting teams, have
durable teams on their own, and build
expertise on how to navigate these
trade-offs.
Um, most people don't. Everyone else has
no ability to negotiate with leverage,
and they're stuck in these scenarios.
Right? Part of my job, as that Anna
Winter joke, is to think about
advocating for the Fortune 5 million,
the non-fortune 500 companies that don't
have the mass to have leverage and
negotiate, but need to think about how.
and I'm going to share some of the
lessons that I've learned when I have
kind of large amounts of traffic behind
me that I think scale to those who
don't.
Um, this is probably less of a secret
now than it was when I started giving
talks like this maybe four months ago.
Um, your supplier is your competitor. I
know very few people who have convinced
me that that's not true.
um you will always be getting a bad deal
on tokens with someone who builds them
natively, right? Sometimes the cost of
goods served is extremely different.
You're basically they're serving a
first-party product and then you're
buying those tokens at a huge search
charge and then selling them again at
another search charge. Um that's not
really value you can defend. You're
getting a really bad deal. And if you
tie yourself to one provider, you have
no exit. If you build an AI product that
you're selling with this structure, you
are crossing your fingers and hoping
that you are a viable business. I do not
encourage that.
This is really interesting. Dylan in
semi analysis posted this. I think it's
it says eight hours ago. It wasn't at
this point. It was probably a month ago.
um they purchased a subscription plan
and they just highlighted right how
different what Frontier Labs charge
customers for first-party products are
versus what they sell. It's a bad deal.
Don't play this game or try and let me
know how you win. I don't recommend.
Think about everyone else. Think about
what that structure means and where you
have expertise.
I don't think that that's winning on the
token economics. I think it's about
product. It's about building data
flywheels and understanding your
customers better than anyone else.
Understanding when you need capability,
when you need low price, when you need
latency improvements. I promise you, you
don't always need what is usually the
slowest but the most capable model out
there. And then build compelling UI and
orchestration. And I'll show you some
examples of that to justify the cost on
the bad deal tokens that you do resell.
The job is not to train. I mean, some of
you might be training the best model and
I'd love to serve it and come talk to me
afterwards, but most of you are not
doing that. Stop trying to win that game
and think about the best product that
uses many models. Help your customers,
help your team. Bet on the frontier, not
on the lab. And we'll talk about what it
looks like to do that.
This cost per capability per second
trade-off is actually really intense.
Um, Citadel came out with this memo um,
a while ago, maybe two weeks ago. I
loved it. The idea is that for the
economy at large, simpler models might
be the most cost-effective productivity
augmenting pathway. They talk about this
bifurcation on frontier versus everyday
usage. I really believe that. And for
every product, the definition of
frontier versus everyday, the definition
of saturated capabilities or model
capability overhangs depends on your
expertise on your product. No one can
replace that.
And not all traffic is equal. It is a
huge miss to send all of these to the
latest opus model. Some of these
absolutely large scale data analysis
when you do it on notion will recommend
Opus, right? When you triage an email
inbox, if we're charging you to do that
on Opus, we're ripping you off and
ourselves.
Think about where your traffic patterns
are.
And then think about how Frontier Lab
model providers are structured today. I
mean, it's functionally an oligopoly,
right? And that's fine because they're
racing to the top. And I think the top
is really hard and really important.
This is not to say that products don't
have a place for frontier difficult
tasks. I want everyone to nod and
understand that's not what this talk is
about. Understand when you need those
tasks and it's not everything. The
problem with those tasks are is keep in
mind how pricing is incentivized. You
can figure out who these players are.
Either you are the best model.
Everything above what AI can't do today
is your market. You can basically price
it as high as you kind of want. If
you're slightly behind that best model,
all you need to be is like a dollar per
million tokens cheaper and you have the
rest of the market. You know that
economic theory about gas stations where
the best gas stations are the ones that
are right next to each other because
they cover east and west the most. Yeah.
It's the same with model pricing, which
means that price does not correlate with
capability growth.
So for this complex task, understand
what capabilities you need, but be the
expert on what complexity is.
And keep in mind that who handles
complexity changes. Um, oftentimes
you'll see applied AI companies really
be super outspoken on marketing with a
specific lab. That's always kind of a
red flag for me when they're not model
agnostic because if you look at this
graph, it basically shows that they're
behind every month, right? the new model
and the new model provider of the best
Frontier capabilities change and if you
hit your ride with one particular
provider in exchange for for instance a
larger discount
um you're doing a disservice to your
customers like half of the time, right?
So really think about if that discount
is worth not having a Frontier product
and remember that that optionality is
your leverage.
If you don't have the capability to walk
at any point, you are stuck. And again,
I think that's probably the most
expensive decision you'll make
regardless of what discount you get or
the engineering work to have model
interoperability.
One option to navigate this is stay
model agnostic.
Have different models and capabilities
in your system so that at any point if
pricing seems unfair or untenable, you
are not out of business.
Notion's auto model does this really
well. We have state-of-the-art models
available always. Um, but we also have
an auto model there at the top that
handles about 75% of our traffic. Right?
We have the ability to switch between
models in our product and we also offer
it to our customers so that they have
access to these models without vendor
lockin. That's part of our AI
Switzerland approach.
You guys love taking photos of slides.
This is the slide. Okay,
model agnostic playbook. This is how you
do it. Build for multimodal. It is hard
to kill the cache and switch models
mid-transcript. I understand that we
invest in that technology. It doesn't
even have to be per thread. Just think
about your harness as model
interoperability.
Think about the cost per capability per
second, not just the tokens. Here's a
great example. We posted this review
when we um announced our partnership
with Parallel as our web search
provider. If you were to look at just
latency of a single call or just cost,
parallel might not be the cheapest. But
if you have expertise in entire web
search trajectories, you'll see how it
differs. The granularity of this eval is
what lets us make the best decisions for
our customers because we understand all
of the trade-offs on entire
trajectories, not just single calls.
Switch fast and often. I think we talked
about that. And give them something
back. That expertise on use cases is
also very valuable to Frontier Labs. We
find that our evals and our early access
program partnerships actually help us a
lot with Frontier Labs and is something
that we can exchange instead of
extraordinarily large commits and I
don't think the discount is ever worth
the lost in optionality. That's a
perspective you can choose to keep or
not. The second option is moderate tasks
understanding open weights place there.
um openweight models are really strong
enough to handle these tasks and the
possibility to RL on top of them has
also kind of expanded the up market
growth that they can cover. I view openw
weight models as basically lowering the
barrier to entry on cost for our
customers and they also give you
negotiation leverage. So it's kind of a
credible alternative that's putting that
downward pressure on pricing that if
there's an igopoly of two or three
providers at the top is unavailable
right now otherwise.
I think Kimmy 26 was probably the first
time that we really saw a model that
outperformed 52, GPT52, GLM 52 now is
another 52 bombshell in the villa that
also probably does best here. But it's
no longer the case where open weight
models are good for just SFT on small
tasks. Really think about without RL if
they're capable enough for what you
need.
Um, and again, don't just think about
external benchmarks. Be able to have
expertise on your system. What are your
tool errors? What's the actual latency
that you need? Right? Here's an example
of a benchmark that we posted. It's a
little bit stale on purpose, right? But
you get the idea.
Philip at Base 10 this showed this slide
once and I've stolen it ever since. Um,
thank you. Are you here, buddy? Okay.
Well, chat, hi. Um, well, he could come
up and say it better, but the idea is
that you don't have to be at the top,
right? I'm not trying to make a case
that open weight is the best model out
there. Um, the case being made, however,
is that um, the gap gets covered
eventually. So, if the tasks that you're
having today are good enough, then in
six months, they're probably covered by
open weight. So, be prepared now.
And the last thing is CPUs over GPUs.
Um, we've we've recently launched
something at notion called workers. I
don't think that the GPU is necessary
for every job.
A lot of the jobs that we have are
actually serving um discrete pieces of
code. Like you don't need an LLM to turn
a CSV into a PDF. You don't need an LLM
to talk to notion tool calls if we have
a CLI. You definitely don't need an LLM
to do deterministic SQL queries. This is
where people become token poor very
quick.
And I think the last option here besides
open weight CPUs and optionality is
actually governance. Um there's a lot of
AI governance. Um one is visibility. Um
understanding who's using the data,
understanding its maintainability and
control. When you have model
optionality, you can offer a lot more to
your customers.
Um here's an example of how that
governance works in notion.
So final tips again, think about
architecture, think about open weight,
and build value that transcends tokens.
So we're going to depart Token Town. I
know I said welcome to Token Town. We're
going to spend the next 10 minutes
really thinking about what to do next.
So I think the challenge of the next six
months doesn't have to do with
capabilities. I think it has to do with
security. Let's start there. There's
this concept called the lethal trifecta.
Simon Wilson, I think, crafted this. If
you have access to private data,
exposure to untrusted content, whether
it be through ingestion, MCP, email,
right? And the ability to ex to
communicate externally, and that can
include like payloads in a web search.
The second you have that system, you're
exposing risk. And in fact, the more
autonomous your system is, the more
unsupervised this risk is. I think that
this is what builds valuable product,
not just capability.
Same with sandboxes and computers. We
talked about this, but it really is
something that builds better determinism
in your product and also better token
economics for your customers
in multi-agent orchestration.
Understanding what agents see and do and
what persists. I think persistence of
enterprise knowledge is something that's
actually really not discussed enough.
It's starting to be with some recent
launches,
you know. Oh, there is audio. So don't
have your workflows look like this. And
I think this is where most software
factories are today, right? It's like
actually your entire engineering time
just spends time babysitting the
factory, right? I mean, I get it. Ours
started off like this. Agent
orchestration is one of the most
difficult tasks of making factories
work.
So okay, this is me telling T pay to
tell people to buy notion AI. And the
reason I included this slide is that I'm
going to sell notion for a second. It's
my job. Always be closing. Always be
selling. Always be hiring. come find me.
But I'm going to talk for a second about
how Notion does this
today. We already have the ability to
inspect tasks.
And you can imagine any task that you
look at um in a notion document, you can
have Claude actually go ahead and scope
out what you need. We've launched this
manage agent capability today. So if I
go ahead to the top of this task, I can
actually ask Claude agent to scope out
the task, right?
Ideally, it's working.
Um, and you'll see it'll actually
populate um an entire spec of what needs
to be done. In this example, it's not
ready. It's going to ask me a question.
Keep in mind, this isn't a markdown
file. This is an active document. Um,
let's say I don't actually know the
question and I go ahead and I ask my
team um what to do. Imagine that you can
kind of tag in your team into these
systems.
MJS are PM
So in this example, she doesn't know.
Usually she does, but multi-agent
orchestration is important. Maybe Claude
Code isn't the best at customer voice,
but Decagon is, right?
You can ask DecaGon agents, we're proud
partners with them as well, to collect
the right data that you need. Okay, in
this example, we think we know enough.
We're going to go ahead and actually um
iterate through some of this flow. I'm
going to skip ahead a little bit. We
asked our TL what we needed. He replied
again. It's a collaborative file, not
just a markdown. And we can have Claude
actually go ahead and spin up the PR.
Hopefully, this is looking a little
familiar now. This is kind of the vision
of software factories. It's what we're
trying to host. Okay, Claude put up a
PR. Maybe that's not enough. Um maybe I
want to go ahead and ask Codeex what it
thinks.
Great. Found two issues.
You can think about this scaling in an
actual factory. So today in notion,
you're actually able to orchestrate
these agents together and you're not
committing to a lab. You're committing
to the concept that AI is augmenting and
automating what you do.
This is real. I asked Rejieve if I could
post this. This is how it works today
internally at notion. Almost all of our
polish and large feedback like this is
actually coordinated um through our
software factories both in terms of
writing to the right teams and also
having coding agents take the first
step. Versel does this as well from
staging to shipping to closing.
And we see massive ROI gains from our
customers.
That's over three minutes saved on a
given task. Imagine that at scale. So I
think we're trying our hardest to think
about the factory lens. We cannot do
this without optionality. And we cannot
do this without conviction that we
understand what models are required for
which tasks.
It's really wild out there you guys. I
get it. The market is really young. It's
exceptionally opaque. It's moving fast.
I'm super grateful for communities like
AI engineer to bring us together and
like talk openly about these things and
how we navigate it. Um I think we owe it
to all of our customers to get it right
and to be critical thinkers about how we
navigate this together. I'm chronically
online fortunately. Um you can always DM
me on Twitter, you can email me, you can
find me after this. Um but thank you for
yapping with me and thinking about this
problem and have a good day.
is for uh it's just got so much in
there. It really helps write better code
and structure your code better and uh
helps with architecture, spinning up new
services for uh and and for us on the
agents team really helping uh design and
build the the core agent loop. So you'll
see throughout this presentation
sprinkled in um how effect on our team
uh has paid off in dividends. So we we
really love effect here at open gov and
we encourage other folks to try it out
and um yeah let's keep going
the effect native loop. So originally we
were on lang graph and that was fine
until the team really started to scale
uh and our use cases started to evolve.
So we decided to move over to our own
kind of effect native agent loop to have
full regency over this uh agent loop
such that if we have complex use cases
or features that we need to build, we
could kind of get in we we had full
control of the of the agent loop. And
not only that, but now we're fully on
effect. So all the cool things you get
with effect is now propagated throughout
the entire agent loop like the tracing
structure currency, the logging,
everything is more fine grading control
and it it really allows us to really
unlock the full potential uh having our
own agent loop from the ground up. Um so
another thing I wanted to mention is on
the left side you'll see a code example.
This is really the basics of the effect
loop that we're using. Uh we're using
this thing called the effect AI package.
And in that package, there's this thing
called um there's a chat and a language
model. So with the chat, you can
instantiate like an a chat for example.
And then you could stream text using um
that that kind of stream text function.
You could pass in a prompt. And what's
cool is uh with a language model under
the hood of since we're kind of doing
dependency injection, we could pass in a
different language model if we were to
uh hot swap to another one for example.
So really just having full control of
our own agent loop just kind of gives us
all the levers and it really just
unlocks the full capabilities of the
model and uh for the team as well to
have full agency over this this loop.
Another thing I wanted to mention is the
agentto agent protocol. So here on the
agents team, we've had a lot of success
with this protocol. So this protocol
being the protocol that Google created
um kind of an open protocol for agents
to intercommunicate. But um we found
this very useful for uh defining our
agent routes for example in the back end
and our model and our schema to follow
this kind of uh agent protocol. So we
modeled so for example there's this
thing called an agent card which you see
here and it's got the name of the agent
a description etc right and having this
kind of rigorous protocol this rigorous
spec really helped drive our development
and drive alignment because you know all
we had to do was um align with this spec
and follow this spec and we knew that
this was kind of the contract that our
front end and backend and would both
consume and and produce. So, um this uh
I would say also has been uh very
helpful for us and and what's really
cool is A2A has a lot of extensions,
right? So, you could extend the protocol
uh add in like metadata. Uh there's also
A2UI.
Um so, lots of fun stuff uh with A2A
protocol, but uh this is kind of what's
worked for us. So just sharing that with
with you folks
feedback and eval. So here the quote is
shipping is the start not the finish. So
what we do here uh on the agency team is
we have kind of multiple ways we do
evals and collect feedback. Um obviously
you know we'll have folks uh call in or
or email us or or just let us know and
tell us but the main way is we have this
thumbs up and thumbs down mechanism. And
here uh someone is able to tell us, hey,
this this worked really well. This was a
great response or that wasn't a great
response. And that signal we take and
we're able to iterate on uh and we could
take it back and help improve uh you
know the response in the future. Um we
also have automated evals. So in in the
in RCI we we have evals that run against
real completion. So we could test the
prompt against hey did it hit some
tools? Did it do what it's supposed to
do? And that also helps with our
accuracy. So, uh those automated evals
in conjunction with collecting feedback
really help us um improve our our our
tools, our skills, um our harness and
and that's really how we're able to
iterate so fast and so quickly.
Humans in the loop. So this is a really
cool feature we built where we
deterministically interrupt the agent
loop. If there is a tool call approval
required. So if an agent tries to make a
tool call that it needs human approval
for it'll show this UI and the human uh
can click accept or reject. So
explicitly rejecting or explicitly
accepting uh the action that the agent
is trying to make. And this ensures that
uh you know we're building trust and
also ensuring that uh you know we're
being safe especially when the agent is
trying to do a mutating operation and
always always always making sure that um
humans are in the driver's seat
sandboxing. So another thing that we uh
worked on um kind of similar to the
safety slide we just saw was um whenever
an agent tries to execute code or tries
to create files, it does so in a
sandbox. So we gave our agents sandboxes
such that it could spin up these
sandboxes on demand and it could use
those sandboxes to honestly write code,
execute code, create files and it's kind
of this safe ephemeral isolated space
such that the agent can can can take
action in there and not and we don't
have to worry about u any risk to you
know our our production systems. Um, and
it's it's really cool because they also
get uh tied uh teared down at the end.
So, um, in this example, I said, "Hey,
create a PDF uh for the folks of the AI
Engineer Conference 2026 and um, allow
me to download it so I can share it with
them." And you could see that the agent
created this
fighting slop with slop.
My name is Vibb and I'm going to talk
about something that is a little I would
say maybe a little silly at first. I'm
going to show you our team's engineering
practices really quickly. We do no code
reviews. We require every engineer to
work on things in parallel and we have
no standardization in how people do AI
and I know immediately what almost all
of you are thinking. We're probably a
Zoomer YC startup and I can guarantee
you I'm clearly a millennial. So what do
we actually do at our company without
code reviews? Well, we about three years
ago we decided to build a programming
language. That's something that has
absolutely no room for slop. is
something that has to work every single
time exactly the same way. It's
something that you can't just change a
year later or a month later because you
made a bad design decision. You have to
be correct. And for the last three
years, we've been in an onslaught of war
against slot.
And when I first met this enemy, I went
to my great mentor, Slop Sue, and he
taught me something. To to defeat the
slop, we must become the slop. So we
began and we prepared and then we
started winning. So when we think about
it, what is slop? Slop is just any code
you don't read. And whether any of you
admit it or not,
this is the least amount of slop that
your codebase will ever have. Cherish
it. So we started fighting back against
this slop and we started fighting back
with slop. So how do we go ship a stable
programming language with these
engineering practices? Well, the first
skirmish we ever had was a skirmish of
standards. The hard part about hiring
great engineers is you sadly can't tell
them what to do. Some of them want to
use clouds. Some of them want to use
codec. Some of them want want to use the
latest thing that they just found on
hackernews. So instead of trying to hold
standards in our codebase, we did
something that is an invariant. We built
an architecture.md file. Instead of
using cloudm just pick something that
every model can just understand. This
file has to be incredibly small and it
can only have things that will not
change for months or for years. In our
case, it's the layers of the compiler.
You go deeper into the compiler, tell
the agent to just talk to at least one
other person. That slows it down a
little bit. So now we have standards. So
anyone can use whatever they want. But
the real foe we faced was actually the
battle of design. Everyone here knows
that you have to write perfect design
docs. And we have a very simple rule in
our team. Code can be slop, writing
cannot. And of course, if I tell every
engineer this, they write beautiful
writing and they handw write everything.
They don't use AI. Well, sadly not. So,
we built a design tool, design doc tool.
What this design doc tool does, it's a
replacement for both notion and GitHub
effectively for design docs. It allows
versioning, commenting, all the stuff
you want. And obviously, we do this.
People use this. Well, sadly not. We
built another tool on top of that. And
this tool was a Slack integration for
that tool. Every time a design doc got
updated, this channel got notifications.
And what ended up happening is this
channel became the most popular channel
in our company really fast. At 2 am
someone shipped a new design doc. Three
people started reading it right away
because it's just interesting. The most
interesting stuff is design docs that
are not going to change. But this wasn't
enough. All of this is actually backed
by markdown files and simple CLI scripts
that make it treat like GitHub without
being GitHub itself. So now agents can
go do this. But the real problem with
all this is I built this and I hit a
little bit of AI psychosis and I started
shipping 10 design docs a day and soon
the team was fighting my slop. So we had
to go in at the last rule. This last
rule was if you're going to ship a
design doc you require people to
actually go read it. And with this last
standard we suddenly had design docs
that are incredibly high quality.
But what about the battle of
architecture? You how do you have your
codebase converge? We built another
tool. This tool basically visualizes our
dependency graph internally with some
external dependencies as well and allows
us to watch the codebase change. It has
semantic boundaries individual packages.
But what's more interesting is we can go
build CLI tools that guarantee that
certain invariants can't be broken. And
what this does is when Claude builds a
new package or adds a dependency that's
leaky, we now have CI/CD changing or or
a simple git commit history that tells
us exactly where things break. And by
this we're actually able to make our
architecture change. We haven't changed
our architecture in the last three or
four months.
But as much as we might do design docs
and as much as we might have stable
code, would you genuinely ship code
without reading it? Would you trust your
team to go do that? And think about a
programming language. A programming
language has so many invariants. You
have generics, you have closures, you
have memory allocation, you have FFI
boundaries. Could you trust that system?
Python has bugs 25 years later.
Well, here's where we did something
slightly different.
What we did was we built a system that
actually has agents constantly running
and creating BAML programs. We take
these BAML programs.
One second. And we have agents try and
spin something up from scratch. We then
look at the entire claw transcript, see
what tools it used, see what happened.
And obviously, we as humans can inspect
them. But more importantly, we can have
agents go inspect them. and agents find
what was good, what was bad, and not
just what was bad in terms of what was
incorrect in the language, but what took
three tool calls when it should have
only taken one. And then we can go ahead
and find issues. And we can have humans
collaborate with these issues to figure
out which ones are real, which ones are
hallucinations, which ones are don't
have taste, as much as I hate to use
that word. And then we can have agents
go ahead and create fixes to these
problems and go address them. And most
importantly, instead of trying to just
detect these issues, we can go one step
further. What if you could find language
features and instead of guessing what
was good, guessing what skill was good,
you could go and AB test it. You could
figure out which ones took less tool
calls, which one took uh which one made
less errors, which one produced the
correct outcome and deterministically
know what's going on. The point is you
can start building datadriven systems
without ever writing a single line of
code. And the thing that really I care
about the most over here is not that any
one of these tools is specifically what
you should go build, but the fact of the
matter is in order to build a
programming language, it wouldn't have
taken eight people. It wouldn't have
taken less than two years. It would have
taken hundreds and thousands and tens of
thousands of manh hours and then you
would still have a broken system. And
today we can just spend billions of
tokens and make it work and we can make
it stable. And you could you too can go
home and build these internal tools and
these sloppy tools to make sure that
your code bases can ship without really
having to read necessarily every single
line of code because your engineers
aren't going to.
And I think we can start winning this
battle against slop. And as we win this
battle, slop can be defeated. But sadly,
I have a sad thing to say. I think we're
still going to lose the war. I think the
reason that we're going to lose this war
is because some of the foundational
stuff that we try and go use itself is
broken. How many of you have used
TypeScript?
Probably most of you hopefully at this
point or at least your agents have. So
something around there. Um did you know
that TypeScript's main design goal is to
strike a balance between correctness and
productivity? And there's an asterisk
here because what they really mean is
human productivity.
And if you think about it, there are
things you would never do in a
programming language at the very core
layer if you were designing in a world
where humans never wrote a single line
of code. Let me show you what that
really means.
I'm going to write something and try and
guess what this code does.
Pretty safe.
What about this one?
or even more so this one. Why do we turn
things to strings when we sort them?
This is just slop baked into the
language whether you like it or not.
What about this? I love this part of
TypeScript. And you know what? My agent
loves this part of Typescript.
This is slop baked into the language.
And whether you like it or not, the
systems will have slop
if you build using these tools. Oh, I'm
sorry, wrong talk. But
if you think about what JavaScript does,
JavaScript exists and then after
JavaScript existed, we started building
systems to layer it on. We built
coffecript, then TypeScript, and now
we're trying to build effect. But thing
is the thing underneath is already
broken and more so the way we write code
is also different now. So why are we
trying to patch something like this? Why
don't we just try and do something a
little different? And I think what we
might need if we try and go do that is
basically going to be a madeup language.
So let me show you what BAML really can
do and when you start thinking from
first principles how you can try and
combat slop from a very foundational
layer itself. I keep talking about not
reading code. Does it even matter? Well,
let me show you a new way to think about
code. And this isn't to say we all have
to go do this right away. But what if
every single time I looked at code
Whoops.
What if every single time I looked at
code, what I really saw was not the code
itself, but a quick little thing that
could actually visualize all the code
for me.
As I clicked around, it took me to exact
lines of code that was linked to. If I
wanted to have a slightly broader view,
I could zoom in and click around and
have it expand, and I could navigate my
code bases more interestingly. I'm going
to let this run really quickly, but
while it runs, I'll show you a different
pipeline. Without any of you ever
reading the code, you know, I'm setting
up stuff and I have an agent loop
because the semantic boundaries in
there. I can expand this. I can keep
expanding this and I can say, "Nope,
that's too much slop. Let's let that be
slop and walk away." So, instead of
having to understand all the code, I can
opt into what parts of the code I want
to read and understand and go to the
exact lines when I really care about
them. But if we go back to the previous
pipeline that was running, what if while
it's running, I can actually get a full
execution trace in a world where we
don't read all the code, the only way to
understand the code is actually by the
execution trace and actually by seeing
exactly how much time was spent on what
parts of my program at any given time.
If you want to go and actually track
your program through, think about how
slow your program would be if you had to
go trace everything in Python or
Typescript. It's untenable.
And the best part here is if you start
from first principles, you can make this
effectively zero performance cost. Not
only can we make it great for humans,
but because it's all built for agents
anyway, you can go ahead and make it so
that every single file has a tracing
system that Claude can navigate through.
So Claude can find what were bugs, what
were errors, and what were
inefficiencies and start optimizing your
code without you having to do it
yourself.
And I think if we go start thinking
about it from this way, it's not so much
about reading all the code, but it's
more so about as a human understanding
the system that you're working with. And
the tools that you can build can give
you information about the system that
you're working with.
But
I think there's another layer to it.
We've spent decades building ID tooling
and that think about how long it took
before someone like me who does not know
how to escape Vim to this day can
finally start using VS Code. It was a
beautiful day when that happened. I
became a real programmer. Well,
according to some people, I'm still not
because I can't write Vim code. But what
does agent first tooling look like?
I think we're all familiar with GP. So
I'm not going to go and talk about it,
but I will talk about rip grep because
gp should not be used anywhere. If I
wanted to g through my codebase and
understand what it was, I would rip grap
say something like calculate and it
would give me a bunch of code where
everything was being used and maybe it
would be somewhat useful. But what if
you could instead just start describing
code and say, can you describe calculate
for me?
What if it came with all the dock
strings? What if it came with the actual
source code? And what if it also told
you everywhere it was actually used
under the hood? We can make something
that used to be multiple tool calls a
single tool call all of a sudden.
What if the way you wanted to learn
about libraries that you were using
instead of having to do a web search,
you just did
you just you could just ask for any
external library as well and it would
just give it to you. Because when I
first learn started learning how to
code, one valuable lesson I had was the
code is always a source of truth. Don't
read anything but the code itself. The
docs may lie. The um the actual
description or architecture file or read
me file will definitely lie, but the
code cannot lie except if you're working
on some weird architectures.
And then when you go down this road, you
go from not reading the code to
understand the architecture. You go from
not searching the code to understanding
exactly what you're getting in everyone
tool call. But what's the next thing you
do? Well, the last thing I do to truly
understand code is I run the code. So,
what if every single thing you ran,
every single function you ever wrote
was immediately available? And I'll pop
this code over here
was immediately available
as a simple CLI command. So, if I run
AD, add AD becomes a CLI command that
has A and B parameters attached to it.
And I can just run it really quickly and
see what happens. What if every single
CLI tool I had could be packed
into a li into a CLI that's completely
standalone
that I can just run without ever having
to actually execute any of the code
and is now a total CLI binary that has
function just bundled in. Suddenly we
can build really quick tooling where
agents don't have to go GP through
what's happening. Everything is type-
safe. Everything is deterministic and
everything is actually guessable. And
the best part is imagine you could build
on any system and your agents don't have
to worry about deployments across
Windows, Mac and Linux and you can just
target any layer you want and it builds
for any architecture including WASM
systems. All of a sudden as an engineer
you're supercharged. You're no longer
bottlenecked by what you can do in the
systems underneath you are preventing.
You can just move very fast. You can
move at agent speed.
But a lot of the stuff that I've been
talking about to this date has been
about tooling. What if we tried to fix
some of the real sins of JavaScript?
Some of the stuff that is deep in the
language. Not the sort stuff, but I mean
more important stuff like errors. Have
you seen error handling be beautiful
ever other than Rust? Um what I see
agents do over here is you do try catch
and then they keep nesting try catch
after try catch after try catch and
eventually they give up and say
console.log. some error happened and
deal with it. What if we could do error
handling from very first principles?
What happens in that world?
Well, I showed you add, multiply,
subtract. I didn't show you divide.
Divide is dangerous. It's spooky.
So, let's go look at divide. You can see
over here, divide throws a division by
zero error.
But what else happens? The function
actually knows that it throws division
by zero error without you having to
write any any code. If I go up to the
calculate function which at some point
calls divide,
this function also knows is throws
division by zero error. So error types
now get inferred without you ever having
to do any guess work. That means if you
catch or handle errors, we can do
exhaustive guarantees and the compiler
can prove that you have handled the
error or not handled the error. It's no
more guessing. There's no unknowns. It's
guaranteed to be proven. So if you
wanted to ship an API
where it guarantees that it never
throws, well, this system is broken
because it doesn't meet the constraints.
It has two errors that you're not
throwing. If you wanted to go catch
that, well, I can write the code for
that in a second, but you can start
catching certain errors.
Let me I'm just going to return a
sentinel value for now. And now this
parse thing which previously threw
division by zero error is now guaranteed
to no longer throw the division by zero
error because if I catch any exceptions
in here, I return a zero value every
single time. The compiler and the
tooling can do a lot of work for us. And
we're already used to this in our code
bases. We many of us probably don't know
how compilers work under the hood and we
trust them. code is a matter of trust.
The reason that we don't tr use LM code
blindly is because we don't trust it yet
because the systems underneath them
don't have enough rigidity.
One more thing, but before I tell you
all to go write a bunch of BAML code,
because I've been there and I can tell
you what someone would tell me if I
said, "Hey, use this new programming
language. It's going to solve all your
problems." It's just going to become
come with a whole slew of new problems.
So we said, I think we'll lose the war
on slop if we try to ask everyone to
rewrite all their code in the world into
this new system. So what does a solution
like that look like where you don't have
to rewrite all your code? Well, we what
we started to do was we started to think
about that about two years ago.
And we said, what if you could use BAML
not just standalone like I showed today,
but from within any existing language of
your choice from Python to TypeScript to
Rust to Go to Ruby to Java to anything
new that comes up even after it. What if
every function in BAML is immediately
accessible in the language of choice? So
in this case, I'm calling the BAML
calculate function directly from Python
and it's completely type safe. Not only
do we get calculate, we get calculate
async in case some of us want to write
async code. So BAML while it has no
function coloring, it does give you the
benefit of having to do whatever you
want across your code.
But what if you went a little bit
sillier?
What if you started passing around
lambdas
across language boundaries? I have a
function here called with timeout. this
function times out after a certain
number of milliseconds and if this work
doesn't complete and it's guaranteed to
no matter how long it takes well in that
world you can even pass Python lambdas
across the bridge you can pass generics
across the bridge you can pass closures
it should just work so engineers don't
have to go fuss with it and more
importantly so when the agent does
something the type system never lies the
type system becomes the absolute center
of truth that prevents invariance from
entering your codebase
And what I really wanted to talk about
today was not any one specific thing,
but it's this general concept. You can
build incredibly complex systems without
traditional systems like code reviews.
You don't you can work in things in
parallel and you can use AI however you
want without requiring any sort of
standardization. But the most important
part is you have to be incredibly
thoughtful about how your engineering
team actually uses the systems under the
hood. When we started building BAML, I
didn't think it would be possible to
build some of the software we did. And
just yesterday, one of our engineers
built a partial C compiler purely in
BAML. So when I start pushing the
boundaries of these systems and you stop
reading the code in some ways, in my
mind, it releases a floodgates for your
engineering team to actually cover the
gaps of what existed in your old
process. Have you ever worked at a
company that had no CI/CD? They said
adding CI/CD would slow us down. They
they do slow down for three months while
they add it, but after that they move a
lot faster. Our processes have to evolve
if we're going to ship at agent speed.
And remember, this is the least amount
of slop your codebase will ever have to
this date. So just embrace it and start
fighting it back. I fell in love with
software about 15 years ago and it was
the first thing that truly changed the
way I perceive the world. And I really
genuinely don't want SOP to win. And I
think we can all build a world of
beautiful software. I think what it
takes is I want each of you to go home
today and build these sloppy tools. Make
your systems more robust. Make your
processes more robust. And then for the
bravest of you, I want you to go back
and think about these core foundation
layer systems. Think about how they're
broken and see if you can imagine a way
to fix them. I think we do need a new
git. I think we do need a new database.
And yes, I think we need a new
programming language. I'm Vibov and I
work on Baml. Thank you
Shan Gupta and I'm a software engineing
tech lead at Meta working on building a
training and inference infrastructure
for the meta super tenis lab and their
infrastructure organization.
Today we're going to be talking about
production events for aentic systems.
When most people hear the word
valuation, they think about benchmarks.
A model scores 90% on a benchmark. A new
version scores 92%. A team celebrates.
But agent systems have fundamentally
changed what the evaluation means.
Today, the systems don't simply generate
answers. They plan, they call tools,
they retrieve information, they execute
workflows, they interact with the
production infrastructure. The question
is no longer did the model generate the
right answer. The question is did the
system behave correctly. Today I would
like to discuss how evaluation is
evolving from model benchmarking into
production infrastructure.
This is the problem almost every AI
organization is encountering today.
Offline benchmarks continue improving.
Yet production reliability often remains
unpredictable. Why is that? Because
benchmarks measure model capability.
Production measures system behavior. A
benchmark doesn't capture tool failure,
API outage, context changes, user
variability, longunning workflows. And
as systems become more autonomous, the
gap between the benchmark performance
and production performance grows. The
result is what many teams experience
today. High benchmark scores, as you can
see, but unreliable production behavior.
Traditional ALM evaluation focus on
outputs.
But we should ask the question did the
model produce a correct answer? Agentic
systems force us to ask a different
question. Did the system behave
correctly? Behavior includes planning
quality, tool usage, execution, workflow
execution, recovery from failures,
decision making. In other words, we are
moving from evaluating answers to
evaluating workflows. And that requires
fundamentally different evaluation
architectures.
Many teams still think hallucinations
are the primary AI failure modes. In
production, they are often just one
category. Agentic systems introduce an
entire hierarchy of failure modes. At
the very foundation, the memory
failures, retrieval failures, safety
failures. As you go up, you have to
think about reasoning mistakes, poor
planning, incorrect tool execution. At
the highest layer, you have to think
about multi- aent coordination failures.
And this is why evaluating only model
output misses the most production risk
we observe.
One of the most useful mindset shifts is
to stop thinking like researchers and
start thinking like a S sur or a
production engineer. SR don't measure
success using accuracy. They measure
reliability, availability, latency, cost
recovery and agentic systems require the
same approach. The goal is not
maximizing the benchmark scores. The
goal is to maximize dependable outcomes.
Reliability becomes the Nostra metric.
Accuracy becomes the only input.
In this pyramid is how I think
personally think about modern AI
evaluation systems. At the bottom you
can see their benchmarks. They're
useful. They're scalable. They're
reputable. But the operational value is
limited. In the middle there scenario
based valuations. These simulate
realistic workflows. And at the very top
you see production telemetry. This is
where the highest value evaluation
signals come from. The surprising
insight is that the most evaluation data
often comes from real users interacting
with real systems.
Now let's talk about offline. So offline
evaluations still matters but the
methodology changes. Instead of
evaluating prompts, we evaluate
scenarios. For example, a customer
support workflow, a code generation
workflow, a research workflow. The agent
operates inside that simulated
environment. We measure the task
completion rate, tool correctness,
planning quality, resource usage which
is which becomes exponentially high at
high scale. The key takeaway 18
evaluation should be scenario driven not
prompt driven.
Once a system reaches production, every
interaction becomes a signal. This is
one of the biggest shifts in evaluation
thinking. Production traffic is no
longer just traffic. It becomes
evaluation data. We collect execution
traces, user outcomes, escalations,
failures, feedback signals. Production
is the largest and the most
representative validation data any
organization will ever have.
Many organizations view humans as
fallback systems. I think that's a wrong
framing. Humans are the evaluators. They
provide signals that automated systems
cannot. They assess correctness, trust,
usefulness, safety. These signals become
really critical for calibrating
evaluation pipelines and identifying
blind spots in automated metrics. The
most successful systems combine
automated valuation with targeted human
review.
Now agent systems drift constantly.
Model changes. You have a new version
every couple of weeks or months. The
prompts can change. Tools can change.
User behavior can change.
Hey everybody, my name is Kyle. I'm
co-founder of a company called Human
Layer and I'm here to talk about loops.
I think we've all been building loops
lately and I realized recently I think
we're all doing it wrong. loops are
really powerful, don't get me wrong, but
so much of the discourse around them is
hype driven and just really not helpful,
right? We I think we have this idea just
kind of as an industry somehow that we
can like pipe a prompt and a loop to a
coding agent and that we can build
software this way, right? Maybe we're
investing a lot of time in verifiers.
Maybe you have six different code review
agents. But at the end of the day, if
we're doing this, we're still building
40,000 line PRs that just nobody wants
to read, right? And this isn't to throw
shade to Jeff Huntley, right? This is
Ralph is an innovative uh it's a sharp
tool that works very well for certain
types of problems. It works very well if
you're not building on a team and it
works very well if you're not working on
critical systems. But most of us are
working on teams and we don't fit in
that box. So today I want to talk about
how to build loops that work in large
complex code bases for systems that have
real customers, real users, real
regulatory obligations and service level
agreements and everything else that
keeps us from shipping yolo 40,000 line
PRs straight to production. In other
words, I want to talk about how to build
loops for the real world.
If you're not aware, uh, this post
actually dates back to July. It went
viral this past January, which is when a
lot of us, I think, started building
loops. And of course, much more
recently, I'm sure you all are going to
see this slide a lot this week. Uh, but
Peter Steinberger said that we shouldn't
be prompting coding agents anymore,
right? We should just be designing loops
that prompt our agents. Of course, Open
Claw is notoriously built on loops.
Loops build the code. Loops review the
code. They merge and release the code.
They find and fix the bugs. There's even
loops for finding and fixing bugs and
the loops that are merging the things,
right? It's loops all the way down. It's
uh Boris Turney also the creator of
Cloud Code recently said that this is
his entire job as an engineer now is
just writing loops to prompt Claude. And
eventually we might not even need loops,
right? We're just gonna have like swarms
of agents designing loops to prompt
agents building swarms for loops and
like I don't know somewhere we're like
writing production code I assume and in
fact all of our loops that we're
building are producing so much code that
we can't possibly read all of it right
so we might as well just not read any of
it right we're we're investing in
verification and in code review but all
this code is readon this was the thesis
of a conference that uh was here in town
last month. So, a lot of smart people at
the Frontier Labs think that this is the
future of software development. And if
you're doing this, you're moving 10x
faster and everybody else is getting
left behind. Now, it's not clear how
well this works yet. Uh took six months
to fix the cloud code terminal flicker.
The Open Code team wrote a renderer in a
fraction of that time. And Open Claw, of
course, also notoriously has stability
issues.
What is abundantly clear, however, is
that this is really expensive if
you don't work at a frontier lab and
have an unlimited token budget. And all
this code that we're writing is actually
really expensive, right? Matt PCO talked
about this recently. Uh, bad code is
much more expensive in the age of agents
than it it has ever been at any point in
the past. So today I want to talk about
what I think works in the real world and
what we've started doing at human layer,
which to be clear is still building
loops, right? I think loops are super
powerful, but we can design loops and
still read the code. In fact, we can
design loops that make it easier to read
the code because the loops are making
the code better. We can solve hard
problems in complex code bases with
loops and we can build our software
factory incrementally. But uh to do this
is going to take some real engineering
y'all. So let's talk about control
theory. Control theory is all about how
we drive a dynamic system which would be
your codebase towards some desired
stable or optimal end state, right? You
have a sensor that measures the current
state of the world. You have your set
point, right? The desired state of the
world. And the difference between those
two things is your measured error. You
have a controller that reads that
measured error and turns it into a
control signal about an incremental
change to apply to the system. We have
an actuator that applies that change to
the system which is undergoing
disturbances in the meantime. And then
we rememeasure recomputee our measured
error and we're back where we started.
Now this sounds really complicated and
it can be. I have a twin brother
actually who's an aerospace engineer.
This is how they keep fighter jets from
falling out of the sky. Uh but uh it's
probably a little bit simpler than most
of you all think. Does anyone have one
of these?
Uh a thermostat uses a control loop,
right? Uh for for any of our European
friends in the audience, it's part of
something we have uh here in the states.
It's called air conditioning.
And uh most of us probably use control
loops on a daily basis, right?
Kubernetes autoscaling systems are built
on control loops. Infrastructures code
uses a desired state, current state,
iterative change like control loop
pattern. Postgress's uh autovacuum and
reacts virtual DOM both use or
approximate control loops. Control loops
are ideal when we have a system that we
want to change, a problem we can
measure, and a way to get feedback on
the result of that change. Like good
software engineers have always been
taught to do, control loops change a
system incrementally instead of just
trying to get straight to the end state
immediately all at once and risk blowing
everything up, right? They help us to
avoid oversteering and destabilizing the
system and it minimizes risk.
So control loops are the opposite of
what I'm going to call a blind Ralph
loop. They're how we avoid PRs that look
like this because nobody wants to review
this, right? Which is not to say that
all Ralph loops are blind loops. The
best Ralphs are actually applying
control theory. I know Jeff Huntley is
out in the hall somewhere wandering
around. If you go talk to him, he's
going to tell you the same thing, right?
That Ralph is a a teaching device. And I
think some of us read it a little too
literally, but this is how we should
have always been building loops. But the
other issue with Ralph loops is they're
not incremental, right? It's just a bash
loop. So we have to build a gentic
control loops. And to do that, we start
by defining a set point, which is the
desired end state of our codebase with
respect to some property of it. And we
add a sensor. There's a lot of ways to
build a sensor. It can be strictly
deterministic, your ESLint rules, your
agp, your pack work, or it can be
non-deterministic. You can have an agent
and a skill and a bunch of natural
language rules. And you could also just
have a pipeline like a combination of
the two. So, how do we build a gentic?
Whoops. There we go. Now, uh, this is
all theory, right? Practically speaking,
and because we're using agents, we can
blur the lines a little bit between
system components. So, Aiden buys React
Doctor, for example, is fantastic. It
is, uh, it's a great way to catch all of
the React slot that Claude snuck into
your codebase last week. But, uh, it's a
hybrid sensor and controller. It tells
you what are all the problems with your
React code, and also, by the way, what
are the top three things you should fix
and how do you fix them? Similarly, our
controller and actuator might actually
just be a single agent deciding on an
incremental change to make and then
applying it in the same context window.
But I want to zoom in on the controller
a little bit because without one or
without a welltuned one, we might make
too large of a change all at once or we
might make the wrong change entirely.
And if you put that in a loop, you're in
trouble pretty quickly.
So, we can use control loops to root out
bad patterns and to clean up our code.
But we can actually use them for all
sorts of things, right? We could make
sure that our API is compliant with
someone else's open API spec. We can
make sure that our MCP server is
compliant with whatever version of the
uh the MCP specification that we're
currently on. Haven't checked. You could
mirror a project from Python into
TypeScript or vice versa. You could even
maintain your uh VE-based slop fork of
Nex.js against the upstream. The key
questions are can we find something we
can measure? Can we apply changes
incrementally and can we get feedback on
the quality of those changes? To
illustrate that, I'm going to walk
through a control loop that we use
internally at human layer. Uh for our
loop, we are incrementally migrating our
RPC API to effect. We adopted it for
some of our racer prone code. We like
it, so we're adopting it across the rest
of our codebase. If you've never seen
effects code before, the code on the
right is just the kind of trivial
procedure on the left rewritten in
effect. Uh the syntax is really weird.
We're psychos. We really like it. It's
not for everybody. That's okay. Uh, this
isn't a talk about effects, so we'll
keep moving.
Clicker's not working. Cool. So, step
one, we have to build our sensor to find
unmigrated procedures. We can have an
agent do this or we could use GP or RIP
GP, but instead we're going to use as GP
because it's really powerful. It's a
great tool to have in your toolbox for
building loops. It's language agnostic.
it's out of band from your TypeScript
config or eslint rules which if you're a
TypeScript developer you have watched
Claude disable those with inline
comments. Uh but so we can just write a
simple rule that finds unmigrated
procedures uh based on the pattern above
and we over time we can even layer on
more rules that describe other patterns
we want to get rid of with granular
include and exclude paths. If you have a
multilingual monor repo like we do, uh
it'll work for any language you could
possibly imagine. And we can just scan
our codebase and it'll produce a long
list of violations. Uh way too long. In
fact, it'll give you about 50 keys per
violation. So, we're just going to
filter it down to four. And we're going
to sort it deterministically. Why are we
doing that? At the beginning, I said
this was going to be practical. And so,
we're going to step outside of our
control loop paradigm for a second.
Because before we start incrementally
migrating procedures one at a time, we
need to enforce that all new procedures
are using effect. Right? So we're going
to run a full scan once on main, sort
all the violations deterministically and
track it in our version control. And
then on every new PR, we can see if the
branch added any unmigrated procedures,
right? So this is our control loop and
our system is undergoing disturbances.
In this case, uh all of our teammates
shipping cloud slot and this is how we
make sure that they're not undoing our
loop's work. This doesn't map directly
to a part of the control loop, but we
can kind of like squint at it a little
bit and call it a disturbance dampener.
So, now that we've stopped the bleeding,
we can actually design our controller.
For a simple controller, we could just
deterministically pick the first
violation from the list. You can use
bash and jq, or we could get a little
cleverer and use aspmigrated
procedure and always pick the smallest
one to reduce the risk.
Uh, we could have an agent make the
decision if we really want to. I don't
think you should ever send an agent to
do deterministic code's job, but you
certainly can. In fact, depending on the
complexity, we could have the agent pick
the procedure to migrate and just do it
at the same time like we just talked
about. But we can make this even more
powerful, right? Because we're not just
migrating to effect for the sake of it.
We're doing it because it's helpful for
handling errors and for helping us
instrument our code better. And so what
we could do if we want to get really
clever is we can look at our telemetry
and figure out which procedures have the
most errors or the least instrumentation
or has a gap in our APM. Right? And when
we send a control signal to our actuator
agent, we can include not just the
procedure to migrate but also all the
data about the things that we're trying
to fix with this migration so that the
actuator agent can actually make the
code better instead of just doing a
onetoone migration.
ma'am. There we go. So, next is building
our actuator. Our actuator is just an
agent plus a skill. Um, bring your CLI
coding agent of choice. You should spend
a lot of time on the skill. Not all of
that should be up front. You'll want to
iterate on it over time based on what
works. At human layer, we like to build
out what we call golden patterns by hand
before setting the agent loose. These
are just like idiomatic handwritten
examples for the agent to follow because
they're just pattern replicators and
otherwise you're getting what's in the
docs or what the agent knows from the
internet. And so we pipe the skill plus
our control signal into our actuator
agent. And the skill of course should
include a response template and the
agent's going to work and work and work
and it'll produce a final response. And
then we're going to deterministically
commit and push and create a PR using
the final message as our PR description.
Now all we have to do is actually run
the loop, right? Uh my recommendation is
to use GitHub actions or your GitLab or
your CircleCI or whatever else you're
using because it has access to your
code. It has access to your secrets and
it has great dispatch and scheduling
primitives, right? We don't need a new
cluster for this. So we can write a
workflow that runs a single iteration of
the loop sense, control, actuate, and
creates a PR and then we can schedule
this to run once a day. And every
morning we walk into the office to a
small incremental PR that's low risk.
And when we first did this it was
actually really frustrating and we
turned the loop off and it uh because we
had to constantly update the skill. We
had to constantly check out the branch,
change the skill, change the code,
commit and push and our loop was
actually really high friction, right?
But there's a better way to do this uh
where we can put a human on the loop in
a really low friction way to resteer it
when it goes wrong. And the way to do
this is to just create a feedback file
that's tracked in version control just
as a markdown file. Right? We can
deterministically load it into our
actuator agents context every time that
it runs after we run the controller.
Then we can add a label to the PR.
Right? Each workflow needs to be able to
identify PRs that are created since
there might be a bunch of different
loops running and we only want workflows
to respond to feedback from comments on
their PRs. And we're going to add a
comment trigger to each loop workflow.
So that when a user leaves a
slashiterate comment on the PR, uh the
loop workflow is going to pick that up.
It's going to deterministically load all
of the PR context, the diff, the
comments, the review comments, the
description into the agents context
along with the skill, and it's going to
instruct the agent to fix the code, but
also to update that feedback file.
Right? Looks kind of like this. And the
benefit of doing this way is that now
that feedback file with instructions is
tracked in your version control. you can
see how you've changed it over time. You
can revert it if you need to.
So, the next thing we're going to do is
add flow control. Because the other
problem that we had when we did this was
that if we were at a customer site for a
week or if we were traveling or spent
six days working on slides instead of
writing code, uh the PRs from all of our
loops would just stack up. They'd
duplicate work. They'd conflict and we
wouldn't get around to doing it. And
like the loop's work is important, but
it's not that important. And so now we
just had all this like junk we had to
deal with that wasn't important. So this
is actually a really easy problem to fix
uh because each loop and its workflow
has a label that gets attached to PRs.
When the workflow first runs uh before
we check out the code and install the
dependencies and run our sense actu or
sense control actuate steps, we can just
check and see if the last PR that we
created or any PR with the loops label
on it is open. And if so, we just shut
down, right? because this means that the
last time that a human uh reviewed the
code from this loop was before the loop
ran, right? No human reviewed the last
output. So there's no reason to stack up
even more work for humans to review.
This way we have exactly one PR at most
open per loop at a time. No stacking, no
duplication, hopefully no conflicts. And
of course, once you're feeling confident
in the loop, we're going to want to
speed it up, right? I have 150 RPC
procedures to migrate. If I do one at a
time, it's going to take six months,
which is way longer than I want to wait.
Fortunately, there's a lot of ways to
pick up the the velocity of our loop. Uh
we could have our controller pick three
procedures to migrate instead of one at
a time or five. Uh we could have our
controller pick three or five and then
do each of those in a separate
implementation phase, which will be both
cheaper and more reliable since each
migration gets its own context window.
Or we could just run the workflow four
times and give one PR to each of four
people on the team. So let's put it all
together. We built a control loop that
improves our code incrementally and
we're actually reading the code. It has
adaptive flow control so we're not
creating a bunch of loop or a bunch of
work that nobody wants to review and we
can rest steer it on the fly in a super
low friction way. If you want to try
this yourself uh we built a skill,
please try it out. My Twitter handle is
down there on the bottom. Please share
it. I would love to see what you build.
And if you get excited by this, uh at
Human Layer, we're hiring here in San
Francisco. And if you're working on
mission critical systems and want to
figure out how to get more out of AI,
we'd love to chat. Thank you so much.
In 2026, coding agents will quietly
retire their first software platform.
Not because it's bad, simply because the
platform is unnecessary.
I am Dominic Turno. I am founder and CEO
of Resonate. Resonate is a durable
execution platform built with minimalism
and simplicity as its core technical
values and these properties will play a
central role in this talk. At Resonate,
we have a working theory where software
engineering is headed.
Generalpurpose implementations will
increasingly be replaced by bespoke
implementations
generated on demand. Not as a new
library, a new framework or a new
platform, but as a minimal extension of
the infrastructure that is already in
place.
If this theory holds true, reuse will
move upstream.
Instead of reusing a general purpose
implementation, we will reuse a
specification and we will derive a
bespoke implementation from it.
In fact, we can build many bespoke
implementations
tailor made for the infrastructure that
is already in place. We just have to ask
the agent. At this point, the prompt is
a platform.
Resonate is a dual execution platform.
We have an implementation of the
Resonate server. We have implementations
of the Resonate SDK for TypeScript,
Python, Rust, Go, and Java. So, we have
to ask
what does this new reality mean for us?
If implementations become generatable,
where does our value live?
and our answer our value moves from
implementation to specification.
Now this changes how we think about
Resonate. The product is no longer the
implementation. The product is the
specification the protocol
and from that protocol we want to derive
multiple server implementations.
One is a general purpose resonate
server, our reference implementation.
Others are implementations built with
infrastructure partners.
For customers and partners, this means
durable execution right on top of their
existing infrastructure with minimal
additional dependencies.
So the question is no longer can we
build a server. The question is, can we
repeatedly synthesize trusted servers
from the same specification?
And if so, how?
When we talk about agentic engineering,
we focus all of our attention on
verification.
How do we know the result is correct?
But today, I want to focus on the
specification instead. And more
importantly, how can agents participate
in specifying the system, not just
building or verifying it.
Now, Resonate is partnering with
multiple infrastructure providers to
bring durable executions natively to
their technology stack. One of them is
Senadia, the company behind Nats.io, an
open-source messaging system designed
for building modern distributed systems.
For the rest of this presentation, we
will use Resonate on Nats.io to explore
our agentic engineering practices. How
do we go from specification to
implementation?
First, we need to level set our mental
model.
This picture is a common view of agent
decoding. There's an agent, there's a
specification, and then there's an
implementation.
And for many applications that is enough
but it is not enough for what we are
trying to do because we are not trying
to generate one implementation from a
specification.
We are trying to generate multiple
target specific implementations from the
specification.
So the specification must not take any
aspect of an implementation into
account.
The specification must not assume a
concrete database schema or concrete
indices.
The specification must not even assume a
relational database with tables and
transactions at all. It must not assume
a key value store. It must not assume
weak consistency. It must not assume
strong consistency.
The specification must be abstract.
Only the implementation must be
concrete.
So we ask the agent to follow the
abstract specification and generate a
concrete implementation.
Specifically at first we ask the agent
build a resonate server in rust on top
of posgress
and the agent failed.
The gap between the abstract
specification and the concrete
implementation was too large.
The agent generated a system that worked
on the happy path.
It passed the basic tests, but it was
not correct. It broke on the
concurrency. It broke on the process
failure. It broke on the network
failure. The implementation was closer
to a prototype, but not a production
system.
So, we amended the process. Instead of
asking the agent to jump directly from
abstract spec to concrete
implementation, we inserted an
intermediary artifact, the concrete
specification.
That concrete specification was derived
interactively with the agent. But the
human was the main driver.
For Postgress that meant making target
specific decisions explicit, the data
schema, the indices, the SQL queries,
the transaction boundaries.
Once those decisions were written down,
the agent was indeed able to implement
the production system. So this worked,
but it also revealed the limitations.
The agent helped us build the system,
but the agent did not help us design the
system.
And if the specification is a reusable
product, then that's not enough.
Now the next step is obvious. Agents
have to move upstream.
But how?
When we started building resonate on
NATO, we changed the question.
We did not ask can the agent build the
production system. Instead we ask what
does the agent need in order to design
the system first and build the system
second.
So we gave the agent access to a
deterministic simulation environment.
And we gave it a different task.
Do not build the production system.
Build a simulated implementation.
The simulated implementation is not the
product.
It is executable design.
Its purpose is to discover the correct
algorithm under partial order under
partial failure. And once these
algorithms are discovered, tested and
verified in simulation, then we ask the
agent to write the concrete
specification. And only then do we ask
the agent to write the production
implementation.
So the process becomes abstract
specification,
simulation implementation,
concrete specification and then concrete
implementation.
This is a point where the agent moves
upstream.
Humans are still involved in the design
process, but now the agent is a driver.
Two ingredients make this possible.
Minimalism and simplicity.
Unfortunately, minimalism and simplicity
are not the starting point. They are the
finish line. We spent three years making
the protocol smaller and simpler. Every
time we ran into a problem, we ask,
"What can we take away? What abstraction
can we erase? What property can we
remove? What relationship can we break?"
The result is a very small protocol
centered around two objects, a durable
promise and a durable task.
That simplicity matters because even
simple concurrent distributed protocol
have a complex state and behavior space.
So in other terms, implementing even
simple protocols on top of a few simple
primitives is tough.
Let's make this concrete with NATS.NATS
gives us a small set of primitives. We
can build on cues, a key value store and
delayed or scheduled messages.
These are not resonate concepts. These
are the concepts of the target platform.
So the design question becomes how can
we express the resonate protocol using
only these primitives?
Let's focus on the key value store.
The key value store is versioned. We
create a key with value fu. Then we
update it to bar. Then we update it to
bass. So the latest value is bass at
version two.
Most of the time when we read the key
that is exactly what we get
a fresh read.
And if all reads were fresh the design
would be straightforward.
But sometimes the read is stale.
Here the latest value is still bass at
version two.
But the read returns fu at version zero.
That is not corruption.
That is not a bug in the key value
store.
That is a valid read under the
consistency model of the target
platform.
And that matters because our
implementation cannot be correct only
when the target behaves conveniently.
The implementation has to be correct
when the target behaves legally.
So the simulation environment has to
expose exactly this kind of behavior.
Fresh reads, stale reads, and the
version information that tells us which
world we are in.
Unfortunately, we do not know the read
was stale simply by reading. We will
find out later when we try to write
here. We read version zero. So, we try
to update version zero.
But the key has already moved on. The
right fails.
That is the moment the target tells us
the world you saw is not the current
world.
Building always correct applications on
top of a concurrency model that allows
occasional stale reads is not simple.
Not for humans, not for agents.
So, how do we set up our agent for
success? What tools does our agent need
to ace this task instead of falling flat
on its face?
Agents thrive on feedback.
Immediate, unambiguous feedback.
Not just feedback that shows this went
wrong.
Feedback that shows why and how this
went wrong.
What stale value was returned? What
logic was triggered? What ride failed
and which invariant broke because of
that.
So we built a deterministic simulation
testing environment in Python. And
inside that environment, we simulated
the parts of nuts.io we depend on
here for example is the simulated key
value store.
It keeps a full version history for
every key on get the simulated store
sometimes return the latest version but
sometimes controlled by the
deterministic random generator. The
store returns an older version.
On update the store enforces optimistic
concurrency. The write only succeeds if
the version you read is still the latest
version. Otherwise, it raises.
This gives the agent a store that
behaves like the real store in the ways
that matter for correctness. But unlike
the real target, the simulation is
deterministic. It's repeatable and it's
inspectable.
So when the agent writes the wrong
algorithm, we can reproduce the exact
execution. that broke it and the agent
can repair the algorithm against that
trace.
But deterministic simulation does more
than just inject stale reads.
It lets us expose facts the real
platform hides.
We call this the forbidden fruit.
In production, when you read from the
key value store, you only get the value
in the version you observed. You do not
get to know whether that read was fresh
or stale. You do not get to see the
latest value you missed. And you
shouldn't get that information because
real code cannot depend on it.
But in simulation, we can record it.
Here every get emits a trace event. If
the read is fresh, the trace says this
was fresh. If the read is stale, the
trace says this was stale. This is what
you got and this is what the latest
value was.
That information is forbidden to the
algorithm, but it is incredibly useful
to the agent.
It lets us explore failures in terms the
agent can act on.
Now this is what a trace event looks
like. The production code only receives
the result.
It sees the promise was pending.
This is all the real platform would tell
us.
But the simulation also records the type
of the read. This read was a stale read.
And it records the latest value that was
hidden from the algorithm.
The latest value says the same promise
is already settled.
That difference is exactly the kind of
fact an agent needs when it's debugging
a distributed algorithm.
Not just the invariant failed.
But the invariant failed because the
algorithm made a decision from a stale
view of the world.
Again, the algorithm is not allowed to
depend on this information, but the
agent is allowed to use it to explain
why the algorithm it designed was wrong.
Cause and effect becomes visible.
The agent does not just learn that the
system is wrong. It learns why the
system is wrong.
And with this approach, the agent was
able to close the gap.
First, the agent built a proof of
concept in the deterministic simulator
verified by fast testing.
From the proof of concept, the agent
derived a concrete specification
where we already knew the algorithm was
correct.
And like before from the concrete
specification,
the agent derived an implementation.
Deterministic simulation lets agents
participate in the design, not just in
the implementation.
Humans are still in the design process,
but this time the agent is the driver.
From a single abstract specification,
the agent designed and built the
platform via simulation to concrete
specification to concrete
implementation.
The prompt is a platform and the
specification is a product. Thank you
very much for watching. If you have any
questions, please don't hesitate to
reach out. You will find me in Resonates
Discord.
Hey everyone, I'm So I'm the CEO and
co-founder of Starite Search. And today
my talk is user signals die after
retrieval boundary. So we'll look into
uh what are agents essentially why agent
fails, what is uh the cause of fails in
retrieval particularly and how to make
actually signal cross the retrieval
boundary and how to make your agent
basically outcome fair.
So uh let's get started. What is an
agent? An agent is an LLM that has
agency to reason, invoke tools, uh
interact with the real world, retrieve
uh the memory to complete the task. One
major loop here is missing is uh
learning. It should also learn from what
worked and what it didn't work. Suppose
uh if I have to uh explain what is agent
is I can explain with react agent. So if
I have to explain uh what agent is I'll
explain it with react agent. So
basically user prompt the agent uh
execute it in a loop uh kind to a
retriever search and then pause when the
task is complete. This is very basic
react architecture. One thing that is
missing is how to make agent learn from
the outcome.
So agent keeps failing at the same task
got reported 85% of AI just failing.
So it's in McKenzie's 2025 report. The
problem came out to be most of the time
is that retrieval is static. 73% of uh
our app pipeline fails because of
retrieval not generation and context
stuffing. So a recent uh uh post from
Ram Shria the XCO of Pine cone said uh
we have been optimizing for the wrong
thing. You are paying a lot for your
agent's memory. It is probably broken
and we have been optimizing for the
wrong thing.
Hey. Hey. Hey.
Heat.
Hey, heat. Hey, heat.
Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat. N.
Heat. Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
Heat. Heat. N.
Heat. Heat.
Hey,
hey, hey.
Ladies and gentlemen, please put your
hands together and welcome back our MC,
member of the technical staff at
Keycard, Ally How.
Welcome back to our afternoon keynotes.
I hope you all had an amazing day so
far. I know I certainly have. I've
enjoyed exploring the different talks
across all of our different 18 different
tracks. I've enjoyed exploring the expo
session and I've enjoyed talking and
networking with all of you. A engineer
is a really special place where we can
all come together in one space and have
really interesting conversations that
push the boundaries of what's next. It's
a really powerful thing to get AI
security engineers and AI engineers into
the same room and understand how we can
unblock um shipping because of security
issues, ship faster and increase our
engineering velocity. It's also really
exciting to get the same people that are
building the models in the same room
with the people that are using them so
we can understand what actually works
and help us define what's next. I'm
super excited for the rest of our
content today, but I want to take a
moment to thank our amazing sponsors
that make all of this possible. Let's
take a round of applause for our
presenting sponsor, Microsoft.
I also want to recognize our lab and
platinum sponsors.
Also, our gold sponsors. Round of
applause for them as well.
And last but not least, I want to thank
our silver and bronze sponsors, which
there are innumeable amount of those as
well.
It sterling takes a lot of people to put
on this event. Um, and so super thankful
to all of our different sponsors,
thankful for all of the people that are
here that make this community possible.
Um, I know we've heard a lot about
software factories today. And they're
super interesting. We're all like very
um allured by the promise of what the
productivity and the unlock that they
can deliver. But in practice, they can
be more difficult than in theory. And
I'm really excited because our next
round of speakers are going to help us
understand the best practices for loop
engineering and help us understand how
we can create software factories that
actually work and don't produce slob.
I'm super excited to introduce our very
first speaker of the afternoon keynote
sessions. Um, this speaker is a seasoned
AIE speaker. Um he just told me this is
his fourth time he's spoken at AI
engineer which is incredible. Um this
speaker is known for raging the war on
slop. He is known for coining the the
term context engineering and he is known
for creating the research plan implement
framework that we know and love. It's my
honor to introduce um Jack Sworthis,
co-founder and CEO of human layer to
talk about harness engineering is not
enough why software factories fail.
Please welcome to the stage Jack.
What's up everybody? How we doing
guys? Give it up for all the great
speakers today so far.
Um,
all right. This is uh harness
engineering is not enough and why
software factories fail. And we're gonna
click maybe.
Oh, that's way too many slides. Hold on,
guys. Okay. Um, so we're all racing to
put AI coding into production and uh
there's been lots been said about loop
engineering and uh we should probably
write more loops and uh yeah, I don't
know. I guess we're doing loops now.
uh strong DM built a lights off software
factory where nobody even reads the code
and the prevailing narrative is we
should just spend more tokens you are
the bottleneck the models are good
enough code is free just ship more stuff
but at the same time we are starting to
see the cracks our friend uh Mario at AI
Engineer Europe begged us to slow down
because companies that should not be
having outages because of coding agents
are having outages due due to coding
agent mishaps. Um, code bases are
falling apart faster than they ever have
before. And our friends at Farosai
actually even did a report since we all
picked up all these AI coding tools in
January, maybe February. Um, pull
request code review quality is way down.
We're having more comments, longer
comments, and tons of PRs being merged
without any review at all. Incidents are
way up, bugs per developer are way up.
And uh, many people will tell you that
you're holding it wrong. that's the only
reason you're not.
Well, maybe you are, but that's not the
point. Um, I've spoken a lot about how
to hold it better when it comes to
working with AI. Uh, probably a million
views on YouTube at this point across a
bunch of different talks. Um, and the
basic thing is like as engineers, we've
been told that if token maxing isn't
working, then it's a skill issue. You
just need to spend more tokens. Uh, let
go of reading the code. that with enough
harness engineering, if we maybe
sprinkle some magic words, adversarial
review on enough of our PR bots, that we
can get the best of both worlds, 10 to
100x faster, high quality, and nobody
has to do that thing we all hate called
code review. Uh, I'm here to convince
you today that this is in fact not a
scale issue. That no amount of harness
engineering or loops maxing can solve
what is fundamentally a model training
issue. That's why we say the harness is
not enough. Um, and to understand this,
we kind of have to grapple and dig into
how coding models are trained. I'm going
to talk about what I think the
shortcomings are with some of the
current benchmarks and what better ones
might look like. And we'll talk about
how to move faster safely. In the
meantime, um, it's going to sound like a
rant, uh, but there is hope here. Uh I'm
going to talk about our journey and a
bunch of the landmines we've hit uh
building in this world. A bunch of
exciting new techniques that we've been
working with uh a lot of our users and
customers to develop and I think how we
all as a community get to the next
chapter of agentic engineering after
whatever this thing that we're in. Um so
we use a lot of words here. I'm going to
zoom out a little bit. I want to give
you kind of like a brief history of the
software factory. Um and it's actually I
don't I I just learned this last week.
It was the term software factory was
defined at a NATO conference in 1968.
Uh we're going to start around 2022,
like right before AI started coming
around. Um and basically in a typical
2022 software factory, you will have
some people building stuff. You'll have
engineers, you'll have PMs, maybe you
have some sort of leadership team that
is driving the vision here, and they all
decide that stuff needs to get done. And
so you put it in a tracker, a linear, a
Jira, a beads, some sort of state
machine that tracks what needs to be
done. And then someone goes and grabs
something off of there and they build
the thing. And there may be some
automated testing in that process, maybe
some ma manual testing in that process.
At a certain point, we make this pull
request thing says, "Okay, cool. We got
to run a bunch of checks, automated
stuff. A human's going to review the
change and review the code. And perhaps
we might even have uh a human pull it
down and test it somehow. And if
anything goes wrong here, we loop back
to someone builds the thing. Uh, and
eventually we're ready for prod. And so
we ship it to production. And once it's
in prod, it makes contact with our
users. And users do uh a thing that uh
we all love. Uh users love to complain.
I I love our users. Uh but yeah, they're
going to ask for things. They're going
to find bugs. They're going to file
feature requests. Uh and that goes back
to your team. You might also add
monitoring. And so uh you know what do
we want more than anything else? We want
to wake up engineers at 3 in the morning
when something breaks so they can get
dragged out of bud to try to go fix it.
Uh and we go on and on in this loop. Uh
and we ship a bunch of code. Um, and one
thing that we noticed here is that uh,
teams figured this out decades ago is
that this someone builds the thing step
is usually going to take hours or days
in most cases. And the review part will
also take hours or days for large
things. And so teams started doing these
upfront planning, architecture,
proposals, sprint planning, and they
would collaborate this on on these
things as a team uh with the hopes that
we might decrease the percent chance
that something would need to be reworked
that we would be able to reduce the time
spent in reviewing every line of code
because we aligned on everything ahead
of time. This brings us to the agentic
software factory. Uh every company and
their mother is talking about how they
built a coding agent factory that ships
75% of their code. now uh literally
everybody uh and so if we look at the
software factory from 2022 uh we just
replace someone builds the thing with an
agent builds the thing and we have an
orchestration and a harness and a
sandbox and a model and computer use and
I'm not going to get into like the
details of that you can watch a hundred
talks about that this week I'm sure um
but now the building part takes minutes
or hours but this human part still takes
hours or days if you're going to review
the code and you're going to test the
changes and so we bring in agentic code
review and we bring in agentic
regression testing Uh, and it makes this
part faster, but it's probably still the
bottleneck. But we can do more loops
here. Why not? Let's do some more loops.
So, we can route all incidents straight
into the factory. Why does someone need
to get woken up uh and try to fix it
when they could just wake up to a pull
request and uh maybe that fixes the
issue for you? You can take all the user
feedback and just stick it straight into
the factory so that uh people ask for
stuff and it gets built. And now your
only job is how much things can you
stuff into the queue of stuff to do and
how fast can you review and test the
changes? Which brings us of course to
I'm sure you know the lightsoft software
factory where basically Dan Shapiro
coined this is we no longer read the
code. We say you know what this is going
great that code review thing no thanks.
We're just not going to do that anymore.
Uh and we invest into all these other
parts of the system your testing your
monitoring your rollout everything else.
we just write more code and build those
systems better. And now our job really
is just how how much stuff can we ask
the agent to build.
I am going to pause that does not work.
Uh and this is why software factories
fail. Um as as an aside, what I'm going
to say has nothing to do with vibe
coding. So Addy had this uh great post.
I'm going to just go literally take his
quote verbatim. a developer vibe coding
a side project a dozen people will ever
run and a team keeping a 10-year-old
enterprise system alive for another
quarter share almost no constraints
worth naming and most of what you hear
on the internet is one of these groups
of people telling the other group of
people how to live their lives
if you love vibe coding please go on um
at human layer what we care about is how
do we help people solve hard problems in
complex code bases um we use the word
brownfield a lot which historically has
meant like some 10-year-old Java thing.
I actually think agents really start to
struggle after maybe 3 to 6 months,
especially with the pace at which we can
ship. Now, um you can ask me how I know
this and I will tell you that it is
because in July 2025, we tried this. We
went full lights off and uh if you have
tried this seriously for a number of
months, you probably found at least one
issue that the agent couldn't solve.
even with your most advanced prompting.
You do research, you do reproductions,
you just you have to go and dig into
that codebase that you stopped reading
three months ago to try to figure out
what's broken. And in the meantime, your
site was down, your users were pissed,
and you were, if you were like me, you
were probably miserable reading all this
slop code that you let slip into your
system. And what I want to get to is
basically models have a shortcoming. um
they can't maintain and improve codebase
quality over time, not without a decent
amount of human steering. Um and when I
say maintainability, I'm basically
talking about issues like it becomes
really really hard to make a change in
one part of the codebase without
breaking other parts of the codebase.
This is Martin Fowler shotgun surgery
textbook code smell. Um I'm not going to
say much more about maintainability.
There's a bunch of books that you can go
read about it. In fact, John Austerhood
is actually here speaking this week, so
you can go ask him in person about the
philosophy of software design if you
want to. Um, but it brings us to this
question of like why can't models do
software maintainability. Um, and you
may also be saying, "But Dex, you know,
surely the models have gotten much
better since then." Um, they've gotten
better in some ways, but they're still
about the same in others. Um, if you
want to solve one-off problems or vibe
code a new marketing site, yes, they got
way better since 2025 and 2024, but as
far as improving codebase quality, I
think uh they have not gotten much
better. Now, I cannot prove this because
there are no good benchmarks for a
model's ability to maintain codebased
quality. And I'll get into like where
we're going with that. Um, but if you've
worked with coding agents for a while, a
lot of people are posting about this.
It's just like you probably have this
vibe that they they generally make
things worse over time and make the
codebase harder to work in. And to
figure out why this happens, I want to
zoom out to the first great coding
agent. Why did cloud code go from
nothing to four billion? And I think now
they're at nine billion in revenue in
under a year because they were great CLI
agents before cloud code. You had aer,
you had codebuff. There was a bunch of
tools in this category. They had all the
same tools, read, write, edit, grab,
bash. Um, so what was the difference?
The difference was was that the this was
the first time that a model lab trained
a model against the harness that they
were going to distribute it to users in.
Um, and it got really really good. This
is just some of the tools, but it got
really really good at calling these
sorts of tools in an agentic loop. In
fact, the OpenAI team did a talk in
November about basically if you are a uh
harness builder and you don't own the
model weights and you can't RL the model
in your harness, you will always be at a
disadvantage compared to somebody who
owns both the model and the harness. Um,
and I'm going to site a couple slides
from my buddy Calvin French Owen who was
a MTS on Codeex during the initial
launch. Um, but LM are just next token
predictors. Uh, this is a slide from
over a year ago where basically as
you're doing your agentic loop, context
window goes in, next step comes out.
problems. We're going to generate a
bunch of we're going to give it a
problem and we're going to generate a
bunch of traces, try to solve the
problem a bunch of different times.
We're going to score them all on
correctness and did the test pass and
all this stuff. Uh, and then we're going
to reinforce. We're going to make the
bad behavior less likely and we're going
to update the weights to make the good
behavior more likely. Um, this one of
the classic ones here is bench
multilingual. Uh, they're about
15-minute tasks. They're from open
source repos like Reddus and jQ and
Django and all this stuff. and they have
binary one or zero rewards on did you
fix the problem you were trying to fix
and did you do it without breaking
anything else. Um and we look at
actually a real problem from one of
these benchmarks. This is fastlane which
is a Ruby project. Um basically there
was some issue where we weren't checking
for nil and we have a stack trace blow
up because you have a null pointer
exception. And in this um in this
benchmark you have a base commit that
we're going to check out before the
issue was solved by a human in the past.
We're going to give it a test patch that
says here's what the behavior should be
afterwards. We have a golden patch. Both
these are hidden from the model. Uh, and
so we have the agent go try to solve the
problem. We store its patch. We undo all
the changes it made to any test files
because I'm sure you've seen models
comment out tests just to get things
working. And then um we're going to
apply our golden test patch. Uh, and
then we're going to run the test. Old
test and did the new test pass? And if
they both pass then, uh, then we get the
reward. Otherwise, we don't. Um, and so
models are trying to get the test to
pass. There's no way in this system that
we can penalize it for poor program
design or for eroding the
maintainability of our systems. That's
why we get things like this try catches
around things that probably don't need a
try catch or things like this. I think
by Bob gave us this example earlier of
casting things to other things just so
the model can just just it just wants to
get the test to pass. Um, and so if you
can't verify the uh maintainability of
the code, it gets way harder to train on
this stuff. Um, so you remember this
picture. Verifying code quality and
maintainability is orders of magnitude
harder than the code runs and the test
pass because the cost function of bad
architecture is measured in months and
years. If you have a coding episode and
then you only find out months later that
like somebody vied this a little bit too
hard. It's really hard to propagate that
reward signal back across the gap. And
now the frontier is getting better
slowly. And since I know someone's going
to be in the YouTube comments about
this, yes, I know benchmarks and
verifiers are different and they
actually have to be separate data sets,
but they're shaped the same and the the
structure of these benchmarks is
directionally correct. So, we're going
to look at these as like what is the
future of evaluating code
maintainability. Um, there's a really
cool one called SWE Marathon from
Abundant AI where they do like 400hour
tasks of like clone all of Microsoft
Excel, every single feature. Uh, and
they have some sophisticated reward
channel stuff. uh deep suite from data
curve is also like large tasks on oss
repos that are not actually in the
training set because they were never
actually built in the real world. Uh and
then you have frontier code from
cognition um which is multipr tasks.
They do interesting things like hey if
the model writes tests that don't fail
on the pre- patch code then it gets
penalized and we have a judge model that
says okay uh did this follow all of our
code quality rules. Um, so we're getting
better, but I think models judging
quality can only go so far. Uh, because
if the new model, if the model knew what
good code looks like, it would probably
write it in the first place. Uh, and
review agents and throwing more tokens
at the problem, it can raise the floor.
Um, but we're still constrained by what
we can teach during RL. Um, and so I
will I will posit that for now we're
stuck reading the code. Uh, but we can
still move pretty fast. And of course
there's a world where this is solved uh
in the future. And if you want to just
keep yoloing prompts until you get to
GPT7, you don't have to think about
this. By all means, please. Uh, but
bitter lesson be damned. We've got some
problems to solve. So, let's engineer
our way out of this. Um, so turning the
lights back on, we're going to put the
code review back. Uh, we're going to
embrace this approach of like how do we
plan up front to reduce the chance that
we have a long or uh difficult review
process. We're going to find leverage.
We're going to use AI to help with this.
Um, the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to do some sort of product
review. understanding what problem we're
solving, what's the desired behavior,
maybe looking at mockups. Here's a
product review I was working on
yesterday with a mockup of a new
feature. Um, once we have our product
review, we're going to, and by the way,
we don't small stuff still just go
straight to the agent. Um, but once we
have the product review, we're going to
also do architecture, system
architecture. A lot of people have been
doing this for a while. Component
contracts, data models, constraints. Um,
this is an example of a doc that we
build to understand how these systems
are going to fit together and what's
like the highle picture of it. From
there, we do something uh that I think
is really underemphasized in uh agentic
coding these days, which is program
design. I think people assume that once
you get the architecture right, the
model can just cook. Um but we I we
often look into the types and the method
signatures, the program layout and the
call stacks. And so here's some
examples. I don't think you'll be able
to read this one, but this is like the
level of abstraction we're at is how are
we actually going to lay this stuff out
and how are these systems going to
interact? Uh Dylan Mullroy from
Cloudflare talks a lot about how he's
using these call graphs as part of his
planning process. I think this is
exactly right. Um and then once we've
done the pro program design, we can do
this thing called vertical slices. Um
which is the order of implementation,
multi-reo coordination. How are we going
to build this across our entire system
and how are we going to check it along
the way? I've talked a little bit about
how models have horizontal plans. I
won't go too deep into it. If you want
to learn more about this, you can go
watch our talk from AI engineer Miami.
um couple shots of a dock like this
going through the tests and the steps in
between each phase. Um the main idea
here is 30 minutes over here in
pre-planning and alignment can save you
hours in review and so it's actually
feasible to still read every line of
code. Um we're skip this part. Uh
basically the the summary here is like
you don't have too many PRs. If you're
drowning in PRs, you actually have too
many bad PRs.
Um because a good PR is a joy to to
review. It's it's you're just reading
through like, "Yep, this is great. This
is what we discussed. This is what we
talked about." Um but even if a PR needs
20% rework, which is generous for a lot
of AI AI vibecoded slop um it's an it's
an emotional and intellectual burden on
both the reviewer and the submitter. Um
and so if you use model assisted
planning and alignment, your alignment
is shorter because you use AI to get all
the information at once. your code
review is faster because you aligned up
front and your coding is faster because
AI did it. And so you're now you're
actually really moving faster, but
you're still reading everything and
you're still owning the code. So closing
advice, um, it's easy to hear all this
and be a little bummed out. Uh, I really
like the world where we just yolo
everything and we can just like not have
to ever read code ever again. But, uh,
we're engineers and these are just
constraints and models are good at
certain things and they're not good at
other things. And so go figure out how
to solve problems given a set of
constraints. Uh use loops. They're
great. Go solve hard problems. Seek
leverage. Um if you want to help with
this, um we're building human layer.
Human layer is an AI IDE and
collaboration platform. It's building
blocks for your software factory. Um and
soon to be better verifiers for software
quality. Um we've got sort of a Figma
for cloud code and codec style
collaborative workspace. It walks you
through the workflows for doing this
sort of work. And uh we are talking to
design partners. We are hiring founding
engineers here in San Francisco. And uh
these slides are live. You can go get
them right now. You can try human layer
at human layer.com. Uh it's free for
small teams. Go solve hard problems in
complex code bases. Thank you all for
your energy.
Please welcome to the stage the research
scholar at Linet's Labs, Eric Meyer.
Well, um, can you go back one slide?
Sorry. All right. Good afternoon,
everybody. Thanks for being here after a
long day of talks, exhibits, side
effects. Oh, sorry, that was a side
event. Um, I hope that, um, you have as
much fun watching this talk as I had
creating it.
Um, let me first get this out of the
way. This is not a product pitch or
announcement or anything. It's a 20inut
tutorial of how you can use elementary
type systems and compiler knowledge to
make AI provably safe. And I'm sharing
all my secrets with you today. Um
hopefully to kind of inspire some of you
that next year you will have a booth
downstairs where you have kind like you
know created a provably safe agentic
harness. Um or who knows maybe some of
you have already solved it. Let me know
and then you know we can grab a coffee
instead of doing this talk. Um with that
out of the way let's get going. um while
I was preparing these slides and I'm
sorry that I was multitasking but I was
site um vip coding on the site um and
then when my attention waned for a
second because I was trying to convince
the model to draw some pictures that it
didn't want to do and you will see some
of these pictures later you can guess
which ones were rejected suddenly when
cloud code deleted one of my files
And I'm sure this has happened to you
before. Um, or maybe not. Maybe you
always kind of like, you know, run
everything with no permissions and then
you say, "Yes, yes, yes." But I like to
live dangerously.
Um, but I'm convinced that if there's
anything between the model's goal and
where the model currently is, it will do
everything that it can to reach that
goal, including killing us or deleting
your files or deleting your database.
So, I think that these models are
intrinsically very very dangerous and we
have to tame them. So, that's what my
talk is about. Um so let's get like you
know start this story. Um and it's I
think a very very sad story but also a
scary story of how we as an industry got
to this point where we are about to let
normal people the general public
give control of their computers their
finances their whole personal lives over
to AI agents and we don't have any
protection in place and I think that's
very sad and very Gary. Um, so let me
tell you the story how we got there and
I will like have some characters like
Claude and we will see Dario, Daniela,
Sam, Bernie, but um the main character
is is our friendly pit cla here. Um, I
think you can all remember
um November 30, 2022. This was kind of
like a very special day in in history
because this was the first time that you
could speak to your computer. You could
say summarize my emails and it would you
know um answer you in perfect English.
Um I think for me at least that was
magic. But I think most of us didn't
realize that by introducing this
innocent looking function here LLM that
takes a question and returns an answer
that that would open Pandora's box and
that would change our history forever.
Um but before we go continue the story
this conference is called AI engineer.
All right. So, we are engineers and
maybe we're the last generation of
engineers that still understand what
this is, what code is and or maybe most
of you have already forgotten what code
is because all your code is written by
agents. But if we look at this signature
here, it says it the LLM takes a
question, returns an answer. The
question and answers are not strings.
They're very complicated JSON structures
and they get more complicated every day
every time a new release of APIs comes
out. But for this talk, we can just
assume that question and answer are just
opaque types. We we don't care about how
they look like. We do care about what
they represent.
Um now anyway the euphoria of like these
LLMs as being great tools didn't last
very long and just when we thought that
we have eradicated the small pox of
computer science SQL injection it came
back with a vengeance because the bad
guys discovered that you can trick LLMs
using prompt injection and LLMs have no
distinction make no distinction between
code and and and text and so they are
very very easy to trick and this I think
is a bigger problem than SQL injection
ever was.
Um but it was not prompt injection only
that made LLMs kind of like have a bad
rep. LLMs are trained on the whole
internet and there's like a lot of good
stuff on the internet but also a lot of
bad stuff like how do you create a bomb?
How do you synthesize drugs? How do you
hack into people's systems? And the
leaders of the big foundation labs, they
got a little bit worried that the that
the government would interfere and
regulated the industry. So they told
their PhD researchers, go find a
solution for this problem right now and
quick. Come on, solve it before you know
the the government steps in. Um, and
here the PhD types, since they're PhD
types, they thought long and hard about
the safety problem. And they came up
with a new interface for LLMs. That's
this kind of scary on the right.
Look at that. What does it say? There's
like some sigma Greek symbols. There's
props, whatever. Well, that is lean.
Probably you have heard of lean. Anyone
here heard of lean? lean is now like the
hot thing, right? Like VCs are are
writing like multi-billion dollar checks
if you just say that you're doing
something with lean and of course these
PhD types researchers are using lean and
you have to suffer because of that. Um
now let's first look at the signature in
a slightly simpler language called um
deafne and what this thing says is that
the llm takes a question returns an
answer it requires this question to be
proper which means that it's not an
offensive question and then the model
returns a safe uh answer and this thing
is proved automatically. So if you give
it a proper question it gives you a safe
answer. Um, now I think there's too much
attention for lean. I'm a recovering
typaholic and math addict. Um, I love
lean, but there's many, many other tier
improvers and model checkers out there
like Isabel, Rock, PVS, TA Plus. Um, but
lean is the grease that kind like keeps
the VC money pumps going. So, I will use
lean um today. So here here's the kind
like you know the the interface again in
lean and now in lean you don't do
automatically improving. If you're like
a lean expert you will say Eric well we
have grind in lean but let's like you
know put that aside for a minute. Um but
in lean you have to both show that the
how to compute the the result type and
you have to do the proof by hand. Um so
it's it's slightly different than um the
definite example. But if you think about
this thing for just a single nancond,
you will realize that it's impossible to
write a formal proof that an answer is
safe or a question is proper. Um and
that is why there are at least 100
startups down here in the exhibition
hall that are using LLMs as a judge
because this is not something that you
can formally specify. But does it mean
that an answer is safe? That's not a
mathematical property. Um, and of
course, if you own a foundation model
like these guys, you don't need external
LLMs as a judge. You just um bake it
into the weights and you call it, the
model is aligned. Um, but unfortunately
trying to bake alignment into the model
is not foolproof and models get
routinely jailbroken. So they had to go
to the pope and ask it to kind of like
you know um bless their model that it's
safe. Um now I think it's terrible if
like a model says something offensive
but those are just words and ultimately
the words are are like they just like
you know they drip off your body. They
don't do anything. Some human has to act
on words to make them dangerous. Um and
so maybe that is what they mean by
broadly safe um when entropic
talks about safety. Um because it's
still a human involved. But then
something terrible happened. Something
really terrible happened that changed
the world forever
and that is in June 2023, OpenAI
announced tool call support in GPT4. And
of course all the other vendors rushed
out to copy this. This is called the
principle of minimum differentiation.
And that is why all these APIs look the
same. Um
now the act of adding tool calls changes
AI safety from a philosophical debate to
something that causes real danger. You
could say tool calls give the model
clause in addition to a mouth. Or you
can say tool calls is like handing a
gun, a loaded gun to them.
But of course, nobody listens to me.
Everybody ignores what they say. And
these guys just went ahead and have
shipped tool calls. They just, you know,
just just do it.
Now let's go back to like this is AI
engineering conference. So let's look at
what is the difference in the signature
of LLMs when they add a tool calls. And
it's just that little IO there. And of
course it messes up the the formatting
of of the the um uh signature. But if
you look at the picture there, what you
show now suddenly Claude goes from like
a nice puppy to a dangerous thing. Look,
it has all these dangerous tools and now
it becomes scary, right? I've never seen
anything scarier than an LLM with tool
calls. Um, now if you look at this, this
is like like a small step for a type but
a giant leap for chaos. Why is that? And
that is because this IO says that in
order to compute the answer, the agent
has to go through the agentic loop and
it's doing side effects. while it's
producing the answer, it might empty
your bank account. It might delete your
files and then it gives you a safe
answer. But who cares about the safe
answer when all my files are gone,
right? So that's why I say it's a giant
leap for for chaos. Um, again, sorry
this is engineering conference. Let's
look at this type IO. And you don't have
to understand it, but just see that
there's a type there called real world.
Yes, lean this esoteric thing has a type
called real world. And why is that?
Because something of type IO will mutate
the real world. So it warns you don't
use this because it can make
irreversible side effects
and like deleting your files. So Solomon
hikes um last year this conference
called an AI agent an LLM that's
wrecking its environment in a loop. And
I think he's a hero. I don't know if
Solomon is here this year, but I think
he should he deserves deserved a round
of applause. Um, because I think this is
the right definition of an AI agent. Um,
by the way, this was one of the pictures
that I had trouble to generate because
it it clearly depicts violence and so
it's kind of an unsafe thing, right? I I
have a picture that depicts violence.
Um, so are we doomed? Well, our agents
have access to private data. They have
untrusted content like the prompt
injections and now we give them tools.
Simon Wilson calls this the lethal
trifecta. And what can we do about this?
Well, um I don't know if you've seen the
Dutch soccer fans, they have the famous
march where they say to the left, left,
left, or to the left, left, to the
right, right, right. This is actually
the secret to solving this problem. The
Dutch team got eliminated yesterday, so
you have to see me do the dance. Um, but
all that we're doing is we're pushing
this IO to the right, to the right. And
what you now see is that the tool belt
of Claude goes to the left, to the left,
and suddenly Claude is a nice puppy
again because instead of executing the
agentic loop, it creates a plan and
says, "Here is the plan to do the
agentic loop." And now Bernie will take
that plan and we'll execute it. And we
all trust Bernie, right? Bernie is a
good guy. All right. So just to kind
like show it here. So in some sense what
we're doing, we're airgapping the
agentic loop from the agent. So we don't
let the agent run the agentic loop
before the agent run it. We want to be
able to check it.
All right. Now the problem is that if
you get a value of type IO of A
um that's a really a black box and the
lean manual says that is a black box you
cannot reason about it. So even though
Claude now gives us this plan, there's
we cannot look into this plan. Lean
doesn't allow us to do it. By the way,
this is another picture, right? That
that promotes drugs use and the model
let me do it. I'm a good hacker. You
know, I can just make it do forbidden
pictures. Um so if we look at the lean
again, what you see here is that the
model now computes an answer, but it
doesn't compute the answer, right? it
creates an an IO of answer. So this is a
plan to generate the answer and then it
creates a proof that this um that that
plan is safe. And the nice thing is here
that you can get at that proof without
having to run the agentic loop. But
unfortunately as I said like this proof
if it's like something of type IO it's
useless. Ah What can we do about
that? So, I keep kind like moving you
guys forward and then we never get to
the final answer.
But there's one less trick and you see
the the researchers here are becoming
more much more sophisticated. Instead of
the flat 2D ones in the past, now
they're like real people. Um, and what
is better than creating a plan of type
IO of A, it's creating a program that
represents an expression of type IO of
A. Oo, that sounds very meta, right? Um,
not meta in terms of meta. I don't think
they're very meta, but meta in the terms
of like, you know, like meta, you you
know, you know what I mean? Um, and
again, it's a small step for a
signature, but a giant leap for safety
because now the model returns an
expression, a program that represents a
computation. If you know link or C, you
will recognize that this is one of the
tricks that I always use. Um, if you
know lisp, this is of course second
nature for you. Um, I cannot like you
know have a talk without talking about
monet. So if you ask yourself what is
this expression thing? Well that's just
a monet but it's not just a monet. It's
a free monet. What is a free monet? It's
a monet that loves tie dice.
Um and now if you look at the the
signature of the the um property to
prove that something is safe, you see
that it takes an expression of a
computation that returns an answer. Um
and if you have taken any compiler
course in college, you know that it's
trivial to do data flow analysis, type
checking and so on on programs, right?
So now we're safe. We're home safe. And
Jeff Huntley wanted to remind you that
we can solve the trifecta problem just
by doing taint analysis on these
expression on these programs. Okay, this
is the last code I will show you because
I'm running out of time. But just want
to show you here that you know you now
have a simple inductive recursive
interpreter for this language and you
have a simple inductive proof and the
models can generate these proofs. So to
um recapitulate like the summarize what
we did is we went from unhinged LLMs
that were like you know could give bad
answers to ones that were aligned. Then
we saw how tools wrecked it. Then we
solved that by deferring execution. So
by air gapping the LLM from the tools
and then the real solution was to refy
the plan into a program and a program
that we could prove to be safe. Now you
would say Eric, oh you're a genius. No,
I'm my brain is the size of a peanut.
This is something that's called proof
carrying code and it was invented by
academics in the 1990s and I'm just
stealing it. Um, all right. At the
higher level, if you didn't understand
the code, three points.
Agents are dangerous until proven safe.
So, you should never ever let your
agents do something unless you can
absolutely prove that it's safe. And the
language that this agents generated was
not designed like normal users don't
understand free monet.
It's a machine that consumes it. It's a
machine that generates it. It's a
machine that proves it. So, we should
stop designing languages for humans. And
it's all basic, only requires
programming 101. Um, do we go? All
right, that's it. Um, the end of the
story. If you're curious to play with
this, a bunch of academics in particular
now that I'm in from Harvard have
implemented this. It's it's there on
GitHub. It uses a slightly different
language than what I use. It uses also a
slightly different language than free
monet but the idea is the same. The
language doesn't matter. It's it's the
um the principle that matters. So
hopefully you've learned tonight that it
is actually possible to have
mathematically proven safe agentic
compute and it only requires very
elementary type systems and programming
language machinery. Thank you so much.
Please welcome to the stage the machine
learning engineer model behavior at
cursor Lee Robinson.
All right.
Hey everyone. Uh I'm excited to be here.
Excited to be back at AI engineer and
talk a little bit about how we're
training models at cursor. So how we
train the models and also how the model
learns to train itself or recursive
model improvement. So our goal at Cursor
is to build the best possible AI models,
which might make sense. You might have
heard of this equation of if we just
give the models more compute, we can get
a better model out. And I think this is
a helpful simplification of the problem,
but I want to actually click in a few
layers deeper in the talk today and talk
about all the different pieces that go
into training these models. So we can
think about this loop. We put a model
out into the world and then we get
feedback from you all when you use the
model. what goes well or places we can
improve. We use that to scale and
improve the data that we do for the next
round of training. And we also then
increase the amount of compute and scale
up training overall to make a new model.
And this is a loop that can just go over
and over again. However, if you see my
helpful snail or uh turtle to bunny
meter down in the bottom right, it's
pretty slow. This is going to be a
serial process and you can only do in
this instance one big run at a time. So,
we want to make this a little bit
faster. But I'll actually go another
layer deeper and add some more color
here. There's actually two loops, the
outer loop and the inner loop. On the
outer loop, we have the feedback coming
in, but we also have data like online
metrics. So, running AB tests and seeing
what users prefer a different checkpoint
of a model. That's going to then flow
into hopefully making better highquality
evals that help ensure we're getting the
right behaviors we want out of the
model. and also being able to create
much more difficult problems for the
models to try to solve where we then can
kind of shape the rewards that we want
to get during training. So we want to
climb that inner loop as well.
We have been training models for about a
year at the large scale at cursor and I
want to talk about some of our progress
so far. So we put out composer 2.5 in
May and it's now the most popular model
in cursor which is exciting and we
scaled up training here quite a bit by
generating more RL environments trying
out some new methods for learning and
also just making more ambitious problems
for the models to solve and the results
have been pretty promising so far. Like
I mentioned this is still a new effort
for us. ML has really been in the blood
of cursor since the start where we were
training more specialized models for
things like tab or code autocomplete but
really in the past year we've staffed up
and built a team with ambitions to train
you know state-of-the-art models and
we've made some pretty good progress
just in the last 12 months people like
composer right now I think because it is
both fast and pretty smart and also cost
effective and as we've heard from other
speakers today I think there is a space
in the market right now for that type of
model in addition to also having the
most uh intelligent models in the world
and we think it's important to have a
good selection of both of these type of
things. So composer we think is serving
a good niche here
and when we released it we were honestly
pretty impressed with some of the public
evals. It did a little better than we
expected on uh artificial analysis. It
was a a pretty modest jump. However,
there were a lot of behaviors that we
found that we really wanted to improve
for the next version of the model.
Notably we wanted to have a much bigger
and smarter model. We wanted to control
every aspect of training. So ideally
doing a full pre-train from scratch
versus the previous open source base of
Kimmy that we were using. We wanted to
infuse new data so that we can make the
model great outside of more things than
just coding but more of a general model
and then also just scale up every part
of the training process. More data, more
compute and really pushing RL as far as
we can.
So first I want to talk about improving
the outer loop and then we'll drill
drill into the inner loop.
If you haven't used cursor in a while,
you might think about it as this IDE or
tab autocomplete thing. And in reality,
uh the vast vast majority of our revenue
today comes from agent usage. And that
means that all of the data inside of
cursor is also coming from agent usage.
And we can use that to train better
models. So for example, we kind of have
two different buckets of feedback. On
the external side, when you're using the
product, you can thumbs up or thumbs
down different responses and give
feedback. And we use that to then
classify places where, for example,
composer maybe doesn't do as good of a
job and we want to improve that for
future versions. And then also on the
internal side, we're heavy dog foodters
of our models and our products. We're uh
very critical and want to make sure
we're using good models and we of course
use them all day. So we have a good mix
of manual reports, automated reports
internally, and just lots of ways we're
trying to get the best behaviors out of
the model. And if we do that over and
over and over again, we can get better
models out into the world. But really,
the place where we can make massive
speed ups is improving that inner loop.
So just to zoom back in on that again,
we have these high quality evals. we
have these very difficult training tasks
and we want to climb these evals as
quickly as possible so that we know if
we make a new checkpoint of the model
we're actually making progress on the
things that we want to measure. So for
example some of the evals that we have
introduced or have already had are
things like understanding what you
really meant when you have included
maybe 50 skill files. it gets kind of
hard for the models to figure out your
actual intent or trying to figure out
the line between when you push back and
ask the user to clarify a question
versus when you trust their judgment and
they said no I really wanted to do this
there's a kind of a fine line and people
have different preferences so a lot of
these eval are trying to shape a lot of
those different behaviors and also model
what it feels like to be a software
engineer we ask the models to do really
ambitious things like hey we just had
this sev could you have actually went
and read through all the data dog logs
read through Slack, read through notion,
and came to the same conclusion or the
same fix that we did. Uh, and a lot of
models are just not very good at this
today. And that uh backs a lot of the
evals that we create based off these
software engineering tasks.
Now, as the models get smarter, they
also find very creative ways to hack the
evals. So, as we've been training for a
new version of our model, we also
noticed there was some interesting
reward hacking going on. Um the models
learned how to really just go back in
the git history and figure out if there
was a solution or a part of a solution.
Uh they figured out good ways to go
online and if it was a public eval just
see if there was a fork of the eval
anywhere they could look up the results
from and this affected our own models as
well as other models. So, we did a
little research here and found that if
we did just a couple small changes on
measuring public uh evals, we could have
a pretty noticeable uh change in the
scores that were reported. So, first
off, we would delete the git history at
the start and we could restore it at the
end so that wouldn't affect the run. And
then also, we can have a network allow
list or just some basic controls on the
sites that the uh the agent can go and
talk to. And I think this is helpful for
public eval which often are the things
that people are using to calibrate
whether a model is good when it gets
released. You know, you see that big
chart of all the benchmark numbers. But
this isn't really a true test of what it
feels like to use these models. Like in
reality, you have access to the
internet. You can do whatever you want
in the internet with these models. And
you're definitely using git. So you want
to be able to test the true capabilities
of the models. And that's why we have
cursor bench. We have this private eval
set that is mostly made up of things
that happen in our codebase which is
held out from the eval so we ensure that
the models aren't trained on it and it's
based on those real world engineering
tasks.
Now another part of climbing that inner
loop is trying to make very very
difficult problems for the models to
solve. As the models get better, you
might have noticed if you're looking at
an eval and all the models are scoring
like 90%. It's probably time to retire
that eval and try to get something more
difficult and that the half-life of
those eval will go down as the models
get smarter. And to do this, it requires
a lot of things. It requires some amount
of researcher taste and what these
problems should be. It requires a lot of
compute. So you can try a lot of
different ideas. Some of them are going
to work, some of them are not going to
work. And there's a race against the
clock here. So you want to try as many
in parallel as you can. Just to put a
example to this of one of those type of
problems. Let's say that on the left for
example you have each one of those
squares is representing files in a
codebase. And then on the bottom you
have the tests. One thing you can do is
generate a very complex application or
environment for a very ambitious
application or task and then you can
delete part of it. You can delete a
feature. You can delete files and the
test will then fail. And then you can
ask these models to go and basically
figure out however it wants to
reimplement that feature and it has a
very verifiable goal of all the test
passing to be able to get some reward
back at the end. And this actually works
out pretty well and has allowed us to
scale making these uh interesting
problems for the you know the frontier
models to solve. Additionally, we have
found some new learning methods which I
personally think are really interesting.
The first one is you can teach the model
to kind of coach itself. So for example,
if you think about an RL roll out or a
conversation with an agent, this can be
hundreds of thousands of tokens. And if
you think about trying to grade at the
end of this where the model made a right
decision or a wrong decision, it's kind
of hard, right? You have all these tool
calls, you have thinking blocks. It's
pretty hard to figure out where to
assign that credit to the root issue. So
the more precise we can be, the better.
You know, was it one of the tool calls?
Was it a thinking block? It's pretty
hard. And one thing that we've done to
improve this process is something called
textual feedback. So we want to zoom in
on one specific part of that roll out.
And ideally we can hint or kind of nudge
to the model, hey by the way here's a
way you could improve and then look at
the probabilities again and nudge up the
ones we want or you know downweight the
ones we don't want. Uh for example on
the left you have this student case
where you have a roll out and it tries
to call a tool and the tool call fails.
it should have known that this tool was
there but it just decided not to work
for this time. We can then use a teacher
or we can use the same model but we
include this hint and we say hey as a
reminder you have all of these tools
available and then we like I mentioned
we can just upvote or upwe the
probabilities such that we can get the
behaviors that we want and this example
is with you know adherence to tool
calling but we can really use this for
anything. We can use this for making
style changes. We can use this to get
any behavior we want to influence the
models during RL. And this has proven to
be uh very valuable for us. Now, how we
scale these loops both the inner and
outer loops also comes down to scaling
the amount of compute we have. Uh we
announced back in March that we are
partnering with SpaceX to get access to
a lot more compute and this allows us to
train very large models from scratch.
not only the product but also the models
down to the supercomputers or the data
centers where we're training these
models with Colossus and then
increasingly to the chips as well with
Terraab and that just allows you to do
some pretty interesting things in taking
advantage of that full stack. If you
haven't seen Colossus, I think it's
really interesting. Personally, they
were able to train uh or able to build
out this supercomputer in 122 days for
100,000 GPUs and then added another
100,000 GPUs in 92 days. So, very
impressive. I had to do some pretty
creative things to get this done and
kind of take over this old factory in
Memphis. And it's kind of shown they can
stand up these data centers really
quick, which is of course very helpful
for our model training efforts. And for
Terrafab, I think it's also very
interesting that they're building their
own chips. I mean, to put the size of
this into perspective, if you just think
about how large this physical structure
is, I know you're all thinking it. It's
like the size of a 100 bies, which for
my for my folks from the south, you
know, we love bies. I'm not even from
the south and I love bies. This is like
the crown jewel of the south, the
premium gas station experience. It's
it's a lot of stuff, but that just puts
it into perspective, the size. So, going
back to this equation at the start, more
compute in, you get a better model out.
I think it's sometimes hard to
understand what does that compute even
do? Where where do you actually put that
compute? Let's say you have access to a
bunch of GPUs. Like, what do I do with
it? And I think it's helpful just to
step through a few of the things. Of
course, first you have actually serving
the model to end users, but also you're
serving up different checkpoints
internally. You're running different AB
tests. You're trying different
variations of the model. You have the
actual training process itself, but also
the sub pieces from pre-training to
mid-training to RL. And then also you're
then training these derivative models to
do other parts of the process like
climbing the inner loop, which we'll
talk about here in a second. you have
the data generation and the reward
generation. So creating those really
ambitious problems that I talked about
or when you're doing eval trying to
create these rubrics for whether it was
successful or not and give it some grade
and then actually judging those scores.
Um you also have the eval themselves.
Ideally on every new checkpoint of the
model you want to be continuously
running evals to see if you're improving
in the places that you're measuring as
well as just developing new evals all
the time. Like I mentioned, the the
halflife of these evals, as models get
smarter, you need to be really
continuously investing in making these
better. Um, and there's just the
research itself. Ideally, you want to
free up your team of researchers to be
able to tweak the knobs to try ambitious
ideas, experiment with new things, as
well as do side runs. And this all is
compute that needs to be, you know,
allocated for somewhere. But what that
ultimately turns into is ideally you can
get in a state where you have multiple
large training runs happening at the
same time where the researchers are
unblocked and they can go try their
research and you're still kind of
contributing back to this core flywheel.
And if you do that and we revisit our
speed meter in the bottom right, you're
starting to get to a point where you're
getting something that's like RSI or
recursive model uh in improvement here
where the models are improving much much
faster.
Then the bottleneck becomes how do you
scale the folks actually training the
models? How can you automate the more
monotonous parts of machine learning or
research so that you can get these
useful models out into the world? And
this is where I think it starts to get
really interesting.
If you think about the model as Mario,
if you give it some tools, all of a
sudden you're more like a Super Mario.
And if you give it great context,
everything about your organization, all
the places that you work, you connect it
to all your different tools. That
context kind of turns it into the fire
Mario or the Super Fire Mario. And just
to kind of further prove this point and
add a few examples here, I think for
tools, a lot of these are pretty
obvious. The models can write code with
a with a harness. They can you run shell
commands. They can look things up on the
web. But I think increasingly even with
these primitive versions of memory, like
writing files. These last three, I
think, are just starting to become
really popular and uh more useful, which
is the models and the harnesses should
be able to use a computer exactly like
you would. It doesn't need to be just
inside of your guey or your CLI. It
should be able to control every part of
your computer. You as a human on Slack
or on your tool is basically subscribing
to Slack threads in your head so that
you can follow them for updates.
Ideally, you kind of want the models to
just follow a thread and then ping you
if it needs something. And just like we
have code bases that store the code,
increasingly as these models do more
work for us, they kind of need like a
Dropbox for themselves. Where do you
store the slide decks? Right? You could
put that in code, I guess, but I think
there's an increasingly uh new
opportunity here. And then for context,
of course, you have all the different
places you can hook up with MCPS, Slack,
and notion, linear data dog, etc., and
the codebase itself. But I think these
last two are really interesting, which
is increasingly we find that you have a
human working with a team of agents, and
then the agents can start working with
the other agents. It's a little meta,
but I think this will be a big trend in
the next six months. Just to kind of put
an example to this, we've created these
tools and these systems where
researchers can run experiments directly
from Slack. We want to avoid this state
of being bottlenecked on humans
launching and reviewing and babysitting
runs. And we actually have an entire
team just working on automating every
part of the research work that isn't uh
you know isn't freeing up the
researchers time to work on their most
ambitious ideas. So every person on the
ML team gets access to this fleet of
agents. They can basically train models
directly from Slack.
And a few people on the team have taken
this very far where they have these
agent systems that can go and do a lot
of work for them. Maybe they want to go
create a bunch of very difficult
problems for the models to uh try and
solve or they want to create a whole
bunch of new evals based on some good
ideas that they have and they just want
to let the models cook and go work for a
while. But if something gets wrong, if
the infrastructure goes down, if there's
some blip somewhere, the model can
message them on Slack or just page them
directly and say, "Hey, this is really
important. You don't want to lose six
hours because your info was down. Like,
you should go check this out right now."
And this like humanto aagent
coordination I think is just starting to
be figured out and it will be an
increasing trend.
The last bit here is that the model is
learning to train the next model and it
it it's a little hard to wrap your brain
around. The way I like to think about it
is every time you release a new version
of this intelligence then you can create
or distill these derivative versions
that you use to speed up other parts of
the training process both the inner loop
and the outer loop. So when you're
trying to do your evals for example, you
have different models for doing the
judging and you have uh your reward
models as well. So when you make the top
level mo model smarter, it actually
improves the whole system. If you think
about the multiple training runs diagram
I showed, I'm going to throw on a a new
meter here, which is the brain to galaxy
brain meter or the intelligence meter.
You are bottlenecked here on the
smartest model in your system. And if
the smartest model then creates those
derivative models, when you can improve
that, you can actually make every single
one of these loops much much better
because you've raised the kind of floor
of the intelligence. And this is how you
start to get to something that feels
like this recursive self-improvement,
this model that is just improving all
the time on your behalf. And especially
as we bring more and more compute
online, I think this is really going to
help us scale our model efforts and
hopefully make even more useful models
for you all to use. Uh to conclude, I'd
just like to thank everyone on the
cursor engineering and ML and research
teams who have been uh working hard to
get a new model out to you all here very
soon. Hopefully very very soon uh that
we think will be a pretty notable
improvement over our last model. And
we're excited for you to try it. Thank
you so much.
Ladies and gentlemen, please put your
hands together and welcome back our MC,
member of the technical staff at
Keycard, Ally Wow.
Thank you.
Wow, what an amazing first day of
content here at AI Engineer. I think the
biggest takeaway for me today after
listening to all the amazing talks on
software factories is that the raw
materials for software factories exist
right our context windows have gotten
larger we have better memory model
vision is improved we can actually
verify the work we've got better AI
security best practices now to
understand patterns around agent
identity and access control
but we have to have the discipline to be
able to wield all of the raw materials
correctly in order to build software
factories that actually work and that
really resonated with me in some of the
talks I heard this afternoon such as
Dex's talk where I mentioned that one of
the takeaways for me was that
engineering as a practice is absolutely
not dead. We might not be writing all of
the code anymore and agents might be
writing the code but engineering has to
be part of that loop. Um especially if
you want to write software factories
that actually work and don't produce
slop. So I hope everyone learned a lot
today. I know I certainly did. And thank
you so much for your curiosity, your
optimism, your energy, and we'll see you
back here tomorrow. Thank you so much.
This is our third year doing the world's
fair. We have so many events.
You are helping us figure out what the
future of engineering should look like.
Down,
hey,
hey, hey, hey, hey.
Come on, go
go go.
Hey, hey, hey.